ROLL.
MITCHELL HERE WARLOCK.
NIELSEN.
ROTH.
SKINNER [inaudible] TEN BIGELOW
[inaudible]
HE'S.
MCCARTY.
WEBER HERE YOU THE TIME ABOUT IT.
OKAY **** GOOD AFTERNOON ARE WE
ARE HERE FOR DAY THREE YES.
OF BUDGET CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
WE'RE GOING TO PICK UP WHERE WE
LEFT OFF ON FRIDAY AFTERNOON
WHICH IS -- CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION ISSUE
SEVENTEEN WILDFIRES IN CLIMATE
CHANGE PAGE.
TWENTY BECAUSE HAVE THE LA --
AND FINANCE YOU JOIN US AT THE
TABLE.
WELCOME BACK EVERYBODY.
COLLEAGUES -- AND FOR THOSE WHO
ARE WATCHING AND LISTENING OUR
EXPECTATION TODAY IS TO GET
THROUGH HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES THAT'S OUR BIGGEST.
FACTION OF CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
AGENDA FULLY ANTICIPATE PERHAPS
GOING LATE -- SENATOR TING AND I
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE.
A DINNER BREAK WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT TIME YET NOT A LONG.
ONE LIKE MAYBE FIFTEEN TWENTY
MINUTES -- AND FOOD WILL BE
BROUGHT IN HOSTED BY SENATOR
SEIZING THE BREATH EXCUSE ME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING AND I FOR
MEMBERS OF THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE.
AND STAFF.
BUT AT SOME POINT FOR THE
GENERAL AUDIENCE WILL BE TAKING
A FIFTEEN TWENTY MINUTE BREAK
FOR DINNER -- SO WE CAN PLOW
THROUGH -- SERVICES WITH THAT
ISSUE SEVENTEEN WILDFIRES IN
CLIMATE CHANGE GOOD AFTERNOON LA
JOH.
ROSS BROWN WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE SO THE ISSUE
BEFORE YOU -- COMBINES THREE
SEPARATE PROPOSALS FROM THE
GOVERNOR RELATED -- TO THE P. C.
OVERSIGHT OVER UTILITY WILD FIRE
MITIGATION MOSTLY IMPLEMENTATION
OF SB -- NINE OH ONE FROM LAST
YEAR.
SO THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED A TOTAL
OF SIXTY FOUR ONGOING POSITIONS
AT THE P. YOU SEE TO EMPLOYMENT
VARIOUS ACTIVITIES RELATED SB
NINE A ONE IMPLEMENTATION
INCLUDING WILDFIRE ADMITTED
MITIGATION PLAN.
REVIEW AT THE P. C. -- ALSO
PROPOSED THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME CONTRACTING
FUNDING FOR A COUPLE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF ACTIVITIES -- TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR BOOTS
ON THE GROUND INSPECTION OF I
OWE YOU WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
PLAN IMPLEMENTATION.
AND THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS --
FOR TO DEVELOP WILDFIRE POLICY
AT THE PC.
INCLUDING A LONG TERM VISION FOR
A RISK REDUCTION ESTABLISHING
METRICS FOR ABOUT YOU ATION AND
CLARIFYING VARIOUS REGULATIONS.
SO THE SENATE APPROVED FUNDING
FOR ALL OF THE POSITIONS FOR TWO
YEARS INSTEAD OF ON GOING AND AS
WELL AS PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
REQUIRING -- THE PC TO REPORT ON
OUTCOMES AND OF THE CONTRACTS
AND LESSONS LEARNED FROM THEIR
CONTRACTS.
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED FUNDING
FOR THIRTY EIGHT OF THE
POSITIONS AS TO YOUR LIMITED
TERM AND THE REST OF THE MONGO
IN.
pBILL LANGUAGE TO ESTABLISH A
STRUCTURE TO SUPPORT STATE
OVERSIGHT OF WILD FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS.
SO THE DIFFERENCES ARE THE
FUNDING LIMITED TERM VERSUS LONG
GOING AND THE LANGUAGE
DIFFERENCES WE DO RECOMMEND THE
ASSEMBLY VERSION OF THE FUNDING --
WE DO THINK THAT MUCH OF THE
WORKLOAD IS ONGOING AS WE THINK
IT'S REASONABLE TO APPROVE AT
LEAST A PORTION OF THE POSITIONS
AND THE FUNDING.
AS ONGOING -- WE THINK BOTH THE
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY LANGUAGE --
FOR BUDGET BILL AND TRAILER BILL
ARE REASONABLE AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THE THE COMMITTEE
AS AS DISCUSSIONS PROGRESS
APPRECIATE THAT GOOD AFTERNOON
FINANCE.
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE APPROVAL
OF BOTH HOUSES OF THE SHORT TERM
RESOURCES WHICH WE THINK ARE
DEAR TO AFFECT IMMEDIATE NEEDS --
WHILE WE BELIEVE THESE RESOURCES
ARE ON GOING IN NATURE WE ARE OF
COURSE OPEN FOR CAUGHT WITH A
CONVERSATION WITH LEGISLATORS
AND STAFF IN THE UPCOMING TWO
YEARS IN TERMS OF HOW BEST TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT AND REFINING OUR
PRIORITIES.
AND WE'RE COMFORTABLE WITH
EITHER APPROACH -- WITH THE
COUNTY -- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE CONFIRMING TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS INDEED
COMFORTABLE.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS -- A SKINNER
FILED BY MISTER NELSON -- IN
LOOKING AT THE ITEMS SORRY --
THEY'RE TRYING TO SEE THE
DIFFERENCE [inaudible]
THE DID THE GOVERNOR'S --
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RECOMMENDATION
HAVE ALL OF THE POSITIONS ON
GOING OR JUST SOME.
SO I HAVE IS I CAN SPEAK TO THAT
PROPOSAL SO ALL OF OUR POSITIONS
ARE ON GOING ALL OKAY.
AND THEN -- THE ASSEMBLY MADE
SOME FOR LIMITED TERM OKAY
[inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
AND I'M I'M NOT NECESSARILY
GOING TO OPINE ABOUT WHICH
SHOULD OR SHOULDN'T BE LIMITED
TERM BUT IT SEEMED TO ME WHEN I
LOOKED AT SOME OF THE DETAIL.
THAT THE POSITIONS IN DAY PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE OF THE PC THAT.
THE NATURE OF SOME OF WHAT WE'RE
DOING IN THIS.
IS.
IS CLEARLY ON GOING [inaudible]
AND AND THEIR ROLE IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THESE THINGS ARE BEING
DONE IN A WAY THE PROTECT RATE
PAYERS.
SO IT SEEMS TO ME THAT AT LEAST
THOSE POSITIONS IN THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE SHOULD BE ON
GOING -- AND I HAVE A LITTLE
LESS -- DETAILER INFORMATION
ABOUT THE OTHER POSITIONS SO I
WON'T NECESSARILY OPINE ON THE
BENEFITS ARE MERITS OF SHORT
TERM OR ON GOING BUT IT SEEMS
LIKE.
THE THAT THE RULE -- THAT IF WE
LOOK AT THE LEGISLATION AND THE
ROLE THAT WERE EXPECTING FOR THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE TO PLAY
THAT THOSE SHOULD BE ON GOING
[inaudible]
CENTER NIELSEN.
WHAT IS THE FORM OF REPORTING TO
THE LEGISLATURE WILL THIS BE A
LETTER TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET CMMITTEE OR?
AND HOW FREQUENTLY WILL LIVE
REPORTING BE TO THE LEGISLATURE --
FOR V. S. SENATE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE IS THE IT WOULD BE
REPORT. TO THE LEGISLATURE I
BELIEVE BY MARCH FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY AND THEN ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER.
THAT'S IMPORTANT THE FORM OF THE
COMMUNICATION.
SO WE WILL HAVE COMMITTEES WERE
AND WE CAN.
HERE AND EXAMINE THE ISSUE.
BUT WILL ALSO HAVE A DOCUMENT
TWO IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU SEE NONE WILL HOLD AN
ITEM OPEN.
I WOULD ASK THAT BOTH THE LA L.
IN FINANCE.
PRESENT THE FOLLOWING ISSUES ALL
TOGETHER ON ISSUES.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN TWENTY AND
TWENTY TWO PLEASE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST
COMPUTERS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
ISSUE EIGHTEEN IS THE FOR HILL
BOULEVARD LINK A BIKE WAY AND
PEDESTRIAN GREENBELTS -- THE
SENATE APPROVED THREE HUNDRED
AND NINETY THOUSAND DOLLARS ROM
THE STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT TO
FIND THE DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION
OF A BICYCLE PEDESTRIAN.
AND LANDSCAPE IMPROVEMENTS ALONG
FOOTHILL BOULEVARD IN A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ON THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE GOVERNOR HAD NO PROPOSAL
ON THIS ITEM.
ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN THE
BURBANK TO ANAHEIM METROLINK
CORRIDOR.
ARE THE SENATE APPROVED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION ACCOUNT FOR
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS ALONG THE
BURBANK ANAHEIM CORD OR AT THE
METROLINK SYSTEM.
THE GOVERNOR AND THE ASSEMBLY
HAD NO PROPOSAL ON THIS ITEM.
FOR ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY THE PALO
ALTO GRADE SEPARATION PROJECT
THE SENATE APPROVED ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE STATE HIGHWAY
ACCOUNT TO FIND THE
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW OF A GRADE
SEPARATION PROJECT. FOR THREE
I'M CALTRAIN CREATE CALTRAIN AT
GRADE CROSSINGS.
ARE THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
GOVERNOR HAD NO PROPOSAL.
ON THIS ITEM.
AND THEN SKIPPING TO ISSUE
TWENTY TWO ZERO THE STATE ROUTE
ONE FIFTY SIX CASTROVILLE SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS THE SENATE APPROVED.
TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN STATE
HIGHWAY ACCOUNT FRIENDS FOR
RIGHT AWAY PURCHASE FOR
ADDITIONAL SAFETY INVESTMENTS
ALONG.
THE AS STATE ROUTE ONE FIFTY SIX
RIGHT OF WAY THE GOVERNOR AND
THE ASSEMBLY HAD NO TIME
PROPOSAL ON THIS ITEM.
THANK YOU FINANCE. FOR THESE
PROJECTS -- NONE OF THEM ARE IN
OUR BUDGET AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THE BEST WAY TO ACCESS THEM IS
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION'S
PROJECTS WASHER SELECTION
PRIORITIZATION.
PROCESS AND GIVEN THAT THOSE
FUNDS ARE PROGRAMMED AND THERE
IS A PROCESS FOR THOSE -- ANY OF
THESE -- PROJECTSIF FUNDED HERE
WOULD NECESSITATE TAKING AWAY
FUNDING FOR OTHER PROJECTS AND
THAT FUNDING HAS ALREADY ALREADY
BEEN PROGRAM SO FOR THAT REASON.
WE SUPPORT OUR CURRENT NAY
REVISION PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU.
SINCE COMMENTS FROM THE DANCE.
FOR THE NIELSEN.
WELL IN THE LIGHT OF THE NORMAL
PROCESS IT WOULD SEEM THAT THESE
BUT NOT.
RISE TO THE FRONT OF THE LINE
COULD COULDN'T DATE AND YOUR
NORMAL PROCEDURES AS YOU DO YOUR
TRANSPORTATION PLANS SIMPLY FOR
THE END TO THE NORMAL SCHEDULE
THAT THEY WOULD -- WITHOUT
SKIPPING TO THE FRONT ISN'T THAT.
THE NORMAL WAY IT GOES THAT'S
CORRECT THERE IS A PROCESS TO IT.
TAX FOR INSPIRATION YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
BACKTRACK TO ISSUE TWENTY ONE ON
PAGE.
TWENTY FOUR ON CALIFORNIA
SHORTLINE RAILROAD
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENT ACT
OF TWENTY NINETEEN LA -- PLEASE.
THE SENATE APPROVED SEVEN POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
TRADE CORRIDOR IMPROVEMENT FIND
FOR INVESTMENTS IN SHORTLINE
RAILROAD INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
CONSISTENT WITH THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA STATE RAIL
PLAN.
IN PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO IMPLEMENT THE
CALIFORNIA SHORTLINE RAILROAD
INFRASTRUCTURE ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN AND THE GOVERNOR AND
THE ASSEMBLY HAD NO PROPOSAL ON
THIS ITEM.
FINANCE A HERE TO OUR THE
PROJECT IS NOT IN OUR BUDGET FOR
SIMILAR REASONS.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
SENATOR -- MORLOCK.
MADAME CHAIR.
THIS DOES NOT SEEM TO GO THROUGH
THE CDC THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION IS
THAT CORRECT. TWO THERE'S A
SEPARATE OUT OF LET MY
COLLEAGUES SPEAK TO THAT YES.
SO -- SO WHAT THIS DOES IS NO
THERE IS STILL THE PROJECT
SELECTION -- PROCESS THROUGH THE
CDC IN THIS CASE -- THERE'S ALSO
THE TRADE KREIDER IMPROVEMENT
FUND AND WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT
RESTRICTIONS ON THAT PROCESS AS
WELL.
OKAY I GUESS I JUST HAVE ONE
TECHNICAL QUESTION AND THAT IS.
WE'VE BEEN DISCOURAGED FROM
DOING BILLS.
TO ENCOURAGE THE BUILDING OF A
NEW ROAD.
AND NOW WE'RE GETTING BIT OF
BUDGET BILLS TO MODIFY OR
IMPROVE ROADS.
AND IT ALL SEEMS TO GO THROUGH
THE CDC HOW DOES A LEGISLATURE.
LEGISLATE POOR WORK WITH THE CDC
THE CHANGE THE PROCESS OF WHAT
SELECTED WHEN [inaudible]
I'M.
STEVE ALSO PART IN A FINANCE SO
THE THE LEGISLATURE IS
REPRESENTED ON THIS THE THE
CDC'S BOARDS SO THERE'S TWO
THERE'S TWO BOARD MEMBERS ON THE
BOARD THAT ARE PART.
OF THE REPRESENTED IN GETS HERE
THE CASE SO.
THROUGH THAT AND THEN JUST
THROUGH THE PUBLIC PROCESS --
YOU KNOW THE THEY HAVE REGULAR
MEETINGS REGULAR HEARINGS WHERE
THEY ADOPT -- WHERE THEY ADOPT
THE THE PROGRAMS AND A AND THE
DIFFERENT OF FUNDING -- PROGRAM
SO THROUGH BOTH OF THOSE THAT'S
NORMALLY WHERE THE INPUT WOULD
BE HEARD.
BUT THAT'S WHERE WE SHOULD REFER
THESE BILLS THEN AS A
RECOMMENDATION SIGNATURE PROCESS
STEP COMING.
THROUGH THIS DOOR GO THROUGH
THAT ONE CORRECT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MANAGER VERY
WELCOME ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SEEING NONE WILL HOLD THAT ITEM
OPEN.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE TWENTY THREE
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROPOSALS.
LA -- SEAN MIGHT WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE MILLION IN THESE
REVENUE BOND FINANCING.
FROM THE PUBLIC BUILDINGS
CONSTRUCTION FUND FOR CAPITAL UP
LATE PROJECTS TO REPLACE C. H.
B. AREA OFFICES.
AND HEY WORD EL CENTRO IN SAN
BERNADINO.
BOTH HOUSES REJECTED THE LEASE
REVENUE BOND FINANCING FOR ALL
THREE PROJECTS AND BOTH HOUSES
ALSO PRE PAYS YOU GO FUNDING --
FROM THE MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNT
FOR THE EL CENTRO AREA OFFICE
REPLACEMENT.
THE SENATE APPROVED A PAY AS YOU
GO FUNDING FOR THE HAYWARD
PROJECT AND THE ASSEMBLY
PREPARES YOU GOT FUNDING FOR THE
SAN BERNADINO PROJECT.
SO -- DATE CONFERENCE ISSUES
CASH FUNDING FOR SAN BERNADINO
IN A WORD.
THANK YOU FINANCE WILL MAKE
THREE BRIEF POINTS OUT FIRST --
WE BELIEVE THAT WE SEVENTY BOND
FUNDING IS APPROPRIATE FOR THESE
TYPES OF PROJECTS AND CURRENTLY
STATEWIDE THERE OVER A HUNDRED
PROJECTS THAT USE.
THIS TYPE OF FINANCING.
THE SECOND POINT IS WE BELIEVE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
MAKES SENSE BECAUSE IF WE RELY
ON CASH FINANCING THAT PUTS
ADDITIONAL PRESSURE ON THE MOTOR
VEHICLE COUNT IN THE SHORT TERM
AND I KNOW WE WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES AND JUST A LITTLE BIT.
BUT MAINTAINING THE HEALTH OF
THAT ACCOUNT IS AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION FOR ALL OF US.
INTO THE THIRD POINT IS WE
BELIEVE THAT USING WAYS REVENUE
BOND FINANCING IS A WAY TO
ENSURE THE SOLVENCY OF THAT
ACCOUNT WHILE MAINTAINING THE
NEED -- TO UPGRADE AND BUILT CHP
FACILITIES.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS ARMS RACE.
YEAH JUST -- THERE'S IT SEEMS
LIKE THE ISSUE IS A WORD ALL
CENTER IN SAN MARINO AND THE
SENATE SAYS NO SAMBAR DINO WHICH
I DON'T PARTICULARLY LIKE -- IN
THE ASSEMBLY OF COURSE -- SAYS
NO HAYWARD SO.
WHAT WHY ONE OR THE OTHER AND
DOES WHAT IS THE SENATE HEY
SAMMY DINO -- AND I GUESS WHAT
IS THE ASSEMBLY -- HATE HAYWARD
I DON'T KNOW IF I UNDERSTAND
[inaudible]
I WALDRON [inaudible]
ELIA.
OUT OF FINANCE [inaudible]
ADD OSTROSKY.
WE'VE WE'VE ELECTED THESE
PROJECTS AND WE THINK ALL THESE
PROJECTS ARE NECESSARY COULD
ANSWER.
FINANCE -- SALLY WHO CAN BUILD
PARTNER FINANCE I WOULD AGREE
THERE THE TOP THREE PRIORITIES
FOR CHP OFFICE REPLACEMENTS.
SEVEN NINE ANSWER FOR YOU --
ESTIMATES.
SO THE MORE LOT WHAT IS THE LIFE
OF A LEASE BOND. TWENTY FIVE
YEARS THIRTY ARE GENERALLY
TWENTY FIVE YEARS SO WE'RE GONNA
BE PAYING MAY BE.
THE SAME AMOUNT IN INTEREST OVER
THE LIFE OF THE OF THE BOND.
THAT'S THAT'S CORRECT AM I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO TO NOTE THAT --
WITH LEASE WERE LEASE REVENUE
BOND FINANCING IT HAS UP ON WE
HAVE A LIFE OF TWENTY FIVE YEARS
BUT WHEN CORRECTED -- FOR
INFLATION THE COST OF THAT IS
THIS LESS THAN THAT THE
ACCUMULATION OF THOSE PAYMENTS --
AND YOU ALSO CONSIDER THAT --
PROJECTS ESCALATED ABOUT 5% A
YEAR SO FOR EACH YEAR YOU'RE
AVOIDING FINANCING THE PROJECT
GETS BY PERCENT MORE EXPENSIVE
TO CONSTRUCT SO THERE'S KIND OF
A A MEDIUM POINT WHERE IT.
IT MAKES SENSE YOU KNOW TO NOT
DELAY PROJECTS AND AND JUST GO
AHEAD WITH FINANCING AS WE DO
WITH SO MANY OF OUR OF OUR ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS.
SO EVERY THOUGHT ABOUTDOING A
BLEND.
OF SOME CASH IN SOME WAYS
REVENUE YES YES WE HAVE PROPOSED
THAT AND THAT THAT'S A SOLUTION
THAT WOULD WORK QUITE WELL.
AND HOW DOES THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE FEEL ABOUT THAT IDEA --
WE'RE IN.
AS PART OF IT.
OKAY WELL IF WE CAN'T DO IT THAT
WAY THEN NOTE NO STATION FIRST
HAMMER TO DO YOU KNOW THAT'S ALL
I GOT US.
BUT A BONE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ON ISSUE.
TWENTY THREE CLEARLY WITH LOTS
OF WORK TO DO THERE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK ON IT THANK YOU.
ISSUE TWENTY FOUR ORGANIZED
RETAIL CRIME TASK FORCE ELIA.
UNDER HIGHWAY PATROL.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED BY PUTTING
A MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
DEFENSE SIXTEEN POSITIONS IN
ASSOCIATED COSTS. TO COMPLY WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS OF AB.
TEN SIXTY FIVE THE SENATE
APPROVED FOR POSITIONS AND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR TWO YEARS.
AND IN THE ASSEMBLY PER THE
GOVERNOR'S -- PROPOSAL AS
PROPOSED SO IT'S A DIFFERENCE OF
FIVE POINT ONE MILLION GENERAL
FUND. FOR THE ORGANIZED RETAIL
CRIME TASK FORCE
[inaudible]
THE THE ADMINISTRATION'S ORDS
ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL ON THIS ISSUE
THIS IS A KEY PRIORITY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THE TWO YEAR TIME FRAME.
AND ADEQUATE RESOURCES WILL
ENABLE CHP TO FILL THE ROLE IN
COMBATING ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
[inaudible]
SENATOR NELSON.
THESE POSITIONS TO BE DEPLOYED
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
OR HOW WILL THEY BE DESIGNATED.
TO BE LOCATED.
I'M AN ART DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
THE BILL ITSELF SAYS TO LOOK AT
AREAS WHERE THE OF THE CRIME IS
IS HIGHEST AND SO THIS PROPOSAL
ENVISIONS THREE TASK FORCE.
DEPLOYED IN DIFFERENT AREAS
WHERE THE RESULTS OF THAT THAT
REVIEW SAYS AND THEY ARE MOST
NEEDED.
PROPERTY CRIME MOSTLY IS WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AFTER HERE.
THE BILL SAYS WE HAVE TO WE HAVE
TO CONSIDER THAT AND IN CERTAIN
DETERMINE WHERE THAT THOSE WHERE
THOSE TASK FORCES ARE DEPLOYED
THE ONLY.
PROPERTY BUT OTHER VIOLENT
CRIMES AS WELL.
THIS IS SPECIFIC TO ORGANIZED
RETAIL RETAIL OKAY SO THAT WOULD
BE LIKE THE END [inaudible]
THE THE NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLAR WIZARDS WHO COME IN WITH
THEIR COMPUTERS AND MASS CENTER
ASSIST.
RETAIL STORE IN.
CRACK UP TO NINE HUNDRED AND THE
WALK OUT THAT'S BASICALLY PROP
FORTY SEVENTY ALL RIGHT.
I THINK IN THIS CASE YOU KNOW WE
ARE THIS ISN'T SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO PROPOSITION FORTY
SEVEN IT'S JUST ADDRESSING THE
BROADER ISSUE OF RETAIL THEFT.
WELL IT WOULD BE IT CERTAINLY
WOULD ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS WITH THAT PROPOSITION
SO.
I WOULD HOPE WE DON'T DISTRIBUTE
ABOUT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THE HEIGHT
OF THE ITEM WILL BE HELD OPEN.
MOVING ON WE'VE GOT A BLUE PAPER
ON DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
ISSUE TWENTY FIVE I KNOW BOTH
COMMITTEES A PAD -- PRETTY
EXHAUSTIVE OVERSIGHT HEARINGS ON
THIS ISSUE.
LAW AND WE'LL HEAR FROM THE LA
YOU KNOW WHEN YOUR FRIEND THANK
YOU.
RIGHT I NEED ONLY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE --
AS THE CHAIRMAN JIM TO DO HAVE A
HANDOUT BEFORE YOU IN YOUR
BINDER THE FIRST FEW PAGES
PROVIDE SOME OVER.
I'M NOT GOING TO GO OVER THEM
BUT IF YOU CAN TURN TO PAGE FIVE
OF YOUR HAND OUT WILL BE USING
THIS CHART TO KIND OF SUMMARIZE
THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN.
THE VARIOUS PROPOSALS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE LEFT MOST
COLUMN THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN
INCLUDES THREE MAJOR PROVISIONS.
THE FIRST IS ONGOING FUNDING
FROM THE NVA STARTING -- TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY TWO POINT ONE
MILLION IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
TWENTY A HUNDRED AND NINETY NINE
POINT EIGHT MILLION IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THAT
DECLINE STEADILY TO THIRTY FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION ANNUALLY
BEGINNING IN.
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE THE
SECOND PIECE IS THAT THE
PROPOSAL INCLUDES -- PASSING ON
CREDIT CARD TRANSACTION FEES TO
CONSUMERS.
AND THE THIRD PIECE IS -- BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE AUTHORIZING THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO AUGMENT
DMV'S BUDGET UPON THIRTY DAY
NOTIFICATION TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
THAT IS LANGUAGE SIMILAR TO WHAT
IS IN THE BUDGET.
THIS YEAR.
IF WE THEN LOOK AT THE TWO
HOUSES PROPOSALS WILL TAKE THE
FIRST TWO LINE ITEMS TOGETHER --
LOOKING AT THE SENATE PLAN THE
SENATE PROVIDES ONGOING AND BE A
FUNDING TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
MILLION IN 200-019-2200 AND
SIXTY POINT ONE MILLION IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THEN IT
GOES TO TEN MILLION ANNUALLY
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO TO SUPPORT.
IT AND TRAINING COSTS THE THE
AMOUNT IS THE SAME AS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROBE BUT IT DOES
INCLUDE IN THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN
ACCEPTED ADJUSTED UPWARD TO
ACCOUNTFOR THE SENATE TO
REJECTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PASS ON THE CREDIT
CARD FEES.
ASSEMBLY ON THE OTHER HAND
APPROVED ONE TIME AND BE A
FUNDING OF TWO HUNDRED MILLION
AND APPROVED GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO PASS ON THE CREDIT CARD FEES.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE THIRD LINE --
THIS IS THEN WHERE WE HAVE
DIFFERENCES RELATED TO THE
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
THE SENATE APPROVED THE PROPOSED
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE TO AUGMENT
DMV'S -- BUDGET WITHIN THIRTY
DAY NOTIFICATION ASSEMBLY
REJECTED THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
INSTEAD ADDITIONAL FUNDING WOULD
BE AVAILABLE.
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS A
UPON LEGISLATIVE APPROPRIATION
AFTER DMB DEMONSTRATES NEED AND
PROGRESS IN MEETING PERFORMANCE
MEASURES.
THE FINAL ITEM I'M ON THIS TABLE
BEFORE YOU BOTH HOUSES ADOPTED
SIMILAR REPORTING LANGUAGE --
THESE WOULD BE MONTHLY REPORTS
ON CERTAIN PERFORMANCE MEASURES
INCLUDING OFFICE WAIT TIMES AND
TECHNOLOGY OUTAGES.
I'M IN A REVIEW OF THE PACKAGES
THE ASSEMBLY'S PLAN INCLUDED
SOME KEY ELEMENTS THAT WE
THOUGHT REALLY WOULD INCREASE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
THE FIRST IS THAT IT PROVIDES
ONE TIME FUNDING -- AND THE
SECOND IS THAT IT REJECTS THE
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE AND SO BOTH
OF THESE WOULD REQUIRE THAN THAT
DMV COME FORWARD -- AND JUSTIFY
HOW IT COULD USE THE MONEY IN
THE PAST AND HOW IT PLANNED TO
USE FUNDING IN THE FUTURE THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT THEY
WOULD NEED AS WELL AS OUR
PROGRESS IN MEETING PERFORMANCE
MEASURES.
THE OTHER THING THAT I WOULD DO
IS IT WOULD PREVENT THE
DEPARTMENT FROM SPENDING MONEY
PRIOR TO THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATING IT.
AND THEN FINALLY -- PASSING ON
THE CREDIT CARD TRANSACTIONS AS
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT OTHER
DEPARTMENTS HAVE DONE SUCH
EXAMPLES INCLUDE FTP AND EIGHTY
FINANCE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- WE KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION
AN UNDERSTANDABLE CONCERN AND
FRUSTRATION.
ISSUES OR JUST MAKE A COUPLE
BRIEF POINTS. FOR STAYS WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT OUR MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL -- WERE
CONCERNED THAT UNDER THE
ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL WHICH THE
FORTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS LESS
IN THE BUDGET YOU'RE BUDGET.
BY OUR CALCULATIONS THAT'S
NEARLY SIX HUNDRED FEWER
POSITIONS AT DMV RIGHT BEFORE
THE REAL ID DEADLINE IN OCTOBER
OF TWENTY TWENTY SO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE FUNDING
SO THAT WAIT TIMES DO NOT.
GO UP NEXT YEAR AND THAT
TRAINING IS NOT DELAYED.
THE SECOND POINT I WANT TO MAKE
IS AROUND AUGMENTATION AUTHORITY
AGAIN WITH EVERYTHING COMING TO
A HEAD NEXT YEAR REGARDING REAL
ID IMPLEMENTATION -- WE BELIEVE
THAT THE JAIL BC AUGMENTATION
PROCESS IS THE RIGHT WAY IF IT
TURNS OUT THAT WE DO NEED WAS
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE DMV
THAT DOCKING OCCUR THROUGH THE
JAIL BC PROCESS AND WE DO KNOW
YOU DO NOT HAVE TO CONVENE
TOGETHER FOR ANOTHER BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR TO MAKE SURE THAT
AUGMENTATION CAN TAKE PLACE.
AND THEN THIRD ON THE CREDIT
CARD FEES -- WHILE WE APPRECIATE
THAT THIS ISSUE -- IT WOULD NOT
UNLIKE THE ISSUES I WAS JUST
DISCUSSING A FACT -- ARE PLANNED
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN FOR
THE DMV IN THE UPCOMING YEAR IT
WOULD HAVE A DOWNSTREAM THE FACT
ON THAT SOLVENCY OF THE MOTOR
VEHICLE ACCOUNT OR THE ABILITY
OF THAT ACCOUNT TO SUPPORT OTHER
CAPITAL.
PROJECTS WE DO BELIEVE THAT
PASSING ON CREDIT CARD FEES IS
CONSISTENT WITH PRACTICES OF
OTHER DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD SO WE DO
WANT TO STICK TO THAT PART OF
THE PROPOSAL -- AND SO WITH THAT
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
AROUND OUR PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS [inaudible]
WITH SKINNER [inaudible]
I'M.
THE CREDIT CARD FEE ISSUE WHILE.
OTHER DEPARTMENTS MAY DO IT.
I THINK WE HAVE A CLEARLY A A
PUBLIC RELATIONS PROBLEM IN
RELATIONSHIP [inaudible]
TO CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS AND THE
DMV.
IN THAT -- AND IN SOME OF THIS
IS.
WAS NOT WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S
MAKING IN OTHER WORDS THE FACT
THAT WE NOW HAVE TO DO THESE
REAL ID'S AND SUCH.
AND WE KNOW THAT OTHER STATES
ARE ALSO EXPERIENCING -- BUT
WAIT TIMES IN DELAYS BECAUSE OF
THIS NEW WORKLOAD.
BUT EVEN PRIOR TO THEIR REAL
ID'S.
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE BEST -- IF WE
I THINK IF WE YOU FIVE VENTURE
TO SAY THAT IF WE DID A POLL AND
ASKED -- CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
WHAT WAS THEIR LEAST FAVORITE.
STATE DEPARTMENT THEY MIGHT.
INDICATE TO DMV SO I THINK IT IS
WELL WORTH OUR WHILE. TO IN IN
THE PLAN IN ANY PLAN THAT WE DO
TO IMPROVE THAT CUSTOMER
RELATIONS AND I THINK CHARGING.
FOR THE CREDIT CARD FEES IS A
BAD MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION.
AND FOR MOST OF US WE EVEN GO TO
RETAIL FACILITIES THAT SAY
EITHER THEY THEY WON'T ACCEPT A
CREDIT CARD UNLESS IT'S UNDER
CERTAIN SALES FOR THRESHOLD OR
VARIOUS OTHER THINGS LIKE THAT
YOU KNOW CUSTOMERS ARE NOT HAPPY.
BUT BEYOND THAT.
WE DON'T CHARGE.
FOR PROCESSING OF A CHECK AND
I'M SURE IN THIS CASE WHAT WE
WOULD BE DOING IN ANYBODY YOU
DIDN'T WANT TO PAY THE CREDIT
CARD FEET IT WOULD MOST LIKELY
BE A CHECK WE'RE NOT.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE PAYING CASH.
SO CHECKS ARE QUITE COSTLY TO
HANDLE ALSO THEY REQUIRE A LOT
OF PERSONAL TIME TO PROCESS.
AND THEN YOU CAN NEVER BAD
CHECKS SO I DON'T KNOW IF THE
DEPARTMENT IS LOOKED AT WHETHER --
I MEAN I ALWAYS FELT THAT WE
WOULD PROBABLY BE STREAMLINING
AND CUTTING COSTS JUST BY REALLY.
INCREASING OUR ACCEPTANCE OF
CREDIT CARDS IN A WHOLE VARIETY
OF PAYMENTS -- SO.
I THINK THE DEPARTMENT SHOULD
LOOK AT THAT THROUGH THAT LENS
BECAUSE WHILE YES IT'S CLEAR
THAT CREDIT CARDS -- COMPANIES
CHARGE A PROCESSING FEE WE ALSO
HAVE A LOT OF COSTS JUST
EMBEDDED IN THE PROCESSING OF
CHECKS.
SO I I WOULD GO WITH THE
SENATE'S VERSION OF REJECTING
THE PASSING ON OF THE CREDIT
CARD FEES.
THANK YOU ARTHUR MORE LUCK FALL
BY SENATOR NIELSEN THE MANAGER
AT HAVING BEEN.
TREASURER FOR THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE FOR TWELVE YEARS AND
HAVING. TO PUT UP WITH THIS
CONVENIENCE FEE WE ARE WHEN IT
CAME TO PAYING PROPERTY TAXES.
BUT OF PEOPLE WANTED TO USE
THEIR CREDIT CARD TO GET MILEAGE
BUT SOME.
BUT BRED TO IS THERE FOR THE IT
ISN'T.
AS IF -- THERE IS -- CHECKS ARE
CHEAPER OR WHATEVER IT'S IT'S
IT'S IT'S VISA CHARGING A
CONVENIENCE FEE AT ALL LIKE A
223%.
AND AND THEY DO NOT HAVE A
GOVERNMENT RATE.
SO LIKE A REDUCED RATE FOR FOR
THOSE OF US THAT ARE.
COLLECTING FUNDS FROM TAXPAYERS --
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT COMPETING WITH
OTHER RETAIL STORES TECH.
COME INTO OUR OUR STORES WHICH
IS WHERE CREDIT CARDS STARTED IN
THE FIRST PLACE SO.
I RECEIVED WE NEED TO DO A
LITTLE WORK WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
BEFORE ABOUT GETTING BE SAID TO
BE A LITTLE MORE --
ACCOMMODATING TO GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTS -- I THINK DISCOVER
CARD IS THE ONLY ONE THAT
DOESN'T CHARGE A FEE BUT THEN
YOU HAVE TO BRING IT IN PERSON
YOU CAN'T JUST DO IT OVER ONLINE.
SO THE THE ARE THE OPTIONS YOU
HAVE HEARD MAYBE TO TO CHARGE TO
FEES.
ONE FOR THOSE A PAY CHECK OR
CASH IN AND SO LET'S SAY THAT'S
TWENTY DOLLARS AND THEN THOSE
THAT PAY WITH CREDIT CARD THAT'S
TWENTY TWO OR YOU DO A BLENDED-RATE YOU SAY LET'S JUST CHARGE
EVERYBODY TWENTY ONE SO WHAT.
AT THE END OF THE DAY WE COME
OUT EVEN BUT NOW YOU'RE
PENALIZING THOSE THAT ARE
WRITING CHECKS OR PAYING CASH --
BUT BUT I I I I I I WOULD ARGUE
AGAINST.
PAYING THE THE THE THE CREDIT
CARD FEE -- AND IN TWO BECAUSE
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S ADDED ON
AS AN EXTRA FOR CREDIT CARDS AND
SO I WOULD TAKE THE OPPOSITE.
POSITION TO HAVE A LITTLE DEBATE
THANK YOU MADAM.
THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN.
WELL I WOULD CONCUR ON THE
CREDIT CARD ISSUE I DO BELIEVE
THAT THAT IS A LITTLE BIT
PROBLEMATIC AND I THINK IT WOULD
ADD TO THE AGGRAVATION.
FILL THE MOTORING PUBLIC.
AND IN TERMS OF THE ONE YEAR
FUNDING AS OPPOSED TO A LONGER
TERM FUNDING.
EVERYTHING RIGHT NOW.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN DO TO
KEEP THE DMV ON A SHORTEST LEASH
I THINK IS REQUIRED.
THE EARLY VIOLATED THE TRUST OF
THE LEGISLATURE UNDER THE PEOPLE.
AND I'M NOT FOR GIVING THEM MUCH
MORE LATITUDE.
I'M RATHER TO GIVE THEM A
SHORTER LEASH WHERE WE CAN HAVE-MORE CONTROL.
AND QUICKER QUICK THE MORE
QUICKLY EXERCISE THAT CONTROL
OVER DMV.
SO THE LONGER TERM FUNDING IS
NOT SUITABLE TO ME.
I WOULD MISTER KING.
NO FOR IT.
I WAS GONNA GO SENATOR NIELSEN
SOUND COMMENTS WE HEARD --
THROUGH A SIGNIFICANT A
TESTIMONY OF LAST YEAR.
ABOUT ALL THE THINGS THAT DMV
WAS GOING TO DO.
I CAN'T PROMISE AFTER PROMISE
AFTER PROMISE BUT THEY DID DO
WAS.
HIRE PEOPLE BUT THEY DIDN'T DO
IS TRAIN THEM.
SO THEY COULDN'T GET THE FULL.
SKILL OUT OF THEM BY NOT
TRAINING THEM THEY COULDN'T WORK
BEHIND THE DESK CAN USE
COMPUTERS DIDN'T REALLY KNOW.
WHAT FORMS WERE USED BY THE
DEPARTMENT REALLY HOW?
TO HOW TO HELP THE CUSTOMERS WHO
WERE STANDING IN.
FAIRLY LONG LINES YOU KNOW I HAD
CUSTOMERS IN IN MY AREA THAT
THEY WOULD LINE UP AT FIVE
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING.
WE NEED TO GET IN DIEM BE AT
NINE O'CLOCK -- SO OF COURSE TO
WAIT TIMES THANKS TO LOOK LIKE --
THAT CUSTOMER ONLY WAITED TEN
MINUTES BECAUSE THEY GOT THEIR
FINE IN [inaudible]
THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT REALLY SHOULD BE
AN EXPERIENCE THAT WE HAVE FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST TRYING TO DO --
THE BASIC WORK AT THE DMV.
WE ALSO GIVE MONIES FOR WIFI WE
GAVE MONEY FOR TABLETS AND WHAT
WE FOUND IS.
THE MONEY THAT'S GIVEN WIFI
THERE'S ONLY BEEN. ONE ONE AS OF
THE PREVIOUS TESTIMONY A FEW
MONTHS AGO ONLY.
ONE OFFICE ACTUALLY HAD EXTERNAL
WIFI -- TABLETS WERE PURCHASED
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO EXTERNAL
WIFI THE TABLETS CAN BE USED.
SO WHAT WE HAVE IS HERE IS OUR
LOT OF PROMISES AND NOT A LOT OF
THE LIVER [inaudible]
AND HILL WE EVEN HAD AN ACTING
DIRECTOR COME IN FRONT OF BUDGET
SUB.
SIX TALK ABOUT -- ALL THE THINGS
THE DEPARTMENT'S GOING TO DO.
THAT ALL THE DEPUTIES WERE THERE
WHEN THE PREVIOUS DIRECTOR START
SAYING ABOUT ALL THE THINGS THAT
SHE WAS GOING TO DO.
AND WE DIDN'T HAVE IS.
A SENSE THAT ANYBODY WAS REALLY.
TAKING RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHAT.
THEY SAID.
THERE WAS A COMPLETE LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND WHEN THAT HAPPENS WE'LL ALL
OUR PHONES LIGHT I MEAN YOU WANT
TO KNOW WHO'S COUNSELED PEOPLE
APPEAR.
ON THE DíAS BECAUSE OUR PHONES
RING.
CALL US I KNOW.
THAT -- DMV'S PROBABLY ONE OF
OUR TOP FIVE OR TEN ISSUES THAT
WE HEAR FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS OR
THE CAN CAN APPOINTMENT THEIR
ID'S ARE EXPIRING THEY THE GUEST
AND APPOINTMENTS TO THE PLACES
THAT ARE YOU KNOW.
VERY FAR FROM HOME.
SO AGAIN.
WITH OUR APPROACH WITH THIS.
APPROPRIATION WAS REALLY TO WE
CAN ENSURE THAT.
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO ARE HIRED OR
IN THE PROCESS OF BEING HIRED.
WERE ON GETTING THE PROBE
GETTING THE APPROPRIATE AMOUNT
OF FUNDING AND THEN WITH HOLDING.
THE ADDITIONAL MONEY WHICH AGAIN
WAS ONLY -- ONLY FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND AND AGAIN LET LET'S
JUST LET'S JUST PUT THIS IN
CONTEXT.
DMV BUDGET IS A BILLION DOLLARS.
SUITE TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
DOLLAR AUGMENTATION EVEN A PART
OF IT IS ONE TIME IS A 20%
AUGMENTATION.
SO IT'S NOT AN INSIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF RESOURCES IT'S A HUGE
AMOUNT OF RESOURCE.
AND KNOWING THE CRUSH THAT'S
GONNA COM.
WITH RELY DE I THINK THE IDEA
WAS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE LET DIEM VIA.
HI THE PEOPLE THAT ARE HIGHER.
MAKE SURE THEY'RE GONNA TRAIN
THOSE PEOPLE THAT ALL THOSE
PEOPLE SUPPOSED TO BE TRAINED.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS IF YOU
NEED MORE MONEY I DON'T THINK
THERE'S ANYBODY HERE SAYING.
DON'T COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
EVEN MID YEAR FOR A MAJOR
AUGMENTATION BECAUSE WE NEED IT.
BECAUSE AT THE END OF DAYS WE
DON'T WANT YOU TO GO BY AND FOR
THE LINES TO CONTINUE FOR THE
LACK OF DELIVERY AND FOR THE
INABILITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
DO SOMETHING.
AT THIS POINT WE WE HAVE THE
SAME HEARING HE WAS LIKE
GROUNDHOG DAY.
LAST YEAR IN AUGUST AND WE HAVE
THE EXACT SAME HEARING WE HAD IN
APRIL.
NO DIFFERENCE IF THEY TOOK THE
ONLY DIFFERENCE WAS.
THAT AGGRAVATION OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS WAS NO LESS.
AND THE STAKES ARE GETTING
HIGHER BECAUSE WE'RE GETTING
CLOSER AND CLOSER TO OUR REAL ID
OCTOBER TWENTY TWENTY DEADLINE.
SO AGAIN -- I PERSONALLY DIDN'T
FEEL THAT THERE WAS A
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ON THE PATH
DEPARTMENT ARE.
REALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE DEPARTMENT SO
I THINK FOR ME IT'S MAKING SURE.
THAT.
THE LEGISLATURE'S PROVIDING IS
PROPER OVERSIGHT WITHOUT TWO
HUNDRED AGAIN A 20% AUGMENTATION
I WOULD NOT.
I WOULD THINK SHOULD BE PLENTY
AND WITHHOLDING THE 40% FOR
AGAIN YOU CAN COME BACK EVEN
BEFORE I TO SESSION BEFORE
SEPTEMBER FIFTEENTH.
AND HAVE THAT DISCUSSION TO HAVE
THAT VOTED ON BUT AGAIN I THINK
IT MADE A LOT OF SENSE TO
WITHHOLD THAT -- FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS BEFORE MONEY WAS FURTHER
MISSPENT SO AGAIN IN THE IN THE
CASE OF THE TABLETS OF THE WIFI
THE MONEY WAS SPENT.
THE RESOURCES JUST ONE USE.
SO I THINK THAT'S THAT'S EVEN
WORSE TO FEEL LIKE TO TAXPAYERS
MONEY WAS.
WASTED ON THINGS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT DID NOT END UP USING.
THANK YOU I THINK THAT I WOULD
SAY THAT I I THINK -- IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US IS THE
LEGISLATURE TO REALLY BE CLEAR
ABOUT OUR ROLE OF OVERSIGHT IN A
PROPER LEVEL OVERSIGHT.
VERSES A ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DIRECTORS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICES -- WE HAVE A
CLEAR ROLE TO PLAY AND YOU HAVE
A CLEAR ROLE TO PLAY AS
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS YOUR
DEPARTMENT HEADS.
ON A AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE AS I SAID
SAID PREVIOUSLY -- IT IS IN OUR
COLLECTIVE BEST INTEREST TO MAKE
SURE TO THE DMV IS A FUNCTION
STATE DEPARTMENT IN THAT NEARLY
EVERY LIFE IN CALIFORNIA'S
TOUCHED BY THIS ONE DEPARTMENT.
AND SOMEONE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO BE CLEAR ABOUT US
NEEDING TO BE PARTNERS IN THAT.
I HAD A QUESTION -- IN LOOKING
AT THE SIMPLEST PROPOSAL -- AND
ASKING THAT -- ANY ADDITIONAL
FUNDING.
REQUEST TO BE BROUGHT BACK -- TO
THE LEGISLATURE AS A WHOLE AS
OPPOSED TO UTILIZING THE
EXISTING -- G. L. B. C. PROCESS
I GUESS MY CONCERN WITH THAT
WOULD REALLY BE TIMING WE HAVE A
PROCESS BY WHICH MADE YOUR
ADJUSTMENTS CAN BE MADE EITHER
THROUGH GOP CITY WHICH IS
TYPICALLY UTILIZED WHEN WE ARE
OUT OF SESSION THAT'SBEEN MY
EXPERIENCE.
THE LAST THREE YEARS THE GOP SEE
CHAIR -- SPRING FINANCE LETTERS
WHICH ARE IN SPRING -- OR
THROUGH BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSALS
YOU KNOW IT IF THE ASSEMBLY
ACTION WERE TAKEN -- WHAT?
YOU CAN DO YOU HAVE A SENSE OF
TIMING WHEN THESE.
ADJUSTMENTS MIGHT BE MADE DO YOU
THINK WOULD YOU HAVE CONCERN OF
THE ASSEMBLY -- ACTION WE'RE
TAKING THAT IT WOULD NOT BE ABLE --
YOU WOULDN'T GET THE RESOURCES
YOU NEED IN A TIMELY MATTER FOR
EXAMPLE IF IT'S DURING OUR
LEGISLATIVE RECESS.
ALL SPEAK BRIEFLY AND THEN TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE SO FOR
THE D. -- ADMINISTRATION IN A AS
IF YOU'RE A VICE CHAIR TING SAID.
WE UNDERSTAND THE LEVEL OF
FRUSTRATION HERE WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S BUILDING OVER A NUMBER
OF NOT JUST MONTHS BUT YEARS.
AHEAD AS YOU NOTED MADAM CHAIR
WE SHARE THAT CONCERN THAT WE
ARE ALL RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS
PROBLEM AND THE GOVERNOR FEELS
THAT VERY DIRECTLY AS TO THE TOP
MEMBERS OF HIS.
ADMINISTRATION SO A LOT OF
THOUGHT WENT INTO THIS PROPOSAL
AND THE LEVEL OF FUNDING THAT WE
PROPOSED FOR THE BUDGET YEAR IS
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS NECESSARY TO
MEET THE NEEDS SO.
AT THIS POINT IT'S HARD FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROJECT WHAT
EXTRA RESOURCES WE MIGHT NEED
BECAUSE ALL OF THAT -- ALL THAT
REASONING WENT INTO THE EXISTING
LEVEL OF FUNDING FOR THE
PROPOSAL.
AND WHILE IT'S POSSIBLE THAT.
LEGISLATURE MAY BE IN SESSION WE
MAY BE ABLE TO GET THE BUDGET
BILL JUNIOR VERY QUICKLY IF WE
DO NEED EXISTING RESOURCES.
IT'S ALSO POSSIBLE DEPENDING ON
THE TIME OF YEAR.
THAT THAT QUICK PROCESS MIGHT
NOT BE AVAILABLE PARTICULARLY IN
A TIME FRAME THAT WE WOULD BE
HOPING FOR THE DMV TO CONTINUE
READING UP FOR THE PEAK OF REAL
ID IMPLEMENTATION.
NEXT SUMMER THE OTHER POINT THAT
I WANT TO MAKE IS -- DEPENDING
ON HOW LONG THAT PROCESS TAKES
IT'S NOT SIMPLY THAT POSITIONS
THEMSELVES BUT THE DOWNSTREAM
EFFECTS ON TRAINING AND HIRING
PEOPLE TO FILL THE NEXT SET OF
POSITIONS.
SO WE DO SHARE THAT CONCERN
WAITING UP TO NEXT OCTOBER AND A
BRIEF WE TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE.
BERNARD MARTIN FINANCE HERE THEN
I WOULD JUST -- NOTED THAT --
THE TO THE JAIL BC PROCESS IN
THE CURRENT YEAR.
THE DMV WAS.
GIVEN FUNDING TO HIRE AT A
HIGHER UP THREE HUNDRED OF THE
POSITIONS OR BEING REQUESTED.
AND WE JUST -- AT AS OF TODAY I
THINK THE DMV HAD MADE -- TWO
HUNDRED OFFERS ALREADY AND THE
FIRST MONTH AND THEY STILL HAVE
ANOTHER MONTHS AGO -- AND OF
THOSE A NINETY HAVE INDIVIDUALS
HAVE ALREADY BEGUN WORKING.
AND SO WE'RE KIND OF AS AS WE
APPROACH THE REAL ID DEADLINE.
WE WERE LOOKING AT THIS RAMP UP
AND IT INVOLVES THE OBVIOUSLY
THE RECRUITMENT AND THEN.
THE HIRING AND THEN THE
COMBINATION OF GETTING THEM IN
OFFICE EXPERIENCE AND TRAINING
AND SO -- WITHOUT THESE FUNDS I
THINK WE THEY COULD CONTINUE AT
THE CURRENT RATE OF HIRING
THROUGH -- MAYBE THE END OF JULY
AND SO IF IF WE WERE TO TO NEED
TO COME BACK FOR FUNDING.
I COULD EASILY ENVISION THAT
BEING YOU KNOW AS EARLY AS
AUGUST.
AND I WOULD CERTAINLY HOPE AS AS
THE VICE CHAIR HAS REMINDED US
OF THE TRAINING FALL POP IN THE
PAST I CERTAINLY HOPE OF TWO
HUNDRED PEOPLE ARE BEING ON
IN A COMPREHENSIVE FULL COMPLETE
KIND OF WAY.
THE OTHER PIECE I WOULD RAISE IS
JUST THE THAT THE AREA THAT THE
SENT ME SOME WE DO SUPPORT WHICH
IS THE REQUIREMENT OF MONTHLY
REPORTING.
ON AND I KNOW THAT A GREAT DEAL
OF WORK IS BEING PUT INTO REALLY
FIGURING OUT PERFORMANCE METRICS --
THAT ARE RELEVANT.
I FOR ONE WOULD NOT BE
INTERESTED IN CREATING -- KIND
OF A RONI IS MONTHLY REPORTS FOR
THE DEPARTMENT THAT PART
MEASURING THE RIGHT THING AND
GET US NOWHERE AND PULL --
PERSONNEL AWAY FROM.
FRONTLINE PROBLEM SOLVING AND
SOMEONE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE IN A
CONVERSATION OF AND AND COME TO
SOME AGREEMENT ON WHAT THOSE
PERFORMANCE METRICS PERFORMANCE
METRICS SHOULD BE -- TO QUELL
THE UNREST AMONG THE LEGISLATURE
SIDE SO WE ARE IN A POSITION OF
HAVING -- DATA TO PERFORM OUR
OVERSIGHT ROLE -- AND THAT YOU
USE IT -- AS A TRUE METRIC IN
TERMS OF SUCCESS IF YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE MEASURE YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'VE GOT THERE
YET.
AND YOU KNOW OFFICE WAIT LINE TO
TECHNOLOGY OUTAGES ARE A
CHALLENGE FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
THOSE ARE MERE SYMPTOMS OF
STRUCTURAL ISSUES IS THE ONE TO
DIG DEEPER AND MAKING SURE WE'RE
MEASURING THE RIGHT THING.
SO AND SO I DO KNOW FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE -- THE BOTH HOUSES
AGREE ON THAT AND AGAIN WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING
ON THE RIGHT MEASUREMENTS ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEE NOT THE
SCENE NONE.
THAT AUTUMN WILL BE.
LEFT TO OPEN.
THANK YOU WE'RE MAKE ABOUT TO
MAKE A TRANSITION TO HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES.
WHERE WE WILL TALK ABOUT
DEPARTMENTS SUCH AS DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES AUSTIN?
CALIFORNIA HEALTH HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY.
NO HELP OVERSIGHT SOCIAL
SERVICES.
THE PROBLEM EIGHTEEN X. AT OUR
X. AT OUR EXPENSE.
WITH A QUICK.
MANY OUT MAN OF THE HOUR
.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
WITH ISSUE ONE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMMISSION
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
KALLIO A GOOD AFTERNOON BEN
JOHNSON WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT PROVIDED
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND FOR THE CREATION OF THE
COUNCIL ON HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEMS.
THIS YEAR THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED REVERTING THAT --
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY AND APPROVE PROPOSES A
NEW GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION
OF AN EQUIVALENT AMOUNT AS WELL
AS TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO
RENAME THE COUNCIL THE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIAFOR ALL COMMISSION.
AND THE JUSTICE RESPONSIBILITIES
TO EVALUATE OPTION SPECIFICALLY
FOR A TRANSITION TO SINGLE PAYER.
HEALTHCARE FINANCING SYSTEM.
THE SENATE APPROVED THE
REVERSION THE NEW APPROPRIATION
AND THE ADOPTED PLACE HOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE CONSISTENT
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WELL THE ASSEMBLY TOOK NO ACTION
FOR WHAT ISSUE HERE IS THE FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR REVERSION.
THE NEW APPROPRIATION AND THE
TRAILER BILL IT JUST -- LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD TRANSITION THE
COUNCIL OVER TO THE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMMISSION.
THANK YOU FINANCE THE
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTS SENATE
BUDGET ON THIS PROPOSAL.
TAKE A NOTE [inaudible]
THE QUESTIONS.
WE CAN'T TAKE ACTION ON AYE
READY.
ALRIGHT ISSUE NUMBER TWO OFFICE
OF HEALTHY AND SAFE COMMUNITIES
HELLO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND SONYA PICK FROM THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M
GOING TO TAKE THE ISSUES TWO AND
THREE TOGETHER.
OKAY GREAT.
SO BOTH OF THESE ISSUES CONCERN --
THE OFFICE THE NEW OFFICE OF
THIS A CALIFORNIA SURGEON
GENERAL WHICH IS HOUSED IN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY.
THE FIRST -- ISSUE THE ASSEMBLY
APPROVE GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF SIX MILLION ONE
TIME TO ESTABLISH THE OFFICE OF
HEALTHY AND SAFE SAFE
COMMUNITIES UNDER THE DIRECTION
OF THE SURGEON GENERAL WELL THE
GOVERNOR HAD NO PROPOSAL IN THE
SENATE TOOK NO ACTION -- THIS
OFFICE WOULD PROVIDE OR DEVELOP
A COMPREHENSIVE VIOLENCE
PREVENTION STRATEGY ACROSS
VARIOUS STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS.
AND THEN THE THIRD ISSUE IS --
RELATED TO A REPORTING
REQUIREMENT THAT WOULD BE HOUSED
UNDER THE OFFICE OF THE SURGEON
GENERAL.
OF THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED TWO
POSITIONS IN GENERAL FUND
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
FOR THE SURGEON GENERAL. TO
ANNUALLY REPORT PUBLIC HEALTH
DATA TO THE LEGISLATURE THAT
DESCRIBES THE STATE OF THE
STATE'S PUBLIC HEALTH.
THE GOVERNOR DID NOT HAVE A
PROPOSAL IN THE SENATE DID NOT
TAKEN ACTION -- WE RECOMMEND --
APPROVAL OF THIS ASSEMBLY IS
ACTION THE PURPOSE OF THIS
PROPOSAL IS TO REALLY PROVIDE
CONCISE ANNUAL REPORTING TO
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
SPECIFICALLY AS THEY ENTER INTO
BUDGET DELIBERATIONS EACH YEAR
IT SORT OF SETS THE STAGE WHAT
ARE THE IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH%
ISSUES.
AND TRENDS -- THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER AS
IT DELIBERATES ON THE BUDGET
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
THE ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTS
SENATE BUDGET ON BOTH OF THESE
ISSUES -- ON THE FIRST ISSUE
THIS IS IN PART OF OUR CURRENT
NAY REVISION PLAN AND SHOULD
ALSO BRIEFLY NOTE ALTHOUGH THIS
ISSUES NOT SPECIFICALLY -- ON
THE CONFERENCE AGENDA THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
SUPPORT THE CREATION OF THE
OFFICE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL
ALONG WITH ASSOCIATED FUNDING.
AND ON THE SECOND ISSUE THAT LA --
MENTIONED WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
TYPE OF REPORTING ROLE IS BEST
SITUATED WITHIN THE EXISTING
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH --
RELEASE SUCH A REPORT THE
DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH RELEASE SUCH REPORT THIS
YEAR AS I UNDERSTAND IT THAT'S
CORRECT RIGHT AND SOLD LA L. IS
IT YOUR SENSE THAT IT WOULD BE
MORE APPROPRIATE TO COME FROM.
THE OFFICE OF THE SURGEON
GENERAL WHO.
I SHOULD WILL FAIL AN ASIDE
STATUTORILY DOESN'T EXIST IT WAS
CREATED TO EXECUTIVE ORDERS I
THINK THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE ABOUT
WHEN THAT'S GOING TO BE RESOLVED
AND I'LL COME BACK TO THE
FINANCE ON THAT.
BUT WAS IT YOUR POINT WE WE
ACTUALLY ARE NOT TAKING A
POSITION ON WHETHER IT'S HOUSED
IN OFFICES SURGEON GENERAL OR
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND
I WOULD JUST REMIND MEMBERS THAT
THE REASON THE DEPARTMENT DID
PRESENT SUCH A REPORT.
AT THE BEGINNING A BUDGET
HEARINGS THIS YEAR WAS DUE TO
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE IN
THE BUDGET.
OF FROM LAST YEAR AND SO IF IT
IS HOUSED IN THE OFFICE OF THE
SURGEON GENERAL -- THE POSITION
THE TWO STAFF MEMBERS THAT WOULD
BE AUTHORIZED BY THIS
APPROPRIATION WOULD MORE.
A MOST LIKELY BE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH -- TO DEVELOP THIS
ANNUAL REPORTING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IN THE ARE ALSO FINANCE OF ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT IS WAS
CONSIDERED AND PUTTING FOR THE
THE BUDGET -- FOR A THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF THAT ACTION WOULD HAVE
TAKEN WAS THE FACT THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH CAN LEVERAGES SOME OF ITS
EXISTING RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO
DEVELOP THIS REPORT WHICH IS ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY WE ALSO THINK
IT'S MORE APPROPRIATE ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH --
WITH REGARDS TO THE PREVIOUS
ISSUE ON THE OFFICE OF HEALTHY
AND SAFE COMMUNITIES ABOUT
PUBLIC HEALTH CURRENTLY HAS A
VIOLENCE PREVENTION INITIATIVE
WHICH WE BELIEVE I HAVE SOME
DUPLICATE OF WORK IN THAT SPACE
AS WELL SO WE BELIEVE PUBLIC
HEALTH WOULD BE THE MORE
APPROPRIATE.
ENTITY.
THANK YOU AND BACK -- TO ISSUE
TO TO THE ADMINISTRATION -- IS
THERE A PLAN -- TO PUT IN
STATUTE THE CREATION OF THE
OFFICE THAT WOULD DETAIL KIND OF
EXPECTATIONS ALL THINGS THAT
STATUTE CURRENTLY REFLECTS FOR
OTHER.
DEPARTMENTS IN COMMISSION TO
WHATEVER THEY HAVE BEEN CREATED
YES SO ALTHOUGH THE GOVERNOR I
CREATED YOU KNOW APPOINTED THE
SURGEON GENERAL NEAR THE
BEGINNING OF HIS ADMINISTRATION.
ARE MAY REVISION BUDGET INCLUDES
AN OFFICE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL
COMPLETE WITH SEVERAL FUNDED
POSITIONS.
BUT IT DOESN'T PUT THE POSITION
OF THE OFFICE OF SURGEON GENERAL
IN STATUTE ROCKET REFERENCES IT
BUT IT DOES IT.
ACTUALLY INCLUDE IN STATUTE THE
OFFICE ITSELF.
WE'VE BUT I BELIEVE THAT'S
CORRECT AND SO ARE WE GOING TO
THAT MY POINT IS ARE WE GOING TO
DO ARE YOU GONNA DO THAT OR NOT
AT SOME POINT.
I SHOULD LOOK INTO THE OKAY
APPRECIATED I'M JUST CURIOUS IT
WILL BE DONE TO LEGISLATION IT
SEEMS TO ME WOULD HAVE BEEN.
YOU KNOW HELPFUL HAVE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE YOU COULD HAVE
BEEN DONE BUT IF YOU WOULD GET
BACK TO ME ON THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO GET BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MR MCCARTY.
YEAH THANK YOU JUST TO MAYBE
FOLLOW UP ON ON THIS SO
FOLLOWING UP ON AND YOUR
COMMENTS RIGHT THERE ON THE
POSITION.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ISSUES
TWO AND THREE WHICH BOTH.
HAVE RESOURCES AND WORK THAT
WOULD BE DONE BYTHAT SURGEON
GENERAL ON FULLY SUPPORT THAT.
FOR HER WORK IN FRANKLIN
CALIFORNIA LAST YOU KNOW DECADE
OR SO.
AND THE WORK HERE AT AND I GUESS
IT'S NOT A CONFERENCE BUT WHO
WHO.
WHAT WAS APPROVED BY BOTH HOUSES
TO FIND?
HER POSITION AND THE AND THE
WORK THAT ACCURATE NO SO BOTH
HOUSES ACTUALLY REJECTED THE
ASSOCIATED FUNDING IN POSITIONS --
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED.
GOTCHA AND SO THESE TWO ACTIONS
I'M CONFUSED AND HOW TO THESE TO
RELATE TO THAT THAT THEY'RE JUST
SEPARATE.
THE CITY REJECTED THE SO -- I
SMITE AWAY -- SPEAK TO THAT.
IT WAS OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THIS IS STILL AN ISSUE THAT'S
MAYBE BEING DISCUSSED AT THE IT
IT'S A NEITHER HOUSE TOOK ACTION
ON THE MAY BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSALS RELATED TO THE
CREATION OF THE OFFICE OF THE
SURGEON GENERAL.
OKAY AND WHAT WAS THAT AMOUNT
THAT IN THE NAVY BASE FOR THAT.
YOU TOO WE NEED TO LOOK UP I
BELIEVE IT'S RIVER WAS.
SIX POSITION IS ABOUT SIX SIX
POSITIONS AND WE CAN LOOK UP THE
ASSOCIATED FUNDING NUMBER.
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE ROGER -- THE DIRECTOR OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IS DOCTOR KAREN
LEE SMITH.
IS AN INFECTIOUS DISEASE
SPECIALIST IN. ONE OF HER
PREDECESSORS WAS ACTUALLY THE
CHIEF MEDICAL.
ORANGE COUNTY AND AND SO YOU
HAVE SOMEONE IN THAT POSITION.
TO OVERSEE ALL OF THE HEALTH OF
OF OF THE STATE AND ITS FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES AND I'M.
I'M TRYING [inaudible]
TO FIGURE OUT.
THE EFFICACY OF A A SURGEON
GENERAL IS IT IS A DUPLICATIVE
IS A REDUNDANT.
OF YOURS A VISIONARY I'M.
I'M I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT WHAT WAS NOT OCCURRING THAT.
REQUIRED THE APPOINTMENT OF THE
SURGEON GENERAL AND IS THAT THE
BEST WAY TO RESOLVE.
WHAT WAS NOT BEING DONE SO ALL
SPEAK BRIEFLY BRIEFLY THAN HAPPY
TO TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES
AS WELL SO THE OUGHT THE
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
CONTINUES TO PLAY?
THE KEY ROLE WHEN IT COMES TO
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
HOW THE GOVERNOR AND
ADMINISTRATION -- ENVISIONING
THE SURGEON GENERAL AS SOMEONE
WHO IS A CLEAR LEADER ON
SPECIFIC ISSUES THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT ARE KEY TO PUBLIC
HEALTH -- ON ISSUED ON IN THIS
CASE EARLY CHILDHOOD ISSUES SO
IN THE FIRST APPOINTEE DOCTOR
NADINE BURKE HARRIS HAS REALLY
DEVELOPED -- EXPERTISE AND
PROGRAMS WHEN IT COMES TO
DEALING WITH THE CHILD TO TRAUMA
WITH ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES AND SO WE SEE THIS
OFFICE AS REALLY SHINING A
SPOTLIGHT ON THOSE SPECIFIC
ISSUES.
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
DIRECTION.
WOULDN'T A POSITION LIKE THAT BE
BETTER.
SITUATED WITH THE FIRST FIVE
COMMISSION YOU'VE ALREADY GOT A
REVENUE SOURCE WITH PROP.
TEN SO THE SO THE FIRST TYPE IS
ONGOING AND AND THERE ARE NUMBER
PROGRAMS FUNDED.
AND THAT HAS BOTH THE STATE AND
LOCAL PRESENCE WE REALLY SEE
THIS OFFICE AS PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION AND REFLECTING
SOME THESE KEY PRIORITIES THAT
NOT ONLY THE GOVERNOR.
HAS PUT SO MUCH TIME AND THOUGHT
INTO BUT MANY OF THE LEGISLATORS
AS WELL.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS.
CAN YOU SEE NONE THANK YOU BLOOM
KEY HOLE THAT I PUT OUT ITEM
OPEN
AND MOVE ON TO ISSUE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH WORKSOURCE DEVELOPMENTS.
BEN JOHNSON WITH THE LA -- AGAIN.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURE
AUTHORITY OF FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT MENTAL HEALTH
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT -- THROUGH
EXISTING PROGRAMS AT THE OFFICE
OF STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT.
THE SENATE ADOPTED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BUT
ALLOCATED ONE MILLION DOLLARS OF
THIS FUNDING TO PROVIDE LOAN
REPAYMENT SPECIFICALLY FOR
FORMER FOSTER USED TO OUR
SERVING AS HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS.
IT THE SENATE ALSO APPROVED TWO
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
FUNDING FOR PSYCHIATRY
FELLOWSHIPS.
THE ASSEMBLY ADOPTED THE
GOVERNOR'S A PROPOSAL BUT SET
ASIDE SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE LOAN
REPAYMENTS FOR FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH AND DEDICATED TWO POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. FOR IT TO
FUND PSYCHIATRY FELLOWSHIP SO
THE DIFFERENCES HERE TODAY THAT
YOU'RE CONSIDERING ARE THE
AMOUNT OF EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
FOR FORMER FOSTER USE -- THAT
ARE MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND IN
THE ASSEMBLY VERSES ONE MILLION
IN THE SENATE.
AND THEN THE FUNDING SOURCE FOR
THE PSYCHIATRY FELLOWSHIPS
WHETHER OR NOT IT WOULD BE A
PART OF THIS FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR APPROPRIATION OR WOULD BE
SEPARATELY FUNDED ON TOP OF THE
THE FIFTY MILLION WITH MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES DOLLARS.
THANK YOU OF FINANCE PLEASE IN
MINISTRATION SUPPORTS FIFTY NINE
DOLLAR PREPARATION BUT WITHOUT
SET ASIDES TO PRESERVE MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY [inaudible]
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THURROCK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THE SENATE
IS PROPOSING TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS A MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FUNDS.
DOES THAT REQUIRED SPECIFIC
LEGISLATION OR DOES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAVE
ACCESS TO THE MHSAA -- I DON'T
BELIEVE THIS WOULD REQUIRE ANY
SPECIFIC LEGISLATION AYE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THIS IS FROM
THE STATE ADMINISTRATIVE CAP
WHICH IS HISTORICALLY FUNDING
THAT THE STATE HAS USED FOR
VARIOUS PURPOSES.
YOU KNOW FOR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES RELATED ACTIVITIES AND
AND AND THIS SEEMS LIKE IT WOULD
BE AN ELIGIBLE USE.
Q. AND THEN ARM HOW DOES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FEEL WITH
THE IDEA THIS PROPOSED BY BOTH
THE SIN IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THAT
IS TO FIND.
PSYCHIATRY FELLOWSHIPS.
SO IT'S NOT IN OUR PROPOSAL
ALTERNATE OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
TO PROVIDE SOME DETAILS.
GEN ONE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO
THIS REQUEST BY THE INCLUSION BY
THE LEGISLATURE'S CONSISTENT
WITH A ONE MILLION DOLLAR.
GRANT FOR THE SAME PROGRAM THOSE
INCLUDED LAST YEAR -- WE WILL
NOTE THAT THE GRANT LAST YEAR
WAS FOR ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
AS OF FEBRUARY THE GRANT CYCLE
HAS CLOSED AND OF THAT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ARE SPENT ONLY
GRANTED SIX HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. TO THIS
PROGRAM WE ALSO KNOW THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS GENERALLY RUN BY THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
AND PRIME MAKES MORE SENSE TO BE
ADMINISTERED BY THAT DEPARTMENT.
ORANGE COUNTY'S ONLY PRODUCING
NINE PSYCHIATRIST A YEAR WE HAVE
SUCH A DEMAND.
SO I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT WE
CAN DO.
TO KIND OF HELP.
PRIME THE PUP.
SO -- DROPPING IT COMPLETELY
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT'S THE RIGHT
ANSWER SO MAYBE WE PUT IN SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR THIS YEAR.
I THINK CONSISTENT WITH THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
PROVIDES BROUGHT FLEXIBILITY
THAT WHICH COULD INCLUDE FUNDING
FOR PSYCHIATRY FELLOWSHIP.
THIS SPECIFIC AUGMENTATION BY
THE LEGISLATURE DIRECTS THESE
DOLLARS TO GO DIRECTLY TO THE
SINGLE PROGRAM WHICH IS OPERATE
AT UC DAVIS AND UC IRVINE.
SO THE OF ADMINISTRATIONS VIEW
OF THIS PROPOSALS TO REMIT --
MAINTAIN THAT BROUGHT
FLEXIBILITY OKAY THEN I SAY DROP
UC DAVIS [inaudible]
JUST GETTING -- JUST A LITTLE
LEVITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUC THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL THIS
ITEM OPEN ISSUE. FIVE SIXTY FIVE
PUBLIC USE FILE ACCESS A
STRICTLY OFSHE BED MADE
AVAILABLE PUBLIC USE FILES WHICH
ARE DATA SETS THAT SHOW PATIENT
LEVEL HOSPITAL INPATIENT
UTILIZATION DATA.
THESE DATA SETS ARE NO LONGER
AVAILABLE -- AS OF TWENTY
FIFTEEN THE GOVERNOR HAD NO
PROPOSAL RELATED TO THIS ITEM
AND THE SENATE TOOK NO ACTION
RELATED TO THIS ITEM THE
ASSEMBLY ADOPTED PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL TO RESTORE ACCESS
TO THE PUBLIC USE FILES AT
CONSISTENT WITH PAST PRACTICE.
FINANCE WE SUPPORT THE SENATE ON
THIS ITEM.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS.
XENA THANK YOU ISSUE SIX THREE
VERSION AJ BED [inaudible]
ALEA.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT --
PER ALLOCATED SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
TO SPREAD TO DEVELOP AN ALL
PAYER CLAIMS DATABASE.
THE GOVERNOR HAD NO PROPOSAL
RELATED TO THIS ITEM.
AND THIS CURRENT YEAR.
THE SENATE REVERTED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF THE SIXTY
MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION -- THAT WAS
ALLOCATED HERE -- WHILE THE
ASSEMBLY TOOK NO ACTION -- IT'S
OUR UNDERSTANDNG THAT UNDER THE
SENATE'S ACTION IT'S NOT A
SIGNAL OF NOT WISHING -- TO
PURSUE THE ALL PAYER CLAIMS
DATABASE ANYMORE BUT INSTEAD IT
THE ENCOURAGES OFSHE PAD TO SEEK
THROUGH BUDGET PROPOSALS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING -- TO
CONTINUE DEVELOPMENT OF THE ALL
PAYER CLAIMS DATABASE WE WERE
JUST BRING UP A COUPLE
CONSIDERATIONS -- ON ONE ON THE
ONE HAND WE DO THINK IT IT DOES
HAVE THE REVERSION DOES HAVE
POTENTIAL -- TO DIMMITT MITIGATE
THE MOMENTUM OF CREATING THE ALL
PAYER CLAIMS DATA BASIC -- AS AJ
BED IS CURRENTLY ENGAGING
STAKEHOLDERS -- CARRYING OUT
CONTRACTS AND SO FORTH ON THE
OTHER HAND GOING THROUGH -- THE
THE THE STANDARD SORT OF
BUDGETARY PROCESS COULD CREATE --
INCREASE FISCAL TRANSPARENCY AS
NEW BUDGET PROPOSALS WOULD COME
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE -- FOR
THE NEXT STAGES OF DEVELOPMENT
OF THE DATABASE [inaudible]
FINANCE.
THE ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTS
ASSEMBLY ON THIS PROPOSAL AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THE SENATE PROPOSAL
COULD WAIT TO UNCERTAINTY
WAITING TO DELAYS IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE DATABASE
[inaudible]
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
MR MAYES YEAH I JUST WANTED TO
I'M GLAD TO HEAR THAT FROM BY
THE ADMINISTRATION DOES BE
SUPPORT OF OF THIS -- OF THIS
INITIATIVE -- FOR THE ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE -- THIS WAS A A
BIG WIN -- BECAUSE WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT COST CONTAINMENT -- IT
SEEMS TO BE THE THE KEY TERM --
IN REGARDS TO HEALTH CARE BUT
THE TRUTH IS AND MAYBE I'D EVEN
CALLED THE DIRTY LITTLE SECRET
IS THAT WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TRYING TO CONTAIN COSTS WITH OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW.
AND THIS PROGRAM THIS INITIATIVE --
TO BE FULLY FUNDED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE DATA SO WE CAN
START TO UNDERSTAND.
HOW IMPORTANT AND WHAT ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
PRODUCE OF REDUCE COSTS I'M
THANKFUL FOR THAT?
I GUESS I DON'T REALLY FULLY
UNDERSTAND AT THE SENATE
PROPOSAL I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S
ANYBODY HERE THEY CAN CAN SPEAK
TO THAT -- BUT I DO THINK THAT --
IF IF WE WERE TO IMPLEMENT THE
SENATE PROPOSAL THEN THERE WOULD
BE UNCERTAINTY AND WHETHER THIS
PROGRAM IS GOING TO GO FORWARD.
I THOUGHT YOU WERE LEANING AND
LIKE YOU HAVE THE ANSWER.
ANY OTHER SENATOR NIELSEN.
THE VERBIAGE HERE WOULD APPEAR
TO ME.
TO INDICATE THAT THE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S BODY AND TO
THIS ALL PAYER.
PLAN IS THAT CORRECT OR IS THIS
JUST GOING TO BE AN ADDRESS STEP
TOWARDS EVALUATING.
THE MERITS FOR THE DEMERITS THIS
REACHED ANYMORE LIKE IT'S YOU
KNOW WE'RE JUST TRYING TO
SUBSTANTIATE NOT REALLY REVIEW.
SO THIS IS SPECIFICALLY -- FROM
LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ACT FOR THE
CREATION OF A DATABASE OKAY.
MISTER MOORE Là.
SO ANSWERED MY QUESTION SIXTY
MILLION WAS APPROPRIATED FIVE
MILLION WAS SPENT ANTICIPATED
SPENT FIVE MILLION THIS YEAR.
LEAVES FIFTY MILLION AND SPENT.
LOADING SEEMS LIKE INSTEAD OF
JUST KEEPING AN OPEN CHECKBOOK
YOU PULL THE FIFTY MILLION BACK.
AND THEN IT HAVE THIS DEPARTMENT
COME BACK TO YOU [inaudible] FOR
AN APPROPRIATION TWO YEARS HENCE
RATE.
SO IN TERMS OF THE PLANNING
TIMELINE THE BILL THAT REQUIRE
THIS DATABASE TO BE CREATE ALSO
REQUIRED TO STAKEHOLDER PROCESS --
DEVELOP A CHOIR INPUT AND
DEVELOPMENT WHEN LOOKING AT THE
INFORMATION THAT.
OFFERED WOULD COLLECT FOR THESE
PURPOSES AND SO THERE HAS BEEN A
APPROXIMATELY ESTIMATE TEN LINE
TO BE SPENT AND KERN YOUR AND
BUDGET YEAR HOWEVER AND BUT YOUR
PLUS.
ONE THE THE SIGNIFICANT COSTS
RELATED WITH THIS PROPOSAL IS
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THAT DATABASE
AND IT IS US MAN RIGHT NOW THAT
DAVIS WILL START IMPLEMENTATION --
START DEVELOPING THAT DATABASE
AND BUDGET YEAR PLUS -- ONE ONE
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THAT
DATABASE HE WILL GO THROUGH THE
REGULAR -- PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE DOCUMENTATION WITH ALL
IT PROJECTS AND SO THERE WILL BE
SOME FOR THE VISIBILITY ON THAT
BUT IN TERMS OF THE SLOWER RAMP
UP IS BECAUSE AUTHORED AND
FOCUSED ON THAT STAKEHOLDER
WORKGROUP TOGETHER THE INPUT FOR
THE DAY THAT THEY'LL BE MOST
USEFUL. FOR INDIVIDUALS LONG
START COLLECTING IT.
THANK YOU SEEM SIMILAR TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ONLINE CAMPUS
ALL STOP HERE.
THANK YOU MANAGER.
KING STOPPED AFTER HE SAID IT
BUT OKAY STOP.
FULLER ROBB FOLLOWED BY SENATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING.
WELL IF IF YOU HAVEN'T COMPLETED
THE PROJECT CLOSE SO APPROVAL
PROCESS HAVE YOU DETERMINE THE
SCOPE OF THE PROJECT AND HOW
MUCH IT'S GOING TO COST.
I MEAN I WASN'T INVOLVED IN THIS
AND I DIDN'T I DON'T SIT ON THIS.
SUBCOMMITTEE SO I HAVE HAD SOME
EXPERIENCE WITH IT PROJECTS IN
THE PAST.
THAT'S A FAIR QUESTION I THINK
WHEN THIS.
AUGMENTATION AND PROPOSAL WAS
INITIALLY BUILT ON THE BUDGET
LAST YEAR -- AT THAT TIME THERE
WAS AGREED UPON THAT SIXTY NINE
WAS A GOOD PLACE TO START I
THINK IF THE PROJECT ENDS UP
COMING IN LOWER THERE WOULD
DEFINITELY BE SAVING CELL RIVER
AT THAT TIME.
IF IT COMES IN HIRE WE WILL HAVE
A PROPOSAL THAT WE WILL BRING
FOR THIS LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU THE MANAGER.
HOMELESS SITTING.
I I WOULD YEAH I WOULD JUST ECHO--
MY COLLEAGUE MISTER MADE HIS
COMMENTS I MEAN THIS WAS.
PART OF A BUDGET AGREEMENT THAT
WE DID LAST YEAR -- IT WAS ONE
OF THE FIRST STEP THAT WE WANTED
TO TAKE TOWARD.
UNIVERSAL HEALTH CARE AS WELL AS
COST CONTAINMENT.
ON HIS WEEDS FAMILY DIFFICULT.
TO FURTHER EXPAND HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE WITHOUT REALLY KNOWING
WHAT THE COSTS ARE AND IF THERE
ARE MORE EFFICIENT AND BETTER IN
A WAY TO DO IT SO THIS WAS.
SEEN AS A VERY GOOD FIRST STEP
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CONTINUING. TO
FOLLOW UP AND GET THE STATED
BASED ON BUT WE DO KNOW OR AT
LEAST.
AT LEAST THE ASSEMBLY FELT THAT.
WITHOUT THIS FIRST THAT WOULD BE
VERY VERY DIFFICULT TO GET AT
TWO OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES
SURROUNDING HEALTH CARE ONE ON
COST CONTAINMENT AS WELL AS
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE THAT THIS
DATABASE HAVE HAVING THESE DATA.
WAS EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT TO
REALLY GET WRITING GET RIGHT THE
FIRST TIME SO WE CONTINUE TO BE
VERY SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS [inaudible]
WITH SKINNER.
I'M THIS MAY HAVE COME UP SO
APOLOGIES YOU CAN STOP ME IF
IT'S ALREADY ASKED WHEN I WAS
TALKING WITH STAFF BUT A NOTE
THAT THE LA YO -- IT
[inaudible]
XPRESSBET.
OUR NOT OKAY POLICIES.
DONE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
MOVING ON ISSUE SEVEN DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
THE MANAGED CARE ORGANIZATION
TAX.
LA -- WE'VE DONE WE SHOULD ALL
HAVE IN YOUR PACKETS A HAND OUT
THAT WE CREATED ON THE MCO TAX
NO USE THAT AS THE BASIS FOR MY
REMARKS HERE.
ON PAGE ONE THE JUST PROVIDE --
SOME BRIEF BACK BACKGROUND --
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS RULES
THAT REGULATE STATE'S HEALTH
CARE RELATED TAXES TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY ARE USED TO DRAW DOWN
FEDERAL FUNDS.
WITH THE THE PRINCIPALLY TO
RECEIVE FEDERAL APPROVAL A STATE
MUST PROVE THAT I AT THAT HEALTH
CARE RELATED TAX DOES NOT
DISPROPORTIONATELY OR I SHOULD
SAY TO DISPROPORTIONATELY FALLEN
MEDICAID AS OPPOSED TO NON
MEDICAID.
SERVICES.
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY HAS A TAX
ON HEALTH CARE RELATED TAX ON
MANAGED CARE ORGANIZATIONS OR M.
CEOS IT IS HAVE THIS TAX SINCE
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND IS
A PER MEMBER PER MONTH TAX ON
MEDI CAL AND COMMERCIAL
ENROLLMENT -- WITHIN M. CEOS IT
FEATURES A TIERED RATE STRUCTURE --
WHERE BY THE TAX RATE VARIES
BASED ON MEDI CAL VERSUS
COMMERCIAL OR NON MEDI CAL
ENROLLMENT AS WELL AS BY THE
ENROLLMENT -- THE NUMBER OF
ENROLLEES THAT MCO HAS THIS TAX
THE CURRENT TAX EXPIRES AT THE
END OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
INCLUDED IN THE NCO TAX PACKAGE
WERE SOME REDUCTIONS TO SOME
OTHER TAT STATE TAXES THAT NCOS%
PAY.
US SPECIFICALLY TO THEIR
CORPORATION TAXES ON THEIR ON
THEIR MCO INCOME AS WELL AS ON
THE INSURANCE PREMIUM REVENUE
GENERATED BY CORPORATE
AFFILIATES OF THE MCO.
THE EXISTING TAX IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IS ESTIMATED
TO GENERATE ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN NET GENERAL
FUND BENEFIT TAKING ACCOUNT BOTH
OF THE REVENUES AS WELL AS THE
REDUCE STAFF -- THE REVENUES
FROM THE MCO TAXES WAS THE
REDUCE STEMS REVENUES FROM THAT
CUTS TO THE CORPORATION AND
INSURANCE TAXES.
TURNING TO PAGE -- TWO WHILE THE
MCO TAX DOES GENERATE THIS --
THIS ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR NET GENERAL FUND BENEFIT
IS ACTUALLY ESTIMATED TO LEAVE
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH INSURANCE
INDUSTRY OVERALL.
NO WORSE OFF SO THEIR NET TAXES
UNDER THE FULL -- MCO DEAL AS AN
INDUSTRY ARE NOT X. ARE ARE
ESTIMATED TO HAVE NOT INCREASED --
OVER WHAT THEY WOULD OTHERWISE
pCERTAIN PLANS CERTAIN THEM CIOS
TO SEE THEIR TAX LIABILITY GOING
UP WHILE OTHERS SEE IT
DECREASING.
THE MCO TAX EXPIRES AT THE END
OF THIS FISCAL YEAR -- AND THIS
WILL ELIMINATE THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR NET GENERAL
FUND BENEFIT.
TURNING TO PAGE -- THREE
LEGISLATIVE STAFF -- THIS YEAR
REQUESTED THAT THE LA L. MODEL --
OPTIONS FOR RE AUTHORIZED MCO
TAX PACKAGE TAKING INTO ACCOUNT.
CHANGES IN THE HEALTH INSURANCE
INDUSTRY MOST NOTABLY -- CHANGE
CONSOLIDATION WITHIN THE MARKET
AS WELL AS CHANGES OVER TIME IN
MCO ENROLLMENT.
WE HAD SEVERAL OBJECTIVES THAT
WE WERE -- PURSUING IN IN
MODELING -- RE AUTHORIZE TAX
NUMBER ONE THAT IT COMPLIES WITH
THE FEDERAL RULES ON HEALTH CARE
RELATED TAXES.
GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE OF DRAWING
DOWN FEDERAL FUNDS. TWO WOULD BE
TO MAINTAIN OR INCREASE THE NET
GENERAL FUND ENEFIT -- OVER THE
SO ACT OR ABOVE THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLAR NET BENEFIT.
THREE WAS PROTECT VULNERABLE AND
CEOS FROM NEGATIVE IMPACTS US
SOME M. CIOS.
CAN SEE LARGE INCREASES IN THEIR
TAX LIABILITY BUT ARE
COMPENSATED BY ANY OFFSETS --
ESPECIALLY SOME SMALL ONES SO WE
LOOK TO MINIMIZE THOSE IMPACTS.
AND THEN WE ALSO TRIED TO
MINIMIZE THE NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON
THE INDUSTRY OVERALL -- FOR
EXAMPLE WE TRIED.
TO REDUCE THE VARIATION BETWEEN
THE COMMERCIAL RATES EFFECTIVE --
COMMERCIAL TAX RATES THAT
DIFFERENT M. CIOS WOULD PAY --
THEREFORE LEVELING -- LEVELING
REALLY LEVELING THE PLAYING
FIELD IN TERMS OF THAT THE
OVERALL TAX THEIR THEM COS TAX
LIABILITY.
WOULD PROVIDED SEVERAL OPTIONS --
ONE WOULD BE TO MAINTAIN THE
EXISTING MCO TAXES TEARS AND
RATES BUT APPLY IT TO UPDATED
ENROLLMENT. TO WOULD BE TO
MARGINALLY INCREASE -- THAT TAX
RATES BUT KEEP THE TAX TEARS THE
SAME AND THEN THREE WOULD BE TO
KEEP THE TAX TEARS BUT REALLY
SICK MORE SIGNIFICANTLY MODIFY
THE RATES -- AND ALL THREE OF
THESE OPTIONS OVERALL INCLUDED
TO THE OFFSETS TO OR THE
REDUCTIONS TO THE CORPORATION
AND INSURANCE TAXES -- UNDER
UNDER OUR MODEL THIS THIRD
OPTION WITH THE MORE
SIGNIFICANTLY MODIFIED RATES
INCREASE THE NET GENERAL FUND
BENEFIT TO ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS AND ALSO.
LEFT THE HEALTH INSURANCE
INDUSTRY BETTER OFF THAN IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN UNDER THE OTHER
OPTIONS.
TURNING TO PAGE -- FIVE HERE
WE'RE GOING TO COMPARE THE MCO
TAX PACKAGES OF THE GOVERNOR AS
WELL AS THE TWO HOUSES.
THE GOVERNOR AS YOU ALL KNOW DID
NOT PROPOSE AN EXTENSION OF THAT --
MCO TAX PACKAGE THE THEIR BY FOR
GOING IN THE ONE POINT FIVE FOR
MORE BILLION DOLLAR NET GENERAL
FUND BENEFIT.
THE SENATE APPROVED A THREE YEAR
RE AUTHORIZATION OF THE MCO TAX
WITH THE MODIFIED RATES
GENERATING IN THAT GENERAL FUND
BENEFIT ON AN ANNUAL BASIS OF
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED A FOUR
YEAR RE AUTHORIZATION OF THE TAX --
WITH THE MODIFIED RATES.
AND THIS ALSO WAS THE PACKAGE
THAT WOULD GENERATE THE NET
GENERAL OF THE BENEFIT OF ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
SO ULTIMATELY THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY BOTH ADOPTED REALLY THE
SAME MCO TAX PACKAGE -- THE ONE
THAT GENERATES THE GREATEST NET
GENERAL FUND BENEFIT AND THE ONE
THAT REDUCES -- OR GENERATES
ALSO THE GREATEST FISCAL BENEFIT
FOR THE HEALTH INSURANCE
INDUSTRY AND THAT WE HAD THAT WE
HAD MODELED AT THAT TIME -- IF
YOU TURN TO PAGE SIX WE HAVE A
WE HAVE A FIGURE THAT REALLY
SUMMARIZES THAT MODEL I WON'T GO
INTO ALL THE DETAILS.
OF THAT BUT HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW THAT
STRUCTURED AND HOW IT IT
IMPROVES.
THE OVERALL OUTCOMES.
THE FIGURE -- THEN THE FIGURE ON
PAGE SEVEN SUMMARIZES LE THOSE
DIFFERENCES IN TERMS OF THE NET
GENERAL FUND BENEFIT AS WELL AS
THE NET FISCAL BENEFIT FOR THE
HEALTH INSURANCE INDUSTRY SO YOU
SEE THAT THE THE NET GENERAL
FUND BENEFIT WOULD INCREASE BY
ALMOST THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS UNDER THE THE MODEL.
THAT WAS ADOPTED BY BOTH HOUSES.
AND THAT THE NET FISCAL BENEFIT
FOR THE HEALTH INSURANCE
INDUSTRY WOULD INCREASE FROM OF
FIVE OR CLOSE TO ZERO BECAUSE
THERE IS A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY
THERE TO THAT CLOSER TO NINETY
THREE YEAR CLOSE TO A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. TO SUMMARIZE
THE DIFFERENCES.
BETWEEN THE TWO HOUSES.
THE MADE THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCES IN THAT TIME PERIOD
FOR WHICH THE HOUSES WOULD RE
AUTHORIZE THE TAX THE SENATE RE
AUTHORIZED FOR THREE YEAR PERIOD
AND THE ASSEMBLY RE AUTHORIZE
THEM CO TAX PACKAGE FOR A FOUR
YEAR PERIOD.
THE REMAINING DIFFERENCES REALLY
REFLECTED TECHNICAL DIFFERENCE
IN TERMS OF NGUYEN SAVINGS FROM
THE TAX OR WHEN THE NET GENERAL
FUND BENEFIT IS REALLY --
MATERIALIZING WITHIN HOW WEAK
ACCOUNT.
FOR ACCOUNT FOR THE ULTIMATE
SAVINGS THE SENATE APPROVED A
PACKAGE WHERE BY THE STATE MORE
SAVINGS WOULD MATERIALIZE IN THE
BUDGET YEAR -- WHEREAS THE
ASSEMBLY SUPPORT A PACKAGE WHERE
A SOMEWHAT LESSER SAVINGS WOULD
MATERIALIZE ADDITIONALLY IN THE
BUDGET YEAR I'D NOTE THAT ANY
SAVINGS THAT DON'T INITIATIVE
THAT DON'T MATERIALIZE IN THAT
BUDGET YEAR WOULD ULTIMATELY
BECOME AVAILABLE IN THE
SUBSEQUENT YEARS SO THIS IS
REALLY A TECHNICAL DIFFERENCE.
AS TO THE TIMING OF WHEN THE
SAVINGS ARE THE NET GENERAL FUND
BENEFIT WOULD MATERIALIZE.
TURNING TO PAGE EIGHT WE PROVIDE
A A MULTI YEAR OUTLOOK ON WHILE
WINDOWS SAVINGS WOULD OR THE NET
GENERAL FUND BENEFIT WOULD
MATERIALIZE.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BOTH IN TERMS OF THE
FIRST YEAR -- HOW MUCH THE HOW
MUCH SAVINGS WOULD BE AVAILABLE
AND THEN ALSO IN THE LAST YEAR
AND THAT'S PRIMARILY REFLECTING
THE LONGER TIME PERIOD RE
AUTHORIZATION UNDER THE
ASSEMBLIES PACKAGE?
OF THOUGH RIGHT MOST COLUMN JESS
IS THERE TO INDICATE THAT FOR
ALL THE YEARS OF THE TAX WOULD
BE RE AUTHORIZED THE AVERAGE NET
GENERAL FUND BENEFIT IS
IDENTICAL BETWEEN THE HOUSES.
NEXT JUST TURNED TO A A FEW LA
OF COMMENTS THAT WE SENT OVER TO
STAFF -- THERE ARE SOME KEY
DESIGN CONSIDERATIONS THAT
REMAIN OUTSTANDING -- FOR
EXAMPLE -- WE HAVEN'T
ESTABLISHED OUT YOUR TAX RATES
THAT WE WOULD WANT TO APPLY AND
IF WE WANT TO MAINTAIN -- THE
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR --
GENERAL FUND BENEFIT YOU'D
PROBABLY WANT TO INCREASE THOSE
TAX RATES MARGINALLY ON A YEAR
OVER YEAR BASIS -- ALSO WE DON'T
HAVE A WE DON'T HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION ON WHICH IS THE
MOST -- TECHNICALLY ACCURATE
REFLECTION OF WHAT SAVINGS OR
BENEFIT WOULD MATERIALIZE IN THE
BUDGET YEAR AND WE REALLY --
WOULD JUST RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ASKING
ADMINISTRATION ON WHAT THE BEST
ASSUMPTIONS ARE -- FOR WHAT
SAVINGS ARE MOST LIKELY TO
MATERIALIZE -- DURING DURING THE
BUDGET WINDOW SO WITH THAT HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS FROM FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
FROM FINANCE FIRST AND THEN
WE'LL OPEN UP TO COMMITTEE.
SAID THE NCO TAX HAS BEEN AN
IMPORTANT ELEMENT WITH ASSOCIATE
REVENUES UP FINANCING THE
STATE'S HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND
IT SHOULD CONTINUE TO BE THAT
WAY IN THE FUTURE.
HOWEVER GIVEN THE CURRENT
ENVIRONMENT -- WE KNOW THAT
APPROVAL OF AN EXTENSION OF THIS
TAX IS UNCERTAIN FOR THAT REASON
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION.
DO NOT SUPPORT INCLUDING ANY
ASSOCIATED REVENUES WERE
ALLOCATION OF THOSE REVENUES AS
PART OF THIS BUDGET PROCESS AND
FOR THAT SAME REASON THE BUDGET
THAT WE PUT FORWARD INTHE NAY
REVISION.
FUNDS THE GOVERNOR'S AT NEW
HEALTH CARE INITIATIVE PROPOSALS
WITHOUT RELYING ON MCO TAX
REVENUE.
THE GOVERNOR IN THE MINISTRATION
ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE LATER THIS
SESSION ON FIGURING OUT THE BEST
PATH FORWARD IN BUILDING THE
STRONGEST POSSIBLE CASE FOR AN
EXTENSION OF THE MTO TAX.
THAT WILL MEET FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT APPROVAL BUT WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT IT SHOULD BE
PART OF THE BUDGET PROCESS.
SENATOR MOORE Là FOLLOWED BY MR
MAYS AND MISTER MCCARTY THIRTY
MORE LAW THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THE THE SIM CO WAS PART OF A
SPECIAL SESSION A FEW YEARS AGO
AND HAD THE JOY OF SERVING.
ON THAT AS WELL.
AND IT WAS A RUBIK'S CUBE TO
CONSTRUCT THE TAX STRUCTURE OF
OF AND SO ON PAGE SIX YOU KIND
OF SEE [inaudible]
HOW?
UNIQUE IT IS WHERE [inaudible]
WE'RE CHARGING.
NCOS WITH SMALLER ENROLLMENTS A
LOT MORE THAN WE ARE WITH THE
WITH LARGE ENROLLMENTS.
IN SO I'M CURIOUS ABOUT A COUPLE
OF QUICK THINGS.
WHAT HAVE BEEN THE NUMBER OF
MERGERS?
SINCE TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
WHEN IT WAS IMPLEMENTED -- I CAN
I CAN GET BACK TO YOU ON THAT
EXACT ANSWER A COUPLE OF THE
MAJOR ONES -- THAT WEREN'T
NECESSARILY INCLUDED IN LAST
PACKAGE WHERE -- BLUESHIELD --
PURCHASING A MEDI CAL PLAN KNOWN
AS FORMALLY KNOWN AS CARE FIRST.
AS WELL AS CENTENE CORPORATION --
PURCHASING HEALTH NET SO THOSE
ARE THE MAJOR -- THE MAJOR
CONSOLIDATIONS IN THE INDUSTRY.
AND WAS THE MCO TAX A COMPONENT
OF THE DECISION PROCESS YOU KNOW.
I'M NOT AWARE OF IT BEING A A
MAJOR COMPONENT THERE AND YOU
HAVE A H. C. S. P..
IT DOES IS THAT REFERRING TO
JUST NONPROFIT HOSPITAL NCOS
VERSES FOR PROFIT -- NOT
NECESSARILY THAT IT REALLY IT
DID AS A SET OF CRITERIA THAT
YOU HAVE TO MEET TODAY TO MEET
THE CRITERIA AS AN H. C. S. P..
AND KAISER -- HEALTH PLAN IS THE
ONLY -- HEALTH PLAN THAT MEETS
THOSE CRITERIA CURRENTLY.
OKAY SO THE KAISER PERMANENTE
IMPACT IS IS SEEN.
WITH THIS ONE THROUGH EIGHT
MILLION.
YES AND SO THAT IS NOT THAT DOES
NOT REPRESENT ALL OF THEIR LIVES
IT ACTUALLY -- STOPS AND AT A
SMALLER SUBSET OF THE THEIR
ENROLLEES RESERVED DISTINCTION
ON THE TAX BASED ON WHETHER YOU
ARE FOR PROFIT TAXABLE VERSES A
NONPROFIT NON TAXABLE NOT ON THE
MCO TAX SIDEBUT THE THE RELATED
REDUCTIONS ON THE CORPORATION
TAX SIDE TO PLAY INTO WHETHER OR
NOT YOU.
CAN -- HEALTH PLAN CAN RECEIVE
ANY OFFSETS FOR SOME OF THE
LIABILITIES THAT THEY WOULD FACE
UNDER THE MCO TAX PROPER.
DOES THAT INCLUDE TAX CREDITS --
I WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON THE TAX CREDIT QUESTION.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- THIS
WAS -- EARLY INTO ME BEING -- AT
THE LEADER ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
AND I REMEMBER IT WAS SORT OF
THE FIRST -- DEAL -- THAT WE
HADN'T DONE WITH THE WITH THEN I
GOVERNOR BROWN.
AND I REMEMBER SOME OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'RE HAVING --
INTERNALLY WITHIN OUR CAUCUS WE
WE GET TOGETHER -- YOU KNOW TEN
OR ELEVEN OF US AND WHAT WE IT
AT THE TIME I MEMBER
UNDERSTANDING IT -- AS MUCH AS
ONE COULD UNDERSTAND IT BECAUSE
IT IS A BIT OF A A RUBIK'S CUBE
AND MEMBER OF MAKING THE
ARGUMENT.
ABOUT THESE ARE FEDERAL FEDERAL
DOLLARS -- AND ONE OF THE
MEMBERS ON NEVER FORGET THIS
SAID -- THAT CHAD IF YOU'RE ON
TEAM CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO
SUPPORT THIS -- AND AND I THINK
THAT STILL THE CASE -- WE ARE A
DONOR STATE HOW WE SEND MORE
MONEY TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THAN WHAT WE RECEIVE FROM THEM
AND I HAVE GOT A LITTLE
CONSTERNATION THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ISN'T -- ISN'T
THINKING THAT WE SHOULD GO
FORWARD WITH THIS BECAUSE THIS
IS ONE WAY.
I'M EVEN THE RUBIK'S CUBE AND
THAT IT IS FOR US TO GET SOME OF
THOSE RESOURCES BACK FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- THAT WE
HAVE THAT WE SEND -- SEND --
THAT THAT WAY I HOPE AND AND I
DON'T WANNA AND SUGGEST THAT
THIS IS THE CASE.
BUT I HOPE THAT WE'RE NOT SAYING
THAT -- WE'RE NOT SURE THAT THE
THE THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ONE
AGREE -- TO TO TO OUR PROPOSAL --
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE RHETORIC --
THAT IS BEEN GOING TO HELP THE
POLITICS IT DOESN'T GET IN TO
THIS I'VE BEEN -- MYSELF A
CRITIC OF THE ADMINISTRATION
WHEN THEY ARE WHEN THEY HAVEN'T
BEEN SUPPORTING LIKE THE WILD
FIRES NOT MAKING SURE THAT WE
GOT GET OUR RESOURCES.
BECAUSE THE RHETORIC BUT IT GOES
BOTH THE BILL GOES BOTH WAYS
THIS IS SOMETHING I THINK THAT
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S BILLIONS OF DOLLARS NOT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS -- AND I
THINK IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE GOT
IT WE'VE GOT IN BEFORE I DO
SUPPORT THE ASSEMBLY PLAN.
JUST MAKE ONE COMMENT FROM THAT
DEPARTMENT PLEASE THAT AND IN
RESPONSE FOR SOME WHATEVER MAYES
AND WANT TO CONFIRM THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION.
IS COMMITTED TO FINDING A PATH
FORWARD ON THIS WE WANT TO FIND
A WAY TO GET AN EXTENSION THAT
MEETS FEDERAL APPROVAL WHAT WE
WOULD DO WANNA MAKE SURE HOWEVER
IS THAT WE DO NOT ALLOCATE AND
COMMIT TO SPEND MONEY THAT WERE
NOT ACTUALLY SURE OF RECEIVING
SO ONCE.
WE GOT TO THAT PROCESS ONCE WE
WORK WITH YOU TO BUILD THE BEST
POSSIBLE CASE FOR APPROVAL AND
THEN IF WE DO GET APPROVAL AND
WE CAN FIND A WAY TO ALLOCATE
THE MONEY THAT COMES FROM THAT.
MCCARTY.
THANK YOU I I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH WHAT MR -- THEY SAID IT AND
BEFORE I GET TO THE POLICY THE
POLITICS THERE THAT -- WITHOUT
THIS AND WITHOUT THE OTHER --
TAX CONFORMITY ISSUE NOT BEING
ADDRESSED THERE'S NO THERE'S A
HUGE HOLE IN THE STATE BUDGET
AND THAT'S THE ELEPHANT IN THE
ROOM.
AND DOWN YOU SAY -- THIS IS NOT
A VIABLE WITH THE OTHER ONE BOTH
HOUSES OF SAID HAVE QUESTIONED
THE VIABILITY AS WELL SO -- I
WOULD I WOULD THINK THANK AYE
AYE AND I HAVE HEARD THE
GOVERNOR SPEAK PUBLICLY AND
OTHERS ABOUT THE THE ISSUE WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
MAN A WAIVER IS WE HAVE 2% AND
IT'S A REALLY.
DELICATE ISSUE ON A DAILY BASIS
BUT THIS IS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE
I THINK YOU KNOW.
MY NAME SAY KEVIN MCCARTHY WILL
HAVE A BIG FAT VOICE IN THIS AS
WELL HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE ON OUR
ON PUBLICLY FUNDED HEALTHCARE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BECAUSE
BECAUSE OF WHAT WE HAVE HERE SO
THERE'S A LOT AT STAKE AND I
THINK THAT WE OUGHT.
TO A PROCEED AS AS WE HAVE
BEFORE US HERE IN THIS PROPOSAL
THANK YOU.
AND I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD APPRECIATE IF YOU CALLED
YOUR NAME SAKE AND MR MAYES CALL
THE PRESIDENT.
AND JUST WORK IT OUT WE COULD
ALL BE DONE HERE JUST GET ON THE
PHONE GENTLEMAN L. ALEJO.
I JUST ALL BUT THIS BOND QUICKLY
DO A COUPLE OF POINTS WE WE HAVE
RECOMMENDED THAT -- THAT ACTION
BE TAKEN ON THIS ITEM DURING THE
BUDGET PROCESS GIVEN THAT IT
WOULD FACILITATE.
AB BAM CEOS ARE HEALTH PLANS
SETTING THEIR RATES AND BEING
ABLE TO INCORPORATE ANY NEW
STATE TAXES INTO THEIR RATES
THEY'RE THEY'RE WORKING ON
SETTING THEIR RATES THROUGH THE
SUMMER MONTHS AND SO.
A DELAY IN THE PROCESS IS GOING --
IN THE IN THE ESTABLISHMENT OF A
RE AUTHORIZE TAX IS GOING.
TO CREATE SOME SORT OF CONFLICT
WITH THE TIME LINE FOR
ESTABLISHING NEW NEW -- TAX
RATES THERE ON ANOTHER FRONT AND
NO AND NO DISCOURAGEMENT FROM
THAT REACHING OUT TO MEMBERS.
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THIS IS --
TO SOME DEGREE AN ADMINISTRATIVE
DECISION -- THAT WOULD BE MADE
BY THE THAT BY THIS ON A FEDERAL
CENTERS FOR MEDICARE AND
MEDICAID -- THE FEDERAL
REGULATIONS ARE.
YOU THERE IS SOME AMBIGUITY TO
THEM BUT THEY DO DEFINITELY
POINT -- TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- APPROVING ATTACKS
THAT MEETS THE THE FEDERAL
STANDARDS THAT ARE ENUMERATED IN
THOSE REGULATIONS.
WE THINK THAT THE TAX THAT WE'VE
PUT FORWARD -- IS A IS A IS A
POSSIBLE OPTION THAT DEFINITELY --%
COULD COULD MEET FEDERAL
APPROVAL GIVEN IT'S A PASSING OF
CERTAIN STATISTICAL TESTS AND
OTHER TESTS THAT ARE WITHIN
THOSE FEDERAL REGULATIONS AND SO
WOULD JUST -- WOULD JUST WANNA
THAT NOTE THAT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THERE IS THAT
THERE ARE SORT OF SOMEWHAT
STRICT FEDERAL RULES AROUND US
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OF FINANCING THE FINAL WRAP UP
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
WELL CERTAINLY TEMPTING TO TRY
TO CALL THIS ITEM WILL HOLD AN
OPEN.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE A FULL SCOPE
MEDI CAL FOR UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS.
AGAIN DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ALEJO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR RHYME WILL
SEE WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
THE FIRST COMPONENT OF THIS
ISSUE RELATES TO THE EXPANSION
OF FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL COVERAGE.
FOR OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES TO EXPAND
FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL. TO
OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE UNDOCUMENTED
ADULTS AGES NINETEEN THROUGH
TWENTY FIVE FEDERAL FUND COST OF
SEVENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY THE
ASSEMBLY APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S
EXPANSION -- THE SENATE WENT
FURTHER THAN THE GOVERNOR AND
THE ASSEMBLY.
APPROVING -- AND EXPANSION FOR
THE NINETEEN THROUGH TWENTY FIVE
FOR A POPULATION -- AS WELL AS A
SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER POPULATION
AND TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THE
GENERAL FUND COST OF ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
ADDITIONALLY THE SENATE'S ACTION
WOULD THERE AFTER INCREASE MEDI
CAL ELIGIBILITY BY ONE YEAR OF
AGE EACH CALENDAR YEAR BEGINNING
WITH TWENTY SIX YEAR OLDS.
IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE OUR
OFFICES EVALUATED THE ON GOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS -- OTHER
RESPECTED HOUSES ACTIONS UNDER
THE ASSEMBLY AND GOVERNOR
SPENDING PLANS WE PROJECT THAT
THE ON GOING GENERAL FUND COSTS
WOULD BE.
AROUND TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
EXPANSION TO THE NINETEEN TO
TWENTY FIVE POPULATION -- UNDER
THE SENATE'S PLAN WE PROJECT
THAT THE GENERAL FUND COSTS
WOULD GROW -- EACH YEAR BY
BETWEEN FIFTY AND ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS BEGINNING IN.
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
SECOND.
COMPONENT OF THIS ISSUE -- HAS
NO -- FISCAL ISSUE IN CONFERENCE
IT'S PURELY A LANGUAGE
DIFFERENCE THAT WOULD TAKE
EFFECT -- IN LATER YEARS.
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND COUNTIES
ARE RESPONSIBLE TO PROVIDE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO THEIR
UNINSURED LOW INCOME POPULATIONS --
SOME COUNTIES ADMINISTER THIS
RESPONSIBILITY ON THEIR OWN
WHILE OTHERS -- IN THIRTY FIVE
MOSTLY RURAL COUNTIES THIS
RESPONSIBILITIES ADMINISTERED BY
THE COUNTY MEDICAL SERVICES
PROGRAM -- WHICH IS OVERSEEN BY
A GOVERNING BOARD -- EXPANSIONS
IN MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY SUCH AS
THE ONE BEING CONSIDERED --
TODAY AND PREVIOUS EXPANSIONS IN
THE PAST OF A MUCH LARGER.
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF UNINSURED
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS AND CREATE
SAVINGS FOR COUNTIES IN COST FOR
THE STATE.
IN RECOGNITION OF THIS THE STATE
CURRENTLY RE DIRECTS A PORTION
OF REALIGNMENT REVENUES THAT GO
TO COUNTIES TO SUPPORT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES.
FOR THE UNINSURED TO THE STATE --
THAT REDIRECTION PERCENTAGE FOR
CERTAIN COUNTIES IS CURRENTLY AT
60%.
OF THEM DESPITE THIS REDIRECTION
THE COUNTY MEDICAL SERVICES
PROGRAM BOARD HAS ACCUMULATED A
SIGNIFICANT RESERVE.
ESTIMATED TO BE NEARLY FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS BY THE
BEGINNING OF NINETEEN TWENTY THE
COULD SUSTAIN THE BOARD'S
OPERATIONS FOR SO FOR SEVERAL
YEARS WITHOUT ANY ADDITIONAL NEW
REVENUE.
THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED
STOPPING THE FLOW OF ALL
REALIGNMENT REVENUES.
TO THE COUNTY MEDICAL SERVICES
PROGRAM BOARD UNTIL IT'S
REVENUES ARE REDUCED.
AND AFTER THAT POINT IT WOULD
INCREASE THE REDIRECTION
PERCENTAGE FROM 6275%.
HOWEVER WE WOULD NOTE THAT UNDER
THE COMPLEX REALIGNMENT FUNDING
RULES THIS INCREASE EVERY
DIRECTION WOULD BE FOCUSED ON
THE CMS P. BOARD.
WHICH MEANS THAT IN EFFECT --
THE INCREASE FOR DIRECTION WOULD
REDIRECT ALL OF THE SAME AS P.
BOARDS REVENUES -- EVEN AFTER
ITS ITS RESERVES ARE REDUCED.
BOTH THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY
HAVE ADOPTED THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO STOP THE FLOW OF
REVENUES TO THE SCENE.
BOARD -- BUT THE ASSEMBLY WENT
FURTHER AND SPECIFIED THAT ONCE
THE BOARD'S RESERVES HAVE BEEN
REDUCED IT WOULD RECEIVE
REVENUES -- AN OUTCOME THAT WE
VIEW IS UNLIKELY UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL -- INTERVIEW
EITHER UNDER THE ASSEMBLY OR THE
SENATE ACTION.
AND IT WILL BE IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER IN THE
FUTURE WHAT THE ROLE OF SEEM AS
P. SHOULD BE.
GIVEN POTENTIAL FUTURE
EXPANSIONS IN COVERAGE -- BUT AT
THIS POINT AFTER THE NINETEEN
TWENTY FISCAL YEAR -- THE
LEGISLATURE DOESN'T NEED TO MAKE
A DECISION ABOUT THAT -- AT THIS
POINT.
FINANCE ON THE GENERAL ISSUE OF
EXPANSION OF FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL
COVERAGE AT THE ADMINISTRATION
STAYING WITH ITS MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL OF EXPANSION FROM AGES.
NINETEEN FOR TWENTY FIVE WE
BELIEVE AT THIS TIME THAT
EXPANSIONS BEYOND THOSE AGES
WILL PUT ON GOING COST PRESSURES
ON THE GENERAL FUND THAT WE'RE
NOT SURE WE CAN SUSTAIN.
AT THIS TIME.
ON THE ISSUE OF CMS P.
REDIRECTION I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
MY COLLEAGUE RIDE.
AND BRAIN MILLER DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- LARGELY IN RESPONSE
TO CONCERNS THAT WE HEARD FROM
STAKEHOLDERS ON FRIDAY THE
ADMINISTRATION RELEASED REVISED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
THAT ACTUALLY CHANGED -- THE
REALIGNMENT REDIRECTION AMOUNT
IN THE OUT YEARS TO BE
CONSISTENT WITH ITS CURRENT LAW
LEVEL IN OTHER WORDS -- THE THE
REVISED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS
NOW CONSISTENT WITH THE ASSEMBLY
ACTION -- WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS.
NO QUESTIONS WILL BE THAT ITEM
OPEN.
MOVING ON TO ISSUE NINE PROP
FIFTY SIX SUPPLEMENTAL PROVIDER
RATE AND WE'VE GOT A BLUE PAPER.
AS OPPOSED TO WHITE PAPER.
FROM LA -- AND SO THIS OUR HAND
OUT ACTUALLY TOUCHES ON BOTH --
ITEMS -- ISSUED NINE AND TEN SO
YOU'LL PRESENTABLE YET WE WILL
PRESENT THEM BOTH SIGNED PHOTOS
IF THAT'S OKAY WITH THAT PERFECT
THANK YOU.
A GREAT SO TURNING TO PAGE ONE
JUST TO PROVIDE A LITTLE
BACGROUND -- PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX OF TWENTY SIXTEEN RAISE
TAXES ON TOBACCO PRODUCTS AND
DEDICATES MOST OF THE REVENUE TO
MEDI CAL -- CURRENTLY ABOUT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY GOES TO
MEDIC COW -- AND IT'S GENERALLY
BEEN USED TO THIS STATE FOR ONE
OF TWO PURPOSES FIRST -- TO
AUGMENT THE PROGRAM PRIMARILY BY
INCREASING PROVIDER PAYMENTS IN
MEDICARE AL OR TWO OFFSETTING
GENERAL FUND COSTS OR A GENERAL
FUND SPENDING ON COST GROWTH IN
THE MEDI CAL PROGRAM -- TURNING
THE PAGE -- TO WE NOTE -- IN IN
OUR ESTIMATION SENATE ASSEMBLY
PROPOSITION -- SPENDING PACKAGES
ARE BROADLY SIMILAR -- BUT WITH
SOME DIFFERENCES. FOR THE
SIMILARITIES AND ALSO WITH THE
GOVERNOR -- BOTH HOUSES WOULD
CONTINUE EXISTING MEDI CAL
PROVIDER PAYMENT INCREASES BUT
ESTABLISH NEW SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS PROVIDE -- FOR FUNDING
FOR PHYSICIAN TRAINING IN TRAUMA
SCREENINGS -- AND AUGMENT THE
MEDI CAL STUDENT LOAN REPAYMENT
IN ADDITION BOTH HOUSES ADOPTED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WHICH
WOULD DIRECT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO SEEK
THREE YEAR -- FEDERAL APPROVAL
OF THE PROVIDER PAYMENT
INCREASES AS OPPOSED TO THE
CURRENT PRACTICE IN WHICH DH CS
REQUEST ANNUAL APPROVAL.
NEXT THE AND SO THE FIGURE ON
THIS ON PAGE TWO DOES SUMMARIZE
THE OVERALL PACKAGES BUT I'LL
HIGHLIGHT THE DIFFERENCES HERE
BELOW.
SO STARTING WITH THE FIRST
DIFFERENCE ON ON PAGE.
THREE THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED A IN
THE MAY REVISION -- SUN SETTING
ALL PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX POLICY
AUGMENTATIONS IN MEDI CAL AT THE
END OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
ASSEMBLY.
APPROVED THESE SUNSETS IN ITS
BUDGET PACKAGE -- AND SO UNDER
BOTH THE THE ASSEMBLY AND
GOVERNOR'S PLAN -- INSTEAD OF
FUNDING SAY NEW PROVIDER
PAYMENTS OR OTHER AUGMENTATIONS
TRIP PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX
FUNDING WOULD BE USED TO OFFSET
GENERAL FUND SPENDING ON COST
GROWTH IN THE PROGRAM.
THE SENATE HOWEVER TOOK ACTION
TO REJECT THESE SUNSETS.
NUMBER TWO THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE PROVIDED A DIFFERENT
LEVELS FOR THE VALUE BASED
PAYMENT PROGRAM THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED -- ESTABLISHING THIS
PROGRAM -- IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY AND ALLOCATES -- AND
UNDER HIS PROPOSAL TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION OR UP TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THREE YEARS -- WHILE THE
SENATE APPROVED THE FUNDING AS
PROPOSED THE ASSEMBLY TOOK
ACTION TO REDUCED.
ANNUAL FUNDIN FOR THE PROGRAM
BY EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS. THREE
THE THE ASSEMBLY USES THE FREED
UP MONEY -- FROM REDUCING
FUNDING FOR THE VALUE BASS
PAYMENTS TO INSTEAD FUND AN
ASSORTMENT OF PROVIDER PAYMENT
INCREASES THAT ARE LISTED.
AT THE BOTTOM OF PAGE. THREE
FOUR THE ASSEMBLY -- ON PAGE
FOUR ON PAGE -- FOUR THE
SOURCE FOR THE OPTICAL BENEFIT
RESTORATION SO THE GOVERNOR AND
THE MAYOR REVISION PROPOSE
RESTORING THE OPTICAL BENEFIT
PURSUANT TO A PREVIOUS AGREEMENT
WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THE GOVERNOR WOULD USE
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX FUNDING TO
DO SO -- THE SENATE APPROVED
THIS ACT THIS PROPOSAL WELL THE
ASSEMBLY WOULD ALSO REDUCE THE
OPTICAL BENEFITS ARE ALSO
RESTORE THE OPTICAL BENEFIT BUT
WOULD DO SO USING GENERAL FUND
INSTEAD OF PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX
FUNDING. FIVE THE ASSEMBLY
ADOPTED -- TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
REGARDING UNSPENT FUNDING --
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX FUNDING SO
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX FUNDING
FLOWS THROUGH MEDI CAL MANAGED
CARE PLANS -- BEFORE ULTIMATELY
REACHING PROVIDERS ASSEMBLY --
PROPOSED LANGUAGE WOULD INSURER
THAT ANNIE'S FUNDING THAT
ULTIMATE THAT GOES TO MANAGED
CARE PLANS BUT DOES NOT
ULTIMATELY ULTIMATELY MAKE IT TO
PROVIDERS IS INSTEAD REVERTED TO
THE PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX FUND.
AND COULD BE SPENT ON OTHER --
ANOTHER -- ORTIZ AND THEN
FINALLY THE ASSEMBLY ADOPTED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE -- THAT
WOULD EXTEND THE VALUE BASED
PAYMENT PROGRAM TO FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CLINICS UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CLINICS REFUGE SEES WOULD NOT
RECEIVE -- OF FUNDING THROUGH
THE VALUE BASED PAYMENT PROGRAM
THEY ARE -- THEY ARE A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
PROVIDER COMMUNITY IN MEDI CAL
AND THE ASSEMBLY -- HAS PROPOSED
TO EXTEND THESE PAYMENTS TO THEM --
JUST TO PROVIDE THAT NOW SOME --
ARE LA -- COMMENTS SO WE SENT
OUT -- TO OUR ISSUES FOR
CONSIDERATION RECENTLY AND FIRST
WE'D WE DO RECOMMEND REJECTING
THE PROPOSED SUNSETS FOR
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX SPENDING --
IN LINE WITH THE SENATE'S ACTION
WHILE WE DO THINK TE THE
OVERALL -- PROVIDER PAYMENT
INCREASES UNDER PROPOSITION
FIFTY SIX SHOULD BE REEVALUATED
TO REALLY UNDER BETTER
UNDERSTAND THEIR EFFECTIVENESS
WE DO NOT THINK THAT -- SUN
SETTING THEM FOR FISCAL
MANAGEMENT REASONS -- IS A IS A
IS AN APPROPRIATE USE OF FUND --
OF THE OF THE FUND AND THEN
SECONDLY WE HAVE A WE HAVE --
PUT OUT -- SOME COMMENTS ON THE
VALUE BASED PAYMENT PROGRAM AND
QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT IT IS A
A COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAM IN
LIGHT OF SOME PARALLEL EFFORTS
THAT ARE BEING PURSUED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. TO REALLY INCREASE
QUALITY OF CARE.
AND SO CONCEPTUALLY WE DO -- WE
WE LIKE THAT SOMEBODY'S APPROACH
OF REDUCING FUNDING FOR THAT
PROGRAM AND DO LIKE THE IDEA OF
TARGETING FUNDING INCREASES FOR
PROVIDERS WITHIN THE FEE FOR
SERVICE SYSTEM.
AS THE ASSEMBLY HAS SO HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FINANCE WILL
MAKE THREE BRIEF POINTS FIRST
YEAR MINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
PLACE A PRIORITY ON THE VALUE
BASED PROGRAMS AND WE BELIEVE
THAT PROGRAMS DOES HAVE VALUE OF
COURSE UNDER PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX PROPOSAL.
THERE IS A HUGE SHARE OF MONEY
GOING TO INCREASING PAYMENTS TO
PROVIDERS BUT WE ALSO BELIEVE
CONSISTENT WITH THAT THAT WE
SHOULD PUT MORE MONEY INTO
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
MORE AND BETTER.
HEALTH.
BETTER OUTCOMES FOR PATIENTS FOR
WHAT WE ARE PAYING SO WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THE EIGHTY NINE
DOLLARS A THE ADMITTED THAT THE
ASSEMBLY HAS PROPOSED RE
DIRECTING SHOULD CONTINUE TO
STAY IN THAT PROGRAM.
THE SECOND POINT IS SPECIFICALLY
FOR VALUE BASED PAYMENTS FOR
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTERS -- THOSE ARE ALREADY
THIS PAYMENTS ARE CRIER RECEIVED
UNDER PROSPECTIVE PAYMENT RATE
SYSTEM WHICH IS DIFFERENT FROM
THE PAYMENTS THAT.
OFTEN OTHERWISE UNDER MEDI CAL
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THAT PAYMENT
SYSTEM IS SUFFICIENT WHERE WE DO
NOT NECESSARILY NEED TO INCLUDE
THOSE WITH THE REST OF THE VALUE
BASED PAYMENTS WE BELIEVE THAT'S
UNNECESSARY AND THAT MONEY CAN.
BETTER BE USED TO THE WAY THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING
RIGHT NOW AND FINALLY ON THE
THIRD POINT THE SUN SETS WE
DISCUSS THAT ONCE I KNOW LAST
THURSDAY.
SO NOT MUCH TO ADD ON THAT
EXCEPT TO SAY THAT WE DO BELIEVE
THAT -- DIFFERENT POLICY WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE MINDFUL
OF THE MULTI YEAR GENERAL FUND
FORECAST AND THE FACT THAT FOR
PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX IN
PARTICULAR.
THIS IS LIKELY DECLINING REVENUE
SOURCE THERE ARE SEVERAL YEARS
INTO THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MISTER MOORE Là.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
DID SOMEONE JUST TO FIND FOR ME
VALUE BASED PAYMENT PROGRAM.
I'M NOT FINDING IT NEARLY --
REPORTS ARE JUST.
WELCOME AND AGAINST DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SO THE IDEA BEHIND
VALUE BASED PAYMENT PROGRAM IS
TO PAY PROVIDERS AN INCENTIVE --
FOR IMPROVING AND IDENTIFIED
METRICS SO -- BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INTEGRATION PRENATAL AND POST
PARTUM CARE CHRONIC DISEASE
MANAGEMENT QUALITY AND QUALITY
AND OUTCOMES FOR CHILDREN MEDI
CAL MANAGED CARE SO WE WOULD BE
PAYING INCENTIVE PAYMENTS IF
PROVIDERS -- MEET -- INCREASE
TARGETS.
THANK YOU AND I'M FROM FURIOUS.
DOES PROP FIFTY SIX HAVE THE
ABILITY.
TO HAVE A SUNSET.
ARE WE DOING THIS BASED ON A
LEGAL OPINION OR SO BASICALLY
DOES -- FUNDS ARE APPROPRIATE
THE GOVERNOR'S MADE A PROPOSAL
AND ARE APPROPRIATED THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS EVERY YEAR.
SO THE GOVERNOR CAN DO WHATEVER
HE WANTS WITH REGARDS TO
MEDICARE ALL BUT WITH THE WITH
THE LEGISLATURE'S AND ACTING
IT'S FOR THAT TO THE BUDGET
PROBLEM THANKS YES -- AND THEN
WHEN I DON'T SEE HERE IS IS A
TREND.
OUR PROP FIFTY SIX REVENUES
DOING OR THE DECLINING.
ARE THE LEVEL OF THE RISING.
SO ARE ONLY IN THE SECOND YEAR
OF REVENUES AND COMPARED TO THE
FIRST YEAR WE DID HAVE A QUARTER
OF SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THEY ARE
DECREASING SLIGHTLY [inaudible]
BY [inaudible] 5%.
I CAN OUT WE HAVE OUR OWN
PROJECTIONS I DON'T KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
PROJECTIONS BUT WE WE HAVE A
GROUP VERY GRADUAL DECLINE OF
ABOUT 2%.
ANNUALLY IN THIS FUND A LARGE
PART THE THE DECLINE IS IS SO
SMALL BECAUSE PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX EXTENDED THE TAX.
TO NON CIGARETE SUCH AS EASY
CIGARETTES AND SO FORTH RUN
INCLUDES VAPING AND OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU.
FOR THAT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
YOU'RE WELCOME A SCANNER.
THANK YOU -- I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT OUTSIDE THE THE
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES FOR
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED.
HAVE HAD THEIR RATES ROZEN
SINCE -- TWO THOUSAND EIGHT NINE
AND OUR PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE
FACILITIES HAVE HAD THEIR RATES
FROZEN SINCE -- SEVEN AWAIT
[inaudible]
AND WITH THE AS FAR AS I CAN
TELL FROM BOTH WHAT YOU ALL
DISCUSSED IN WHAT IS IN OUR
MATERIALS IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
ACTION.
WOULD ALLOW FOR SOME ABILITY TO
ADDRESS THAT THOSE FROZEN RATES.
THAT IS CORRECT AND I DIED ONLY
TWO THINGS I WOULD KNOW DESERT --
INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES FOR
THE DRESS TELL ME DISABLED
CURRENTLY DO RECEIVE SOME
PROPOSITION -- FIFTY SIX FUNDING
FOR OUR SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT SO
IT'S NOT A RATE INCREASE BUT
IT'S AT AN INCREASE -- FOR THOSE
PAYMENTS AND THAT WOULD BE
CONTINUED UNDER BOTH HOUSES --
ACTIONS THE STANDALONE PEDIATRIC
SUB ACUTE FACILITIES DID RECEIVE
A ONE TIME -- INCREASE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT LAST YEAR
OR PROVIDER PAYMENT INCREASE --
BUT THAT WAS NOT -- THAT CARRIED
FORWARD TO TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
WE WILL MOVE ON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- YEAH.
ISSUE.
ELEVEN RELATES -- TO OPTIONAL
BENEFITS A MEDI CAL THAT WERE
ELIMINATED DURING THE LAST
RECESSION -- AS WAS NOTED IN THE
PREVIOUS ITEMS THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED RESTORING OPTICAL
BENEFITS USING PROPOSITION FIFTY
SIX FUNDING -- THE SENATE
ADOPTED THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR OPTICAL BENEFITS -- AND
ADDITIONALLY APPROVED SIX POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND.
TWENTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS TOTAL
FUNDS TO ALSO RESTORE -- SEVERAL
OTHER OPTIONAL BENEFITS THAT HAD
NOT YET BEEN RESTORED INCLUDING
AUDIOLOGY INCONTINENCE CREAMS
AND WASHES PODIATRY AND SPEECH
THERAPY.
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVE THE
RESTORATION OF ALL OF THE SAME
BENEFITS BUT ALSO APPROVED
FUNDING FOR CHIROPRACTIC
SERVICES -- BUT AS WAS IMMINENT
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY FUNDS THE
OPTICAL BENEFITS USING THE
GENERAL FUND SO HAS A HIGHER
GENERAL FUND COST OF EIGHTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND A TOTAL FROM COSTA THIRTY
EIGHT POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
[inaudible]
BY THE THE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT THE MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL.
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
HOLD THE SOAP I AM OPEN THANK
YOU -- NINETY ISSUE TWELVE THE
WHOLE PERSON CARE HOUSING
SERVICES.
BELIAU BUT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED --
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL FUND FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
THE FUND -- SUPPORT OF HOUSING
SERVICES -- IN WHOLE PERSON CARE
PILOT COUNTIES THE SENATE
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S REQUEST
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED THE
GOVERNOR'S REQUESTED FUNDING --
FOR BUT ALSO ADOPTED PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO WORK WITH
COUNTIES ON THE ALLOCATE
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY TO TARGET
THE FUNDS FOR EXAMPLE -- FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
THAT ARE HOMELESS AND TO INSURE
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW THE FUNDING
IS USED.
SO THE ISSUE HERE BEFORE YOU IS --
THIS EXTRA TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
APPROVED BY THE ASSEMBLY THANK
YOU AW I UNDERSTAND THE THE
ADMINISTRATION -- HAS AGREED TO
COMPROMISE LANGUAGE.
OKAY IF YOU LIKE TO SHARE THAT
WITH IS THAT BE GREAT -- YES
WELL OF AMENDED HIS APARTMENT OF
FINANCE SO WE A COMPROMISE WOULD
BE CLARIFYING LANGUAGE -- TO ARE
PROPOSED BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
FOR THIS ISSUE AND WILL SHARE
WITH YOU ALL [inaudible]
GREAT.
SO COLLEAGUES THIS ISN'T AN
ISSUE THAT WE COULD TAKE A VOTE
ON ON TERROR AND THAT LANGUAGE
IS BEING DISTRIBUTED NOW.
WILL TAKE A MINUTE TO TAKE A
LOOK AT IT
.
SO JUST TO SUMMARIZE THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE THAT WE
RECEIVE FROM THE ADMINISTRATION --
WITH REGARD TO DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR THE
WHOLE PERSON CARE PILOT PROGRAM
OR SUCCESS A PROGRAM. TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT OF HOUSING SERVICES THE
NEW LANGUAGE SAYS BUT INCLUDED
IS AS FOLLOWS QUOTE INCLUDING
BUT NOT LIMITED TO RENTAL
SUBSIDIES.
THAT'S THE NEW LINE THAT WAS
ADDED TO THE LANGUAGE THAT HAD
BEEN PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION PREVIOUSLY.
AND TO CLARIFY THAT LANUAGE WAS
ADDED TO SOLVE WHAT PROBLEM.
THE ABILITY TO USE -- THE
FUNDING FOR ADDITIONAL SERVICES
OKAY.
A FEW PEOPLE TODAY TEND NOT
READY -- MORLOCK [inaudible]
MINIATURE -- I'M JUST TRYING TO
GET MY ARMS AROUND.
HOW THE ALLOCATION PROCESS IS?
DONE AS IT RELATES TO SAY
POPULATION FOR ENTIRE COUNTY.
ORANGE COUNTY HAS THREE POINT
ONE MILLION.
SACRAMENTO HAS WE REQUESTED HALF
THAT ONE POINT.
FIVE BUT IT HAS GETTING THE SAME
AMOUNT OF MONEY SO I'M JUST KIND
OF JUST CURIOUS IF MAYBE YOU
COULD EXPLAIN.
HOW THAT WORKS?
AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL WE USE A
TWENTY SEVENTEEN POINT IN TIME
COUNT TO DETERMINE A COMPONENT
OF THE METHODOLOGY FOR
ALLOCATING THESE FUNDS.
CANINO WHAT POINT TIME IS I'VE
DONE IT -- OKAY I'M AB.
WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THE ITEM
OPEN JUST GIVE -- FOLKS Là MORE
TIME TO DIGEST THE LANGUAGE IS
THAT OKAY WITH YOU FOR MORE LUCK
WITH THAT THE HELPFUL.
YOUR WISH IS MY COMMAND
[inaudible]
REMEMBER THAT.
FULL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN.
WHEN ON THE ISSUE THIRTEEN NON
WHOLE PERSON CARE COUNTIES
FUNDING THAT'S INTERESTING NON
HOLD?
FOR CARE COUNTIES FUNDING ALEJO --
SO THAT THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FUND AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY FOR COUNTIES
THAT DO NOT HAVE A WHOLE PERSON
CARE -- PILOTS IN THIS WOULD BE
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE SIMILAR TO THE
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE CARRIED OUT
IN COUNTIES THAT DO HAVE WHOLE
PERSON CARE.
PILOTS SUCH AS COORDINATING
HEALTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND
SOCIAL SERVICES. FOR INDIVIDUALS
TO UTILIZE MULTIPLE SYSTEMS THE
SENATE APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'S
REQUESTED FUNDING.
FROM THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FUND.
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED THE
GOVERNOR'S REQUESTED FUNDING BUT
USE GENERAL FUND RATHER THAN
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND --
SO THE DIFFERENCE TODAY IS
BETWEEN -- WHICH FUND SOURCES
USED TO TO FUND THIS
AUGMENTATION GENERAL FUND FOR
THE ASSEMBLY AND MENTAL SERVICES
FUND FOR THE SENATE.
THANK YOU FINANCE WE BELIEVE
THIS EXPANSION IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE INTENT AND PURPOSES OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACTON
SAID THIS IS AN APPROPRIATE USE
OF THE FUNDING.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS. THREE NONE
MOVING THE ISSUE FOURTEEN
STRENGTHENING FISCAL ESTIMATES
IN CASH FLOW MONITORING DELEO.
THIS ISSUE -- RELATES TO A
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND THREE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
TOTAL FUNDS IN TWENTY FIVE
POSITIONS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
ACCOMPLISH A VARIETY OF TASKS --
RELATED TO FISCAL -- OVERSIGHT --
FIRST TO THESE POSITIONS WOULD
BE INTENDED TO IMPROVE THE
MONITORING OF CASH FLOWS AND THE
MEDI CAL PROGRAM.
SECOND THEY WOULD INCREASE THE
RECONCILIATION OF ACTUAL
SPENDING TO BUDGET ESTIMATES
THIRD THEY WOULD IMPROVE THE
PROCESSING OF PAYMENTS AND
COLLECTIONS.
AND FINALLY THEY WOULD INCREASE
COORDINATION AMONG
ADMINISTRATIVE UNITS AT THE
DEPARTMENT -- THIS PROPOSAL IS
CONNECTED -- TO RECENT -- LARGE
AND MAJOR ADJUSTMENTS IN IN THE
MEDI CAL BUDGET THAT -- HAVE
BECAUSE SOME CHALLENGES FOR ON
THE LEGISLATURE'S -- BUDGETING
AND AND OVERSIGHT OF THIS
PROGRAM.
THE SENATE APPROVED GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND ADDITIONALLY
ENACTED PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE TO
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROVIDE REGULAR UPDATES ON
ACTUAL CASH FLOWS COMPARED TO
ESTIMATES -- ALSO TO PREPARE AND
PRESENT TO THE LEGISLATURE A
PLAN WITH LONGER TERM CHANGES TO
ADDRESS -- ISSUES IN IN THIS
REGARD AND FINALLY -- TO REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT TO INITIATE -- A
WORKING GROUP WITH LEGISLATIVE
STAFF AND OUR OFFICE TO IDENTIFY
POTENTIAL CHANGES.
AND THE ASSEMBLY REJECTED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
WE RECOMMEND THE SENATE ACTION
AS IT ALIGNS WITH OUR PREVIOUS
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THIS ISSUE.
AND WE BELIEVE IT WILL LEAD TO
IMPROVED FISCAL ESTIMATES AN
INCREASE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
OF THE MEDICARE PROGRAM.
ALTERNATE OVER MY COLLEAGUE
RIGHT -- SO I I THINK FIRST WERE
WERE VERY GLAD TO SEE THAT THE
SENATE HAD SUPPORTED OUR A
PROPOSAL IN THIS AREA -- I
ACTUALLY BROUGHT ALONG WITH ME --
PAGE FROM THE LA OWES ANALYSIS
OF THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
BUDGET IN WHICH THEY HAD A TEXT
BOX.
LOOKING AT KIND OF SOME OF THE
MAIN CAUSES OF MEDI CAL
VOLATILITY -- ESTIMATE
VOLATILITY -- AND YOU KNOW WE'VE
HEARD A LOT FROM THE LEGISLATURE
IN RECENT YEARS ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT THIS HAS CAUSED --
FOR IT FOR GENERAL FUND PLANNING.
HI WE WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT WE
SHARE THOSE FRUSTRATIONS BECAUSE
IT ALSO IMPACTS OUR ABILITY TO
PLAN -- FOR GENERAL FUND
BUDGETING -- BUT BRIEFLY ON THE
ALLEY AS TEXT BOX HERE -- THEY
THEY MENTION THREE DIFFERENT
THINGS -- MANAGED CARE PAYMENTS --
WE HAVE OVER A THOUSAND
DIFFERENT MANAGED CARE RATES
THAT ARE APPROVED EACH YEAR BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
TIMING OF THOSE RATES BECAUSE
THE MEDI CAL BUDGET IS ON A CASH
BASIS -- THE TIMING OF THOSE
APPROVALS IF WE DON'T GET THAT
RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO BE OFF --
THE NUMBER TWO ONE THAT THEY
POINTED OUT WAS THE QUALITY
ISSUE THE HOSPITAL QUALITY
ASSURANCE BE -- WHICH PROVIDES
AN OVER ONE BILLION DOLLAR
GENERAL FUND BENEFIT EVERY YEAR.
AND THE THIRD -- DRUG REBATES WE
GET SAVINGS FROM.
FROM DRUG REBATES THAT ARE --
NEGOTIATED WITH MANUFACTURERS --
I WANTED TO POINT THESE OUT
BECAUSE THAT YOU KNOW LIKE LIKE
OUR REVENUE DISCUSSIONS THAT WE
HAD SEVERAL YEARS AGO WHERE WE
LOOKED AT WHAT KIND OF OPTIONS
WE HAD TO ADDRESS REVENUE
VOLATILITY.
I THINK WE HAVE A SIMILAR
DISCUSSION HERE ABOUT -- HOW TO
ADDRESS MEDI CAL VOLATILITY IN
AND IN EACH OF THESE CASES?
PRINCIPALLY THINGS LIKE THE
QUALITY ASSURANCE FEES -- THERE
ARE STRONG POLICY REASONS WHY WE
WOULDN'T WANT TO GET RIDOF
THESE MECHANISMS THEY PROVIDED
GENERAL FUND BENEFIT IN SOME
CASES THEY PROVIDE PROVIDER
BENEFITS THEY MADE IT IN AND IN
MANY CASES THEY ALSO -- INCENT
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM.
AND SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT HOW
CAN WE INSTEAD MANAGE THAT MEDI
CAL VOLATILITY.
WE HAD TO PROPOSALS THIS YEAR
THE FIRST A COVER VERY QUICKLY
BECAUSE BOTH HOUSES APPROVED IT --
WE CREATED A SPECIAL FUND IN
WHICH TO DEPOSIT DRUG REBATE --
SAVINGS -- AND THE CONCEPT WAS
KIND OF LIKE PROPOSITION TWO
THAT WITH PROPOSITION TWO YOU
TAKE OFF SPIKES IN CAPITAL GAINS
REVENUES TO TRY TO SMOOTH OUT
GENERAL FUND SPENDING --
LIKEWISE WHEN WHEN DRUG REBATE
SAVINGS EXCEED OUR INITIAL
ESTIMATES WE PLAN TO DEPOSIT
SOME OF THOSE SAVINGS INTO THE
SPECIAL FUND AND USE THEM FOR
WHEN WE ACTUALLY UNDERESTIMATE
OUR SAVINGS TO TRY TO SMOOTH OUT
THE EFFECT.
OF THOSE REBATES ON THE GENERAL
FUND AND THE SECOND IS THIS
PROPOSAL -- WHICH I THINK -- HAS
A FEW DIFFERENT PURPOSES ONE IS --
WHAT WHEN WE THINK ABOUT THE THE
MANAGED CARE PAYMENTS THAT I
MENTIONED -- MANY OF THESE --
CALL THE FEES AND OTHER
ENHANCEMENTS ALSO HAPPEN TO BE
VERY COMPLEX -- AND THE TIMING
OF TRANSACTIONS -- THE TIMING OF
OF SETTLING UP -- FOR DIFFERENT --
ITEMS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE THIS IS ON A
CASH BASIS AND IT WOULD CST I
BELIEVE OVER TWO BILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO PUT IT
ON THE CRUEL BASIS.
YOU KNOW IT WOULD PROBABLY BE
VERY DIFFICULT TO PRIORITIZE
THAT -- WE WE WANTED TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THOSE PROBLEMS BY -- ON
THE ONE HAND PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL ANALYTICAL CAPACITY
AND WITH RESOURCES TO THE
DEPARTMENT -- SO WE WILL BE
BETTER ANALYZING AYE
TRANSACTIONS IN CASH TRENDS --
AND ALSO IMPROVING GIVING
RESOURCES TO THE FISCAL
FORECASTING DIVISION TO IMPROVE --
THEIR MODELING EFFORTS THERE
NUMBER -- TWO WE'RE GONNA BE
INCREASED IMPROVING COORDINATION
BETWEEN UNITS OF FOR EXAMPLE
THESE MANAGED CARE PAYMENTS
THERE FOR DIFFERENT DIVISIONS
THAT WORK ON THESE.
THAT WORK ON THESE PAYMENTS IN
ORDER TO GET A PAYMENT OUT TE
DOOR AND THESE PAYMENTS CAN BE
YOU KNOW A FEW BILLION DOLLARS.
APIECE AND SO WE WANT TO GET
RESOURCES ACROSS THE DEPARTMENT
TO BETTER COORDINATE AND TRACK
THESE THINGS IN THE CENTURY JUST
TALK TO EACH OTHER BETTER.
AND LASTLY WE WANT TO CENTRALIZE
FISCAL LEADERSHIP IN A CFO
POSITION A NEW POSITION A DH CS.
WHO WILL BE ABLE TO SORT OF SEE
THE BIG PICTURE -- IN IN -- IN
THE FISCAL SITUATION AND SO JUST
TO CLOSE YOU KNOW WE WE REALLY
DO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
NECESSARY COMPONENT OF
CONTINUING. TO TO MINIMIZE THE
IMPACT THAT THE BALLOT CAL
ESTIMATE IS HAVING ON THE
GENERAL FUND -- WITH BAD WERE
HAPPY ANSWER QUESTIONS -- WE WE
REJECT THE ITEM BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T GET DONE REALLY A
SATISFACTORY ANSWER ABOUT THE
TWENTY FIVE POSITIONS WERE GONNA
DO I DON'T THINK YOU.
GIVE THE PROPER CONTEXT OF THE
SITUATION AND THE REASON.
WE ENDED UP REJECTING THOSE
POSITIONS IS BECAUSE THERE WAS A
ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION AND IN
WITH THE P..
NAT SHORTFALL THAT WAS.
HER PRETTY PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON OUR BUDGET.
BECAUSE OF WHAT WHAT HAD
HAPPENED SO I THINK WE WE ALL
AGREE THAT.
THIS THIS IS AN ISSUE WE ALL
AGREE THAT THIS IS -- I
CHALLENGE AND AND I'M I'M PERSON
VERY SUPPORT FOR WHATEVER WE
COULD DO.
TO HAVE BETTER ESTIMATES -- I
THINK WHEN WE DRILL DOWN ON THE
ISSUE WITH IT WE GET
SATISFACTORY ANSWERS TO WHAT THE
TWENTY FIVE NEW PEOPLE ARE GONNA
BE DOING SO PERHAPS YOU CAN GO
TO SOME DETAIL ABOUT THAT.
SO IN ADDITION TO WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE SAID -- WAY TO THINK
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL IS -- ADDING
POSITIONS TO CRITICAL AREAS
THROUGHOUT THE DEPARTMENT --
ACCOUNTING FISCAL FORECAST DEAN
MANAGED CARE -- THIRD PARTY
LIABILITY DIVISION TO BETTER
COORDINATE COMMUNICATE TRACK --
REPORT -- I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT A
SPECIFIC DIVISION OR TO THIS
INCIDENT.
THIS IS A DEPARTMENT THAT AND
UNFORTUNATELY HAS BEEN SOMEONE
ANTAGONISTIC TOWARD LEGISLATURE --
WITH THE DEPARTMENT HEAD THAT
HAS A SORT OF A HISTORY OF
ANTAGONISM THERE ARE SUB
COMMITTEE SO.
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL TO KNOW ON
WHICH WHICH POSITIONS WHICH
AREAS BUT THEY BE DOING I MEAN
THAT'S THAT'S THAT'S SORT OF
NORMALLY WE WOULD NOT BE DOING
THAT A CONFERENCE THAT WAS WHAT
WE REALLY WHAT WAS.
TO ROB QUESTIONS SUBCOMMITTEE
WASN'T GIVEN FOR THE PURCHASE BY
WE REJECTED.
I REQUEST YEAH AND SO -- I CAN
GO DIVISION BY DIVISION -- SO
AND MINISTRY OF DIVISION FOR
POSITIONS --TO CENTRALIZE
ACCOUNTING RESPONSIBILITIES AND
ASSISTING WITH RECONCILING CASH
BALANCES WITH PROJECTED A NET
ENACT ACTUAL EXPENDITURES -- THE
CAPITATED RATES DEVELOPMENT
DIVISIONS TO POSITIONS --
COMPILING A PROVIDING MONTHLY
MANAGED CARE PAYMENT RATE --
UPDATES -- RESEARCH DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN PROJECTED AN ACTUAL
EXPENDITURES FOR MANAGED CARE
FOR THE MANAGED CARE PROGRAM --
THIS THE CFO POSITION MY
COLLEAGUE DISCUSSED -- AND THE
FISCAL FORECASTING DIVISION TEN
POSITIONS -- TO COMPARE AND
RESEARCH ESTIMATED VERSES A
CRUEL EXPENDITURES -- DEVELOP
FISCAL ESTIMATES TRACK
IMPLEMENTATION OF EXPENDITURES --
THE SCENE.
A INFORMATION MANAGEMENT
DIVISION TWO POSITIONS -- THIS
IS TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT --
CHANGE REQUESTS NECESSARY -- TO
EXECUTE THE MANAGED CARE
PAYMENTS WHICH AS MY COLLEAGUE
MENTIONED ARE CAN BE ABOVE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS -- MANAGED CARE
OPERATIONS DIVISION SO THAT'S
TWO POSITIONS -- OVERSEE --
PROJECT MANAGEMENT ACTIVITIES
RELATED TO THE MAN THE MEDIC
MEDICAI MANAGED CARE PROGRAM.
THE PHARMACY BENEFITS DIVISION
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
VOLATILITY MY COLLEAGUE -- NOTED
ON THE DRUG REBATES TO COME BACK
TO THE PREVIOUS ISSUE WHEN YOU
IDENTIFIED -- REALLY THE THE
SHORTCOMING WHAT -- WHAT
SHORTCOMINGS IN PARTICULAR ARE
ARE THESE POSITIONS -- DEALING
WITH.
SO I I MEAN I THINK AGAIN LIKE.
WE ARE WE'RE DEALING WITH
THOUSANDS OF THOUSANDS OF RATE
CHANGES A YEAR.
HE OF BENEFITS FOR OVER THIRTEEN
MILLION PEOPLE THAT THE ESTIMATE
ITSELF IS OVER A THOUSAND PAGES
AYE.
KLAY PRETTY UNWIELDY AND IN
ORDER FOR IN ORDER FOR ALL OF
THIS. TO TO BECOME AGAIN BECAUSE
WE'RE ON A CASH BASIS IN ORDER
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO GET ALL OF
THESE ESTIMATES RIGHT -- YOU
KNOW THE THE THE SEVERAL
DIVISIONS A DH CS THAT ARE
DEALING WITH THESE TRANSACTIONS
HAVE TO BE TALKING WITH ENOUGH
IT'S EACH OTHER THEY HAVE TO BE --
TRACKING THESE THINGS AND AND
RESEARCHING THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
WHAT ALL THESE POSITIONS ARE
ABOUT RESEARCHING -- YOU KNOW
CHANGES IN LAW -- WHAT WE AMONG
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- OFFERS
CHANGES IN -- GUIDANCE AND
REGULATIONS THEY HAVE TO BE
TRYING TO DETERMINE WHAT THE
IMPACT IS -- ON THE MEDI CAL
ESTIMATE -- REALLY -- I THINK
AGAIN IT KIND OF  HIGHER LEVEL --
TEN OF THE TWENTY FIVE POSITIONS
WOULD BE.
FOR ESSENTIALLY IMPROVING THE
ESTIMATE ITSELF.
AND THE BULK OF THE REST OF THEM
I THINK GENERALLY SPEAKING ARE --
FOR COORDINATING BETTER -- FOR
TRYING TO TRACK ALL OF THIS
COMPLEXITY BETTER.
IT SOUNDS LIKE HALF THE
POSITIONS ARE. TO ASSIST WITH
TEST.
ANALYZING AND COMBING THROUGH
THE DATA.
CORRECT AND THEN SOUNDS LIKE THE
OTHER HALF IS. TO SORT OF
IMPROVE COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN
THE VARIOUS.
YEAH AND AND AND THE VISION YOU
KNOW BOTH FROM LIKE AN
ACCOUNTING LEVEL AND AT A
BUDGETING LEVEL AND THEN YOU
HAVE -- FOLKS A DH CS WHO WORK
ON THE ESTIMATE ITSELF THERE ARE
A LOT OF SIMILAR BUT DIFFERENT
FUNCTIONS CAN I TRY TO HELP GET
THEM ON THE SAME PAGE.
WHERE THE ARMY THE CHALLENGES IN
PREVIOUS YEARS JUST THE?
THE IS JUST SORT OF BEING
OVERWHELMED BY THE AMOUNT OF
DATA.
OR WAS IT ON TECHNOLOGY ISSUE
BECAUSE NORMALLY WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT.
ANALYZING DAMAGE IN ITS NOT
NECESSARILY HUMAN BEINGS WHO DO
IT IT'S NOW.
COMPUTERS WHO AND THE TWO THINGS
ARE NOT THERE'S A TECHNOLOGICAL
SOLUTION THAT.
COULD ASSIST WITH THAT OR WAS IT
I'M REALLY BECAUSE IN A TO THE
DIFFERENT SILOS WAR.
COMMUNICATING WITH ONE ANOTHER
IF YOU DON'T MIND I'D ACTUALLY
LIKE TO TURN OVER TO A COLLEAGUE
OF HER.
AROUND FOR MORE OF THOSE --
ESTHER.
HI ADAM DIVERSITY BERMAN FINANCE
SO -- THERE'S BEEN A FEWISSUES
OVER THE YEARS AN EGG AND AND
PRIMARILY WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
DESCRIBED IN TERMS OF THE
COMPLEXITIES.
LED TO SOME ISSUES THAT RESULTED
IN YOU KNOW DRASTIC CHANGES TO
THE ESTIMATE.
THE MOST NOTABLE ONE WAS AROUND
THE CORNER TO CARE INITIATIVE
ESTIMATE TWO YEARS AGO AND
LARGELY WHAT WAS HAPPENING THERE
IS ACCOUNTING FOR MONEY BETWEEN
THESE THIS KIND OF MANAGED CARE
BASED PROGRAM.
WHERE WE TALK ABOUT ALL THESE
THOUSANDS OF RATES THAT TO BE
DONE?
AND TRANSLATING THAT INTO THAT
KIND OF THE LANGUAGE BETWEEN THE
SYSTEMS THAT ARE USED FOR
BUILDING THE ESTIMATE AND THE
BUILDING THE RATES PAID THE
PLANS.
AND BASICALLY THOSE TWO THINGS
DON'T SYNC UP AND THE SYSTEMS
THAT HAVE BEEN IN PLACE FOR FOR
MANY MANY MANY YEARS TO DO THESE
THINGS IN A VAULT.
I'M TOGETHER KIND OF SEPARATELY --
TO DO THAT KIND OF TRANSLATION
THOSE ARE THE ISSUES THAT THAT
YOU KNOW ARE ARE SO PROBLEMATIC
IN A IN A PROGRAM THIS COMPLEX.
AND SO -- AND THAT'S KIND OF
WHERE THE ISSUES HAVE BEEN
THAT'S WHERE THE BUDGETING
ISSUES A BAND AND THAT'S WHAT
THE THE REQUEST IS DESIGNED TO
TEACH TO ADDRESS.
CAN YOU FEEL GIVEN THE
LEADERSHIP'S THAT'S IN PLACE.
THAT THERE IS ENOUGH --
MANAGERIAL COMPETENCY.
TO BE ABLE TO ABSORB THE TWENTY
I MEAN BECAUSE PART OF IT IS AND
JUST.
HAVING THE BODIES IS SO SOMEONE
NEEDS TO BE THE SYMPHONY
CONDUCTOR FOR LACK OF BETTER
ANALOGY -- BIT HERE DO YOU HAVE
THE MANAGEMENT TEAM IN PLACE AND
KNOWS HOW TO BRING THESE PEOPLE
ON IT.
HI GET THEM IN PLACEAND THAT
TAXI MANAGE THIS PROCESS GOOD
COMMUTERS TENNIS COMPLEX AND
OBVIOUSLY -- WE WE WE SHARE YOUR
CONCERN THAT WE DO NEED TO GO
ADDRESSED US.
YES SO THAT'S AGAIN PART OF WHAT
THIS PROPOSAL IS TRYING T
ADDRESS BY CREATING A CFO
POSITION AND SO THE YOU'LL HAVE
SOMEONE IS GONNA BE A POINT
PERSON THAT CAN HELP KIND OF
BRIDGE -- SOME OF THESE ISSUES
AND AND PROVIDE LEADERSHIP IN
THIS AREA.
OKAY.
AND IT DOES LOOK AGAIN
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON YOUR
WORK -- WE WE REJECTED BECAUSE
WE OR WE WHAT WE HAVE SAID WE
GOT ADEQUATE INFORMATION SO IF
YOU DO THAT ADDITIONAL
PERMISSION TO PROVIDE.
TO OUR OUR BUT TO START TO BE
GREAT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS ON
THIS ITEM.
SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE.
FIFTEEN COLLEAGUES I'M GONNA
SUGGESTIONS -- OF FOOD HAS
ARRIVED WE'RE GONNA TAKE ISSUE
FIFTEEN IT'S THE LAST
ADMINISTRATIVE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL THE REST ARE PROPOSALS
THAT HAVE COME FROM.
THE LEGISLATIVE SO I'M GOING TO
SUGGEST THAT WE BREAK -- AB
FIFTEEN ON THE WILL TAKE ONE
MORE ACTION BEFORE WE BREAK --
IT.
ALL RIGHT -- ISSUE FIFTY MANAGE
CARE SANCTIONS TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE ELIO -- THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO CLARIFY A AND EXPAND
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES AT THE READY TO IMPOSE
SANCTIONS ON MANAGED CARE PLANS
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS AND
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER PLANS
THAT ARE.
FOUND IN VIOLATION OF THE
STATE'S CONTRACTS OR OTHER RULES
THE SENATE ADOPTED THE
PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE CONSISTENT
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S -- PROPOSAL
THE ASSEMBLY REJECTED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WITHOUT
PREJUDICE AS THE LANGUAGE WAS
UNAVAILABLE -- SO AT CONRAD THEY
CONFERENCE ISSUE IS WHETHER OR
NOT TO APPROVE THIS LANGUAGE THE
TRAILER BILL WAS RELEASED ON
FRIDAY -- THIS PAST FRIDAY --
WE'VE GIVING IT A PRELIMINARY
REVIEW -- BUT HAVEN'T HAD IT
REALLY IT SIGNIFICANT TIME. TO
FULLY RENT COMPREHENSIVELY
REVIEW THE LANGUAGE.
WE DO AGREE WITH THE GENERAL
INTENT BEHIND THE LANGUAGE BUT
DO HAVE OUTSTANDING QUESTIONS
ABOUT -- MANY OF THE SPECIFICS
AND ABOUT SOME OF THE BREADTH OF
A STORY THAT IT WOULD ULTIMATELY
GIVE THE ADMINISTRATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FINANCE THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
STAND BEHIND THIS PROPOSAL AS LA --
MENTIONED WE KNOW THE LANGUAGE
WAS JUST RELEASED ON FRIDAY SO
WE ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT THANK YOU.
MEMBERS [inaudible]
SENATOR NIELSEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NOW THE AT
THE GOT THIS THE OTHER DAY BUT
THIS IS THE FIRST I'VE SEEN THIS.
RIGHT NOW.
THEY CONFESSED THAT THEY GOT IT
OUT ON FRIDAY [inaudible]
THEN THE WE DON'T HAVE WE HAVE
NOT HAD TIME TO TRULY EVALUATE
AND THE REASON THAT I AM
CONCERNED AT THIS IS A
POTENTIALLY VERY PUNITIVE
SECTION.
THE RECTOR MY IDENTIFY FINDINGS
NON COMPLIANCE OR GOOD CAUSE
THROUGH ANY MEANS INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO A WHOLE SERIES OF
POINTS HERE -- TEMPORARILY OR
PERMANENTLY SUSPEND ENROLLMENT
THE THE THIS THIS IS A VERY
PUNITIVE.
DOCUMENT AND DIED I DO BELIEVE
THAT.
TO IT IT IS DUE THE JUSTICE OF
SOME VERY DEEP SCRUTINY AND SO
LET'S NOT MOVE ON THIS TONIGHT
AT LEAST.
ABSOLUTELY SIR THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS FROM OTHERS.
VISITING TO JUST A QUICK
QUESTION WHICH IS WHERE WITH THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE COMING OUT
SO LATE ON FRIDAY WAS THERE.
IS THERE A RUSH TO IMPLEMENT
THIS I KNOW THAT STAKEHOLDERS OF
NOW START COMING OUT AND HAVE
RAISED SOME CONCERNS BUT JUST
WANT TO UNDERSTAND THE URGENCY.
FOR MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED WE
ARE STILL STANDING BEHIND THIS
PROPOSAL AM SO GIVEN RECENT --
PERFORMANCE OR LACK PERFORMANCE
OF FROM OUR MANAGED HEALTHCARE
PLANS WE THINK THAT THIS IS A
MEASURE THAT WE SHOULD -- MOVE
FORWARD WITH.
NOW I WOULD ONLY ADD THAT --
WITHIN -- WELFARE IT'S HIS
INSTITUTIONS CODE THERE IS
AUTHORITY FOR THE DIRECTOR OF
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO SANCTION PLANS AND
TO HAVE OTHER SORT OF PUNITIVE%
ACTIONS IF THEY'RE NOT COMPLYING
WITH CONTRACTS OR STATE RULES
AND SO FORTH.
THIS DOES INCREASE AUTHORITY IN
LINE WITH IN LINE WITH THE
INTENT AND WE DON'T SEE
CHALLENGES THERE BUT THERE IS
EXISTING AUTHORITY -- TO
SANCTION OR TAKE OTHER ACTIONS
AGAINST MANAGED CARE PLANS OUT
OF COMPLIANCE CURRENTLY AND I'M
SORRY IF I MISSED IT HAS THERE
BEEN A SITUATION BECAUSE I AS I
THINK I RECALL I BELIEVE
SANCTIONS HAVING BEEN LEVIED.
ALL IN THE PAST -- THEIR
PARTICULAR -- A THE LAW THAT'S
VAGUE OR A SCENARIO THAT.
ON THEDEPARTMENT IS ENCOUNTERED
WHERE THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY THEY NEEDED TO TAKE.
APPROPRIATE ACTION TO PROTECT.
PUBLIC RESOURCES AND
CALIFORNIANS [inaudible]
YEAH.
WELL OF AMENDED ITS DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SO THIS INCREASED
INCREASES A SANCTION AMOUNT AND
EIGHTY CLARIFIES -- AND APPLIES
AUTHORITY TO ALL OF THE MEDICAL
DELIVERY SYSTEM INCLUSIVE OF
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS WHICH
HAD NOT BEEN INCLUDED BEFORE.
THAT IS MY UNDER IN THE DIRECT
AS A STORY OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. THIRTY
NIELSEN.
FOLLOW UP ON IT A LITTLE BIT NOW
WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH THIS
EVERY YEAR.
FOR MANY YEARS.
AND NOW SOMETHING THAT APPEARS.
THE LITTLE BETTER ABOVE THE BAR
THE NORM IN TERMS OF AUTHORITY
THAT YOU'RE BEING ACCORDED EVEN
THOUGH YOU MAYBE HAVE SOME
STATUTORY AUTHORITY THIS LOOKS
LIKE IT GREATLY EXPANDS THAT
IT'S ALREADY.
AND GREATLY EXPANDS THE PUNITIVE
ABILITY OF THE AGENCY NOW.
AGAIN THE JURASSIC Là BIT OF
QUESTION IS SOMETHING
PERPETRATED THIS IS A BEEN SOME
KIND OF A GREAT DMV DISASTER
HERE THAT HAS OCCURRED THAT --
THAT WARRANTS THESE KINDS OF THE
PENALTIES I WON'T EVEN USE AN
ADJECTIVE THAT. ONE OF THE
CONCERNS -- THIS IS A PROPOSAL
REACTING -- TO AGAIN -- LACK OF
PERFORMANCE FROM OUR MEDI CAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS -- IN
PARTICULAR THE REASON I ADDED ON
THE LACK OF SERVICES BEING
PROVIDED TO CHILDREN -- SO THE
IDEA CAME OUT AND AND MARCH AND
SO THIS IS A RESPONSE IN TRYING
TO IMPROVE -- UP PERFORMANCE IN
THIS AREA GOT IT.
WELL IT DID NOT COMPLETE AS FAR
AS I'M CONCERNED BUT IT IS AN
ANSWER AND I THANK YOU FOR THAT
BUT WE'RE GOING TO WANT TO LOOK
A LITTLE MORE DEEPLY AT THIS.
THAT WAS HELPFUL TO HEAR THAT IT
SAID IT WAS AN AUDIT FINDING IN
THIS IS IN RESPONSE TO AN AUDIT.
FINDING THAT THAT WAS HELPFUL
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
GOOD EVENING MR BIGELOW THANK
YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
MAYBE YOU COULD EXPAND ON A
SENATOR NELSON'S.
QUESTION THERE -- DURING THAT
AUDIT THAT WAS DISCOVERED.
THAT WHERE THERE WAS -- SOME
ISSUES WITH MENTAL HEALTH WHERE
WAS THE DOWNFALLS.
WHAT WAS COPPER TRADING THAT AND
WAS THERE CONTROLS IN PLACE THAT
COULD HAVE SORTED THAT EFFORT IF
IT HAD BEEN?
VIEWED BY OTHERS IN A MORE
TIMELY WAY WITHOUT HAVING TO GO
TO THE EXTENT OF WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING FOR TODAY.
I'D HAVE TO GO BACK AND PREPARE
A RESPONSE TO YOUR YOUR QUESTION
IN MORE DETAIL CURRENT.
SOME OF THAT MIGHT BEAR ERIT
FOR US TO CONTINUE THIS ITEM SO
THAT WE CAN GET A MORE DEFINED.
DETAILED ANSWER.
THANK YOU DONE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS WE WILL HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN.
WELL LET'S GO BACK COLLEAGUES TO
ISSUE. FOR THE
FOURTEEN FORTY
ONE WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO ISSUE
12-1 PAID.
SIXTEEN AND EVERYONE HAS SEEN
THE COMPROMISE LANGUAGE AND SO
ALL ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ACCEPT
THE CONFERENCE COMPROMISE.
THANK YOU IT IS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WITH A VOTE A FOR YOUR GIPSON.
FOUR FOUR FOUR ONE ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE. FIVE ZERO ON THE
SENATE SIDE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT FILE
ITEM IS CLOSED.
COLLEAGUES WERE GONNA DO.
A COUPLE OF MORE [inaudible]
ITEMS.
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO A COUPLE
MORE ITEMS?
IF WE COULD GO ON TO ITEM.
SIXTEEN ASSISTED LIVING WAIVER
EXPANSION UNDER DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
THE ASSISTED LIVING WAIVER
ALLOWS UNLIMITED NUMBER OF MEDI
CAL BENEFICIARIES TO RECEIVE
SERVICES IN AN ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITY AS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
MORE COSTLY SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES.
THE ASSISTED LIVING WAIVERS
CURRENTLY WOMEN TO YOU
500-070-0404 SLOTS IN FIFTEEN
COUNTIES.
THE GOVERNOR MADE NO PROPOSAL ON
THIS ISSUE IN THE ASSEMBLY TOOK
NO ACTION IN THIS AREA.
THE SENATE TOOK ACTION TO DIRECT
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. TO INCREASE ALE W.
SLOTS BY -- FIVE THOUSAND IN
EARLY TWENTY TWENTY WITH
ADDITIONAL INCREASES -- IN
FOLLOWING YEARS IN AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE
SENATE ACTION REDUCES SUPPORT
FOR THE MEDICARE PROGRAM IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY BY TWENTY
THREE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS --
FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO REFLECT
THAT SAVINGS RELATED TO THIS
ACTION -- IN LIGHT OF THE STRONG
LIKELIHOOD THAT EXPANDING THE
ASSISTED LIVING WAIVER WOULD
RESULT IN SOME STATES SAVINGS WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPT THE SENSE ACTION AND
CONCEPT.
HOWEVER WE WOULD NOTE THAT --
THE AMOUNT OF SAVINGS OVER ITS
PARTICULAR VER THE LONGER TERM
EXPANSION -- MAY NOT BE -- AS
SIGNIFICANT AS HAS ESTIMATED --
ONE ISSUE TO KEEP IN MIND IS
THAT -- THIS PROGRAM TARGETS
PEOPLE WHO ARE IN SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES -- WHERE THE
COST THE STATE ARE MORE
SIGNIFICANT BUT THAT ARE WELL
SUITED?
TO RESIDE IN ASSISTED LIVING
FACILITY IN AFTER A CERTAIN
POINT IT'S NOT REALLY CLEAR
WHERE THAT WOULD BE.
AFTER A CERTAIN POINT THE POOL
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHAT WILL
RUN OUT AND AFTER THAT.
AND THE LEVEL OF SAVINGS WOULD
BE DIMINISH SO IT'S NOT CLEAR
THAT -- THE AMOUNT OF SAVINGS
WOULD BE CONSISTENT OVER THE
ENTIRE RAMP UP OF OF THE SENSE
ACTION.
AT SECOND IN -- NINETEEN TWENTY
THE SENATE ACTION LIKELY
OVERSTATES THE AMOUNT OF SAVINGS
THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR A
FEW REASONS NUMBER -- ONE WE
BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WOULD LIKELY
REQUIRE SOME ADDITIONAL STATE
OPERATIONS RESOURCES OUT LIKELY
NOT MORE THAN A FEW MILLION
DOLLARS TO PROCESS THE TO
ADDITIONAL APPLICATIONS FROM A
SIGNIFICANT RAMP UP OF SLOTS --
SECOND -- INCREASING THE
CAPACITY OF THE PROGRAM WOULD
REQUIRE FEDERAL APPROVAL --
BEFORE THE SLOTS COULD BE
CREATED -- AND THEN ONCE THE
SLOTS ARE CREATED IT WOULD TAKE
SOME TIME TO PAY TO PROCESS
APPLICATIONS AND ALTHOUGH THE
SENATE ACTION DOES REFLECT.
A DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION THE
ADDITIONAL SLOTS OUR SIGNIFICAN
AND NUMBER AND AND WE BELIEVE
THAT -- THE ROLE I WOULD LIKELY
BE SLOWER THAN WHAT IT IS SOON
TO THE SENATE ACTION.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THEIR SAVINGS
ESTIMATES -- SOME OF THE REASONS
WERE DESCRIBED BY THE LA OPEN.
IN ADDITION AND WE LOOK AT THE
PROPOSAL AND WONDER ABOUT SOME
OF THE COST PRESSURES INCLUDING
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS THAT MAY
NOT BE REFLECTED IN THE PROPOSAL.
AND THEN FINALLY MORE BROADLY WE
BELIEVE THAT THE EXPANSION WERE
WHETHER TO EXPERT THE QUESTION
OF WHETHER TO EXPAND THIS
PROGRAM.
IS A BROADER POLICY DECISION
THAT SHOULD BE DISCUSSED IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE TRANSFORMATION.
THE TRANSFORMATION OF OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND AS WELL
THE RENEWAL OR POSSIBLE RENEWAL
OF THIS WAIVER AN INTEGRATION
WITH ANOTHER WAIVER.
OVER THE NEXT ONE TO TWO YEARS
A QUICK QUESTION I HAVE IN TERMS
OF THE WAITING LIST BECAUSE THE
WAIVER WAS FOR REALLY A MERE
FIFTY SEVEN HUNDRED SLOT -- IS
THAT A NUMBER THAT WE REQUESTED
THE WAIVER IS AT LOOK WHAT THE
FEDS CAME AND HOW HOW DID THAT
NUMBER COME ABOUT -- SINCE WE DO
HAVE A WAITING LIST.
SO THE WAIVER HISTORICALLY HAS
BEEN AT ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND
SLOTS AND THAT'S BEEN OVER A TEN
PLUS YEARS -- WE RECENTLY
EXPANDED BY TWO THOUSAND SLOTS
IN THE NEW TWENTY EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT -- AND THIS WAIVER
WAS ALWAYS INTENDED TO BE.
RIGHT NOW IT OPERATES AND
FIFTEEN COUNTY SO IT'S ALL IT
WAS ALWAYS INTENDED TO BE AT A
AT A MINOR.
SCALE -- AND SO YES SO STARKLY
ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND I'M WORRIED
ABOUT SIX THOUSAND NOW -- SLOTS
WE CONSIDER AS WE TALK ABOUT IN
MANY INSTANCES IN BOTH THE
NUMBER POLICY COMMITTEES BUT
PLUS THE BUDGET COMMITTEE -- THE
AGING OF THE STATE'S POPULATION
IT IF ARE THOUGHT TO BE AT FOUR
THOUSAND FOUR DECADE IT JUST
SEEMS -- GIVEN THE COST SAVINGS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MANAGE PEOPLE
WHO ARE HAVE THE CAPACITY BEING
ASSISTED LIVING VERSUS THE SMITH
JUST SEEMS PRUDENT.
SO IS THERE -- AS WE GO FORWARD.
IF IF THAT YOUR ASSERTION THAT
WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED HERE.
ISN'T IN THEFISCAL BEST
INTERESTS AT THE STAKE IS A
BECAUSE WE IN EFFECT WOULD BE
UPSIDE DOWN -- ARE.
DO YOU AT ANY POINT -- HAVE AN
INTENTION TO TRY TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF SLOTS. FOR THE WAIVER
IN THE FUTURE.
SO THEN TEN WHAT DOES WAIVER
BECAUSE AGAIN IT IS ONLY LIMITED
TO FIFTEEN COUNTIES AND THAT WE
WOULD INTEGRATE THIS WAIVER --
WITH THE HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED ALTERNATIVES WAIVER DURING
THE NEXT RENEWAL IN A FEW YEARS
OKAY AND SO THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR
A BROADER SCALABILITY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE -- BUT FOR NOW THE
WAIVER IS IS LIMITED -- IN SCOPE.
GOT IT.
QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
MISTER MOORE Là.
I'M SURE I'M I'M HAVING
DIFFICULTY WITH THE TERM SLOTS.
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT OUR
PARENTS RIGHT YES TALKING YOU
KNOW.
BEDS ARE WE TALKING PER CAPITA
ARE WE TALKING ONE PERSON PER
ROOM TWO PEOPLE PER ROOM.
I'VE JUST JUST WONDER IF THERE'S
A BETTER TERM.
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO TELL MY
MOTHER WERE LOOKING FOR A SLOT
YOU KNOW YOU GET WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR A UNITS WERE LOOKING
FOR AN APARTMENT WERE LOOKING
FOR IT DEPENDS ON THE THE
FACILITIES SO IN A SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY IT'S PROBABLY A
BAD.
IN AN ASSISTED LIVING FACILITY
IT COULD BE EITHER OR IT COULD
BE A UNIT WHERE SHE WOULD BE AND
YOU THE BUYER SELF OR HAVE A
ROOMMATE I MEAN I THINK IT
VARIES [inaudible]
THE STEP.
POINT MAYBE WE COULD LOOK AT IN
THE FUTURE THAT MAYBE WE CAN
FIND BETTER NOMENCLATURE JUST A
LITTLE.
MORE RESPECTFUL.
THANK YOU.
I DON'T I'M NOT.
A VERSE THE SLOT BUT OKAY WILL
WORK ON THAT THANK YOU.
OKAY I GOT TO I'M OFFENDED BY
CLEARLY.
THIRD FOURTH CONVERSATION ABOUT
IT.
WE'LL WORK ON THAT USE ANYMORE
Là.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
DON'T SAY THE WORD SLOT ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS.
DOCTOR WEBER.
I'M AWAKE YES.
I PROMISED I WOULDN'T BE LONG
THAT'S WHY -- YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT HAVING ADDED ADDED
INDIVIDUALS TO BASICALLY ASSESS.
WITHIN A PERSON NEEDS TO BE IN A
NURSING HOME OR IN.
A IN AN ASSISTED LIVING FACILITY
AS SOMEONE THAT'S WHY YOU NEED
PERSONNEL.
IS THAT WHAT YOU SAID.
THE MINISTER OF THE PROGRAM --
ACCORDING TO THIS EXPANSION SO
GOING FROM FROM SIX THOUSAND
SLOTS APPROXIMATELY TWO EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL STAFF RESOURCES TO
ADMINISTER.
THE EXPANSION.
AND THE ADDITIONAL PERSON THOUGH
ARE ARE ALREADY ASSUME IN SOME
SYSTEM IS THAT CORRECT THESE ARE.
COMPLETELY NEW INDIVIDUALS.
THE WORK CURRENTLY AT ABOUT SIX
THOUSAND SLOTS BUT THE EXPANSION
WOULD BE NEW INDIVIDUALS.
OKAY.
SO THAT'S WHY YOU NEED THE EXTRA
ONE NOT NECESSARILY MOVING
PEOPLE FROM THE NORTH FROM THE A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY TO A A
A A DIFFERENT.
LEVEL OF CARE.
SO THESE WOULD BE PRINT BRENDA
PEOPLE WE WOULD NOT BE ASSESSING
THOSE WILL CURRENTLY IN A
FACILITY.
THAT IS A SAY AT THE NURSING
FACILITY AND DECIDING THAT THEY
DON'T NEED AS MUCH CARE AND
THEREFORE IT'S COULD BE PLACED
INTO.
AN ASSISTED LIVING IS OR WOULD
THAT ALSO OCCUR THESE WOULD BE
NEW BENEFICIARIES -- FOR DISH
ADDITIONAL BEDS FOR ADDITIONAL
BENEFICIARIES OKAY THANK YOU.
I THINK THEY'RE COMING FROM
SMITH BUT I THINK THEY'RE COMING
FROM SNIFF DOCTOR WEBER WITH
THAT YEAH THEIR CRIME WAS AND I
WAS WONDERING BECAUSE IT WAS
THEY WERE GOING TO SAVE MONEY BY
HAVING.
A FEW OF THEM INTO THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY BECAUSE OF THE
COST.
OF THE CONTRACT RIGHT AND AND
AND THOSE KIND OF THINGS HAT I
WOULD THAT'S WHY I'M SAYING
THEY'RE ALREADY.
DEALING WITH THIS POPULATION YOU
KNOW SOMETIMES WE ASK FOR STAFF
AND WE REALLY DON'T NEED STAFF
BECAUSE YOU DEAL WITH THE SAME
POPULATION AND YOU DOING AN
ASSESSMENT.
OF WHERE THEY ARE AND WITHIN
THAT IT'S AN APPROPRIATE
PLACEMENT BUT IF YOU'RE ADDING
NEW PEOPLE YOU MIGHT NEED
ADDITIONAL PERSON I WAS JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
WITH WHAT WHAT WE WERE ACTUALLY
DOING -- AND AND CLEARLY MOVING
ON FROM A HIGHER NEED TO A A
LESSEN THE FACILITY IS ALWAYS
THAT ONLY COST SAVING BUT IT'S
ALSO BETTER FOR THE PERSON WHO'S
IN THAT LESS A FACILITY.
OF ITS THE SO I JUST WANTED TO
KNOW WHAT PEOPLE IN PACE BE
INVOLVED IN THIS AT ANY POINT A
WE LOOKING AT PACE IN THIS I WAS
AT A TOTALLY SEPARATE PROGRAM.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS A SEPARATE
PROGRAM BUT I WILL GO BACK AND
CONFIRM.
OKAY BECAUSE I KNOW THAT'S QUITE
A COST SAVINGS AS WELL.
OKAY THANK YOU AND SO THE LAST
THING I WILL ADD ON ON THIS
PROPOSAL IS THAT -- AT THE SICK
A SIGNIFICANT EXPANSION OF THIS
SIZE WE DO HAVE CAPACITY CONCERN
SO THE AVAILABILITY OF BEDS ON
THE GROUND.
AND SO -- THE RECENT EXPANSION
TO TWO THOUSAND SLOTS HAS -- WE
ARE STILL FACING AND THAT
EXPANSION AND SO DID WANT TO
NOTE THAT FOR FOR CONSIDERATION.
AND WE WOULD BE ASKING YOU TO TO
DOUBLE.
HISTORICALLY WHAT YOU'VE BEEN
DOING FROM FIFTY SEVEN HUNDRED
TO AN ADDITIONAL.
TEN THOUSAND OKAY.
ANY MORE QUESTIONS.
OKAY THREE NUMBER GOING TO HOLD
THIS ITEM OPEN -- ACCORDING TO
THE CLOCK ON THE WALL IT'S TEN
MINUTES.
TO SEVEN I KNOW THIS IS HARD BUT
I'D I THINK WE WANT TO NOT TAKE
A LEISURELY BREAK -- WOULD
PEOPLE BE COMFORTABLE COMING
BACK BY. SEVEN FIFTEEN SEVEN
FIFTEEN OKAY THANK YOU WE WILL
STAND IN RECESS ON I WILL GAVEL
DOWN AT
I'M STUNNED THAT THOSE LITTLE
SOUND ALIKE.
THE ROCK [inaudible]
YOU INTELLIGENCE. SIX NAY ON THE
OLD NAY.
YOU THINK YOU THINK YES THANKS
[inaudible]
TO IN TODAY'S.
THE CAST RAY.
I KNOW I'M OLD THE COULD BE
LATIN [inaudible] FIVE TO GET
THE LA ALL LAUGH TO WAKE HIM UP.
WELCOME BACK ALL -- WE'RE GOING
TO BEGIN AGAIN.
WITH ISSUE NUMBER.
SEVENTEEN ON PAGE TWENTY ONE
EXPANSION OF THE F. B. I. R. T.
AT ANOTHER WAY THAT. TO OPIOIDS
AND OTHER DRUGS WE'LL HEAR FROM
THE LA HELLO BEN JOHNSON AGAIN
WITH HELIO -- THE GOVERNOR HAD
NO PROPOSAL RELATED S. BIRD.
OF THE SENATE APPROVED A POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS TOTAL FUNDS
TWO POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ADOPTED PLACEHOLDER
TRADE GOD TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
TO EXPAND.
A NEW MEDI CAL BENEFIT FOR
SCREENING BRIEF INTERVENTION
REFERRAL AND TREATMENT TO
INCLUDE SCREENING FOR OPIOIDS
AND ILLICIT DRUGS IN ADDITION TO
ALCOHOL THE ASSEMBLY TOOK NO
ACTION ON THIS ITEM [inaudible]
WE SUPPORT.
SUBSTANCE USE COUNTS AS AN
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT.
LA OUT AGAIN THE GOVERNOR HAD NO
PROPOSAL ON THIS ITEM THE SENATE
APPROVED TEN MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ON GOING TO SUPPORT --
THE HIRING OF TRAIN SUPER OF
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER PEER
NAVIGATORS AND A BEHAVIOR HEALTH
CARE NAVIGATORS WITHIN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS AT ACUTE CARE
HOSPITALS.
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ON
A ONE TIME BASIS. TO SUPPORT
THESE PEER NAVIGATORS AND PLACE
THEM IN THE AT EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS OF ACUTE CARE
HOSPITALS THUS THE CONFERENCE
ISSUE BEFORE YOU IS THE FUNDING
LEVEL. TEN MILLION IN THE SENATE
VERSUS TWENTY MILLION IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE LENGTH OF TIME --
WHETHER OR NOT FOR SO WOULD E
ONE TIME IN THE ASSEMBLY AND ON
GOING IN THE SENATE [inaudible]
FINANCE.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS CONCERNS
ABOUT COSTS HERE SO WE DO NOT
INCLUDE THIS IN OUR BUDGET
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
MR MCCARTY YEAH THANK YOU JUST
JUST BRIEFLY.
YOU KNOW THIS IS A A GREAT
EFFORT YOU MENTIONED EARLIER UC
DAVIS THOUGHT FUNDING AT UC
DAVIS WILL I LEARNED ABOUT THIS
EFFORT AT OUR UC DAVIS HOSPITAL
IN MY DISTRICT IS LOOSELY BASED
AFTER OF THIS PROGRAM.
CALLED THE TAMI MODEL THERE'S A
GUY THAT LITERALLY SITS THERE IN
THE E. R. THAT HELPS TRANSITION
PEOPLE COME IN.
WHEN THEY'RE HAVING THE
PSYCHOSIS INCIDENTS SO THEY'RE
JUST NOT QUITE RIGHT SO AS
OPPOSED TO HAVING SOMEBODY A
BABY SAID IN THE HOSPITAL?
ON A CONTINUOUS MANNER HE CAN
HELP PUT THEM ON A PATH GOING TO
SOME SUBSTANCE PROGRAM AND SO.
YOU KNOW IT IS GENERAL FUND
COSTS BUT THIS WILL SAVE OUR
HOSPITALS A LOT OF MONEY IN THE
LONG RUN AND FREE UP SPACE AT
OUR SEE DEPARTMENTS THANK YOU.
LITTLE -- HOLE THAT ITEM OPEN IF
THERE ARE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES SENATOR WARLOCK.
THIS.
THE SETTLEMENT MCCARTY WOULD
THIS BE LIKE A DETOX.
CENTER.
NO IT'S REALLY KIND OF THAT
INDIVIDUAL IS A IT.
IS A FAMILIAR THREE AUCH WHEN
YOU GOT A HOTEL THE PERSON HELPS
ANYONE YOUR WAY IS THIS SOMEONE
WHOSE LITTLE YOU THERE THAT
HELPS -- SEND PEOPLE TO THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT EXISTS
AS OPPOSED TO HAVING SOMEBODY
STATE -- FOR TWENTY FOUR HOURS
RELEASE THEM AND HAVE THEM GO ON
THEIR WAY AND THEY THE
UNFORTUNATE COME BACK YOU KNOW
SOMETIMES THE VERY NEXT DAY
SOMETIMES THAT DAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
WILL THANK YOU FOR THAT
INFORMATION MISTER MCCARTY.
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER
HOLD ITEM OPEN MOVING TO ISSUE
NINETEEN EXTENSION OF MEDICARE
FOR POST PARTUM MENTAL HEALTH LA
JOH -- MEDI CAL EXTENDS
ELIGIBILITY TO PREGNANT WOMEN --
OVER THE NORMAL INCOME
ELIGIBILITY STANDARDS -- AND
THEN IT ULTIMATELY AFTER THEY
HAVE THEIR BABY SIXTY DAYS AFTER
THEY HAVE THEIR BABY -- THEY ARE
NO LONGER ELIGIBLE FOR THE
PROGRAM THEY WOULD CONVERT TO
ANOTHER FORM OF COVERAGE --THE
GOVERNOR HERE ON THIS ITEM HAD
NO PROPOSAL WELL THE SENATE
APPROVED A POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND. TO
SUPPORT AN EXTENSION OF THIS
MEDI CAL ELIGIBILITY FROM SIXTY
DAYS TO ONE YEAR FOR POST PARTUM
WOMEN -- THAT ARE DIAGNOSED WITH
A MENTAL HEALTH DISORDER THE
ASSEMBLY TOOK NO ACTION ON THIS
ITEM.
AND THE BUDGET SIX TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE TERM OPPOSITION FIFTY
SIX THE VALUE BASED PAYMENTS
PROGRAM THAT WE DISCUSSED BEFORE
WHICH INCLUDES INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS FOR POST PARTUM MENTAL
HEALTH AND CARE SO WITH WITH
THAT IS THE APPROPRIATE VEHICLE.
AND DO NOT SUPPORT -- THIS ITEM
AT THIS TIME [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES.
QUESTIONS. THIRTY SKINNER
[inaudible]
IT WAS.
UNCLEAR HOW THAT VALUE
[inaudible]
BASED IN [inaudible]
WOULD.
BE SPECIFIC TO THIS POPULATION
[inaudible]
AND THE THE ENLARGEMENT OF THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR MEDI CAL FOR
PREGNANT WOMEN.
IS.
VERY IN MY OPINION LARGE GOAL
BUT IT WAS ALSO. FOR KNOWING
THAT.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT IT.
THAT A MOTHER IN A BABY ARE AT
THE GET THE PROPER -- PRENATAL
CARE SO THAT WE SO THAT WE
IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES AFTER
ALL -- AFTERWARDS.
AND THE CATEGORY OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE IMPACTED BY THIS THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
GET.
THE WOMEN COVERAGE OF A
DIFFERENT SORT IMMEDIATELY.
AND TO BE DROPPED WITHIN THAT
SIXTY DAYS ESPECIALLY IF THEY'RE
GOING THROUGH POSTPARTUM
DEPRESSION.
WHEN THEY ARE EVEN LESS CAPABLE
OF FIGURING OUT HOW TO GET?
OTHER TYPES OF COVERAGE SO I
THINK THAT THE YOU KNOW WE COULD --
YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
WHETHER WE HAVE ANY DATA ON FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE SENATE SEAT POINT
SIX MILLION IS BASED ON SOME
NUMBERS THAT WE ARE.
YOU KNOW SO I GUESS WHAT I'M
RAISING IS.
THERE MIGHT BE THE ABILITY TO
REFINER HONED WITH THE NEEDED
AMOUNT IS.
BUT FROM A DOLLAR POINT OF VIEW.
BUT THE NEED ITSELF IS REAL.
AND I THINK THAT -- IT SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED AS A SPECIFIC CATEGORY.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON MEDI CAL EXPAND
EXTENSION FOR POST PARTUM MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
WILL HOLD ITEM OPEN THANKS FOR
THE COMMENTS.
ISSUE TWENTY CHILDREN'S CRISIS
RESIDENTIAL PROGRAMS ALEJO --
THE GOVERNOR HAD NO PROPOSAL
RELATED TO THIS ITEM THE SENATE
ADOPTION ADOPTED PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO TO FIND
CHILDREN'S CRISIS RESIDENTIAL
PROGRAMS WHICH PROVIDE CRISIS
SERVICES TO CHILDREN.
AS PSYCHIATRIC RESIDENTIAL
TREATMENT FACILITIES FOR THE
PURPOSE OF REIMBURSEMENT THIS
WOULD CHANGE THE REIMBURSEMENT
STRUCTURE FROM ESSENTIALLY AYE
MY UNDERSTANDING IS A SORT OF
FEE FOR SERVICE SO FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL SERVICES THESE
CHILDREN.
PROGRAMS -- CARRY OUT THEY CAN
BILL SEPARATELY TO A FULL IN --
YOU KNOW THE THE AWFUL STAY
OVERNIGHT THE ASSEMBLY TOOK NO
OPTION NO ACTION ON THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
Q..
FINANCE THIS ITEM IS NOT IN OUR
SPENDING PLAN AND WE ARE
ESTIMATING SOME ADDITIONAL
OPERATIONAL COSTS ABOUT BEYOND
WHAT THE SENATE HAS ESTIMATES.
I'M GOING BASIS.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS. THREE NINE
HOLE THAT ITEM OPEN ISSUE TWENTY
ONE HEALTH ENROLLMENT NAVIGATORS
ALEJO.
THIS ISSUE RELATES TO FUNDING
FOR HEALTH AND ROMAN NAVIGATORS
THAT WOULD PROVIDE ENROLLMENT
RETENTION -- ASSISTANCE IN THE
MEDICARE PROGRAM -- BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND THE CALIFORNIAN DOWN
AND PROVIDED TWELVE AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS MATCH BY AN
EQUAL AMOUNT OF FEDERAL FUNDING
FOR THESE ACTIVITIES IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND NO
FUNDING WAS PROVIDED IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
GOVERNOR HAS NO PROPOSAL AND THE
SENATE TOOK NO ACTION IN THIS
AREA BUT THE ASSEMBLY A PRIDE
APPROVED A ONE TIME FUNDING OF
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND WITH AGAIN AN EQUAL
AMOUNT OF FEDERAL FUNDING -- TO
BE AVAILABLE OVER TWO YEARS.
THANK YOU FINANCE AS THE LA --
NOTED -- IN THE PAST THESE --
EFFORTS HAVE OFTEN BEEN FUNDED
BY NINE GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
INCLUDING PHILANTHROPIC DOLLARS
AND AS ALL OF YOU KNOW OUR
MEDICAL PROGRAM NOW COVERS
NEARLY ONE OUT OF EVERY THREE
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OVER
THIRTEEN MILLION.
PEOPLE SO WE THINK THE STATE HAS
DONE A GOOD JOB IN REACHING OUT
TO MOST OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE AND WOULD BENEFIT FROM
COVERAGE IN CARE.
AND THE ONE OTHER THING I SHOULD
MENTION AND I KNOW THIS IS A
CONFERENCE ISSUE FOR LATER BUT
WITH THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE AND
COVER CALIFORNIA WE BELIEVE THAT.
THAT WILL FURTHER STABILIZE THE
MARKET AND MAKE SURE THAT MORE
PEOPLE KNOW ABOUT THE OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO THEM INCLUDING MEDI
CAL ELIGIBILITY.
THANK YOU COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS MISTER MAYES.
A JUST BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE A
LOT OF BACKGROUND I'M HERE NOW.
BUT FOR SOME REASON THIS WEEKEND
I GOT BORED OR A SYSTEM MY MIND
STARTED TO GO DOWN THIS ROAD AND
I TRIED -- TO FIGURE OUT HOW
EASY WOULD BE TO BUILD UP APPLY
FOR MEDI CAL -- YOU A YEAH --
AND AND ACTUALLY -- WHAT START
OFF AT THE -- DH CS SINCE AT ALL
YEAH JUST CLICK HERE AND THEN IT.
SENT ME TO THE NEXT PLANE CAN
SET A WHICH COUNTER YOU AND SO I
CLICKED ON SENATOR DINO.
AND I GOT DECEMBER DINO AND THEN
IT SAID -- PLEASE CLICK TO THIS
HERE AND I THOUGHT.
I HAVE NO IDEA NOW ONCE I'VE GOT
THAT HOW TO APPLY NOW YOU CAN
APPLY ON COVER CALIFORNIA -- I
UNDERSTAND -- OF COURSE GOING
THROUGH THAT WHOLE PROCESS.
BUT IF YOU WERE THINKING
YOURSELF YOU KNOW I'D LIKE TO
APPLY FOR MEDI CAL.
THERE'S NOT A QUICK AND EASY WAY
AT LEAST FOR ME AND I'M NOT VERY
SMART NOW MIND YOU BUT IF YOU'RE
THE PUBLIC.
TOM IT'S TOUGH TO BE ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT HEY GO UP AND UP AND
APPLIES SO IS THAT WHAT THESE
THESE DOLLARS.
ARE FOR TO BE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MAKE IT SIMPLE BECAUSE OF
SOMEBODY WANTED TO APPLY ARE
ACTUALLY WHAT THE PROCESS BEGIN
TO APPLY.
WE SHOULD BE MAKING THIS AS
SIMPLE AS POSSIBLE TO BE ABLE TO
DO SO.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THESE
DOLLARS WILL BE PRIMARILY
TARGETED -- TO PROVIDING FUNDING
TO ORGANIZATIONS THAT WOULD HELP
LOCATE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
LIKELY ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICARE BUT
DON'T KNOW OR AREN'T SURE HOW TO
PLAN ASSISTING THEM IT WOULD NOT
BE IS RELATED.
TO CHANGING THE WAY THAT THE
APPLICATION PROCESS WORKS.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE NO I MEAN I
THINK IT'S JUST ONE OF THOSE
JUST MAKING IT SIMPLE I THINK IF
YOU KNOW HEY I WANT TO BE ABLE
TO APPLY. FOR FOR MEDI CAL IS
THAT YOU GO TO COVER CALIFORNIA
WHAT IS COVERED CALIFORNIA
MEANER DISCOVER CALIFORNIA YOU
GOT THE APPLICATION PROCESS IN
ON MICHAEL LEADS YOU -- LEAD
LEAD TO THEIR YOU KNOW THERE'S
SOME CONFUSION ON ON YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS FOR DIFFERENT
TO DIFFERENT FOLKS BUT IT
DOESN'T SEEM VERY SIMPLE AND
USER FRIENDLY.
WHEN YOU'RE GOING TO IT TO TRY
TO UP TO APPLY AT LEAST IT DID
FOR ME -- OVER THE WEEKEND AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S SOMETHING
WE'RE GONNA BE SPENDING MONEY --
I I THINK MAYBE THE FIRST STEP
IN SPENDING SOME MONEY IS MAKING
IT VERY SIMPLE -- AND AND HAVING --
A THE USER INTERFACE TO ALLOW
PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO A TO DO IT
THAT'S JUST MY THOUGHTS.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
CAN I FEAR NONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL HOLD THAT ITEM OPEN.
ISSUE TWENTY TWO CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY TRANSITIONS --
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES LA -- CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY TRANSITIONS PROGRAM
ADDENDA FI'S INDIVIDUALS IN AN
INSTITUTIONAL SETTING SUCH AS A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY -- THAT
CAN LIVE SAFELY IN A COMMUNITY --
SETTING AND PROVIDE SERVICES TO
FACILITATE THIS TRANSITION -- AS
AN EXAMPLE THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE TRANSITIONS PROGRAM
HAS MOVED -- SOME INDIVIDUALS
INTO THE ASSISTANT LIFE LIVING
WAIVER PROGRAM WHICH WE
DISCUSSED -- ON A PREVIOUS ITEM.
THIS PROGRAM HAS LARGELY BEEN
FUNDED THROUGH A FEDERAL GRANT
PROGRAM KNOWN AS MONEY FOLLOWS
THE PERSON REBALANCING
DEMONSTRATION WHICH EXPIRES.
IN SEPTEMBER.
TWENTY NINETEEN THE GOVERNOR HAS
NO PROPOSAL IN THIS AREA AND THE
SENATE TOOK NO ACTION.
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED FOURTEEN
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE GENERAL FUND. TO BACK FILL
THE LOSS OF FEDERAL MONEY
FOLLOWS THE PERSON GRANT FUNDING
TO ALLOW THIS PROGRAM TO
CONTINUE -- BUT ALSO ASSUMES
OFFSETTING SAVINGS OF AN EQUAL
AMOUNT -- IN LIGHT OF THE THE
THE ASSUMPTION THAT PICKED
COMMUNITY PLACEMENTS ARE LESS
COSTLY THAN INSTITUTIONAL
PLACEMENTS.
AND TRANSITIONS IN THE PROGRAM
ARE TYPICALLY ESTIMATED TO
RESULT IN GENERAL FUND SAVINGS
THAT ARE SHARED BY THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THE ACTUAL EXTENT OF
OFFSETTING SAVINGS FROM THE X.
SIMPLY ACTION IS UNCERTAIN -- IN
OUR VIEW THIS WOULD DEPEND IN
PART ON WHICH SERVICES THE STATE
COULD RECEIVE REGULAR FEDERAL
MATCHING FUNDS.
FOR NOW THAT THE FEDERAL MONEY
FOLLOWS PERSON GRANT FUNDING HAS
THAT WILL BE EXPIRING -- IT'S
OUR UNDERSTANDING THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN WORKING
ON AN ESTIMATE FOR THIS ACTION
BUT WE'VE NOT RECEIVED IT OR
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW
IT AT THIS TIME.
FINANCE THIS ITEM IS NOT IN OUR
BUDGET AS LA -- MENTIONED THAT
FEDERAL GRANT EXPIRES THIS
SEPTEMBER AND WE ARE NOT SURE IF
IT WILL BE RENEWED SO THAT COULD
CREATE SOME ADDITIONAL PRESSURE
ON THE STATE BUDGET.
MMHM MMHM.
QUESTIONS MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
ISSUE TWENTY THREE FRIDAY NIGHT
LIVE FUNDING DELEO.
FRIDAY NIGHT LIVE PROGRAM --
PROVIDE SERVICES AIMED AT
PREVENTING TEEN SUBSTANCE USE
GOVERNOR HAD NO PROPOSAL AND THE
SENATE TOOK NO ACTION ON THIS
ITEM THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED ONE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME FOR THE FRIDAY NIGHT
PROGRAM.
FINANCE THIS ITEM IS NOT OUR
BUDGET.
QUESTIONS MEMBERS MISTER MOORE
Là.
THE LAST TIME THIS PROGRAM WAS
ADDED.
FOR MEASURE MENTION RESULTS.
I'M A WE CAN LOOK AND TRY TO
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION TO YOU.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT AT THE START
[inaudible]
QUESTION.
IN THE OTHERS.
THE WHOLE THAT ITEM OPEN.
ISSUE TWENTY FOUR CARE GIVER
RESOURCE CENTERS.
HELLO.
THE STATE CURRENTLY CONTRACTS
WITH ELEVEN CARE GIVER RESOURCE
CENTERS -- IN VARIOUS LOCATIONS
IN THE STATE TO PROVIDE SERVICES
AND SUPPORTS TO FAMILIES AND
OTHER CARE GIVERS OF PERSONS
WITH PHYSICAL AND COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENTS -- EXAMPLES OF
SERVICES INCLUDE SUPPORT GROUPS
LEGAL AND FINANCIAL CONSULTATION --
ANOTHER EDUCATION TYPE SERVICES.
IN RECENT YEARS THE STATE BUDGET
HAS INCLUDED FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND -- FOR THESE CONTRACTS.
THE GOVERNOR -- HAS NO PROPOSAL
IN THIS AREA AND THE SENATE TOOK
NO ACTION.
AND THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED AN
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME AMOUNT OF
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND.
AND TO BE EXPENDED OVER THREE
YEARS THIS FUNDING WOULD BE TO
EXPAND SERVICE DELIVERY BY THE
CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTERS AND
TO SCALE UP AND IT SYSTEM THAT.
IS CURRENTLY USED BY TWO OF THE
LARGEST CENTERS -- TO THE
REMAINING CENTERS IN THE STATE.
BEFORE WE GO TO FINANCE CAN YOU
TELL US WHERE THE ELEVEN CENTERS
ARE DO YOU HAVE THAT INFORMATION
BY ANY CHANCE -- YES THEY ARE
LOCATED IN THERE'S A A REDWOOD --
CENTER DELAURO -- SOME OF THESE
I JUST HAVE THE NAMES OF THEM IN
THE GENERAL LOCATIONS -- INLAND
EMPIRE ORANGE COUNTY SAN DIEGO --
ONE OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA -- THERE'S A
BAY AREA -- FACILITY THAT
APPEARS TO BE IN SAN FRANCISCO
THOSE ARE THE APPROXIMATE
LOCATIONS.
THANK YOU FINANCE.
SO ALTHOUGH THE APPROPRIATION
HERE A PROPOSED BY THE ASSEMBLY
IS ONE TIME -- THE MINISTRATION
EXPECTS THAT WATER WOULD RESULT
IN ON GOING COST PRESSURES AND
WORDS ON CERTAIN WHERE THAT
FUNDING OF WERE ESTIMATING ABOUT
TEN MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
WOULD COME FROM.
IN ADDITION THE ADMINISTRATION
AND I HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE LEVEL OF DETAIL IN THIS
PROPOSAL SO FOR RIGHT NOW WE ARE
SUPPORTING THE SENATE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
MEMBERS. THREE NINE THANK YOU.
ISSUE TWENTY FIVE AUDIOLOGY
LIAISON.
ELIA.
THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
SERVICES PROGRAM -- PROVIDES
MEDICAL SERVICES TO CHILDREN --
WHO ARE MEDICALLY FRAGILE -- THE
GOVERNOR SAID I HAD NO PROPOSAL
ON THIS ITEM IN THE SENATE TOOK
NO ACTION WHILE THE ASSEMBLY
APPROVED A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND.
TO FUND AT ONE POSITION TO SERVE
AS A LATE LIAISON BETWEEN
AUDIOLOGISTS AND CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S SERVICES PROGRAM WITH
THE AIM OF REDUCING DELAYS IN
TREATMENT AUTHORIZATIONS AND
REIMBURSEMENTS [inaudible]
FINANCE THE ADMINISTRATION
PLEASE THAT EXISTING PERSONNEL
ARE ADEQUATE TO PERFORM THESE
TASKS.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS.
HOLD THE ITEM OPEN ISSUE TWENTY
SIX COUNTY OF RESIDENCE.
STD TREATMENT FUNDING DISPUTES
ALEJO -- SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
SERVICES ARE PRIMARILY FUNDED --
THROUGH -- WITH WITH COUNTY
FUNDING INCLUDING REALIGNMENT
FUNDING THAT THE THE THE THE
STATE A SENSE TO COUNTIES -- THE
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR HAD NO
PROPOSAL ON THIS ITEM AND THE
SENATE TOOK NO ACTION WELL THE
ASSEMBLY ADOPTED PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
ESTABLISH A PROCESS -- FOR
RESOLVING COUNTY OF RESIDENCE --
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
FUNDING DISPUTES WHEN AN
INDIVIDUAL SEEKS TREATMENT IN A
COUNTY OF WHICH THEY ARE NOT A
RESIDENT.
FINANCE THE COST CONSEQUENCES OF
THIS PROPOSAL ARE UNCERTAIN SO
IT'S NOT IN OUR BUDGET
[inaudible]
MEMBERS [inaudible]
THIS [inaudible]
SKINNER.
I WONDERED IF THE MAYBE IT'S NOT
FOR THIS BUDGET BUT WHETHER THE
ADMINISTRATION.
HAS LOOKED AT THIS IS NOT THE
ONLY CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE.
THE FACT THAT WE ADMINISTER SO
MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS THROUGH
COUNTIES HAS -- ALL SAY
INTERFERED NUTS NOT WITH THE
JUDGMENT BUT RATHER.
JUST A FACT WITH THE ABILITY OF
A RECIPIENT -- TO ACCESS.
SO FOR EXAMPLE IN THE CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT'S
ADMINISTERED INDIVIDUALLY BY
EACH COUNTY WE HAD DURING THE
RECESSION.
THE DIFFICULTY WHERE A FAMILY
WOULD BE -- EITHER FORECLOSED ON
OR SOMEHOW YOU KNOW HAVE TO MOVE
TO A DIFFERENT COUNTY AND THEY
COULDN'T JUST BRING THEIR
BENEFITS WITH THEM THEY HAD TO
COMPLETELY START OVER AND RE
APPLY.
AND WE'RE SEEING A SIMILAR
PROBLEM NOW HERE WITH THE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT AND OF
COURSE WITH THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT.
AT LEAST WITH CAL FRESH.
NO MATTER WHICH COUNTY URINEYOU
CAN GET IT BUT THERE'S NOT
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
PROGRAMS IN EVERY SINGLE COUNTY --
AND THERE'S MANY MANY OTHER I
COULD GIVE LOTS OF DIFFERENT
EXAMPLES WERE SIMILAR WHERE WE
HAVE A SIMILAR SITUATION WHERE.
THIS KIND OF NEAR GEOGRAPHICAL
DIVISION OF COUNTY.
DOESN'T RELATE TO THE ACTUAL
NEED OF THE INDIVIDUAL WHO NEEDS
A SERVICE OR THE DELIVERY OF THE
SERVICE.
SO WHEN I SAW THIS ITEM I
THOUGHT YOU KNOW SETTING UP A
DISPUTE MEDIATION JUST FOR THIS.
ONE WHEN WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
MULTIPLE DIFFERENT SERVICES THAT
ARE IMPACTED BY SUCH A BY THIS --
IT JUST SEEMED LIKE WE SHOULD BE
ABLE -- TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
SOLVE IT SO AND PEOPLE CAN
[inaudible]
KERRY THERE.
BENEFIT WITH A MORE CARRY THEIR
YOU KNOW IT CAN BE TRANSFERRED
EASIER AND NOT WITH A LOT OF A
HASSLE. FOR THE COMMENTS.
SEE NUMBER GONNA KEEP TO TWENTY
SIX OPEN ISSUE TWENTY SEVEN
HOSPITAL REIMBURSEMENT FOR HIGH
COST DRUGS.
OHIO.
IN IT MEDI CAL.
HOSPITAL INPATIENT STAYS ARE
REIMBURSED THROUGH METHODOLOGY
KNOWN AS DIAGNOSIS.
RELATED GROUPS WHICH IS A
BUNDLED PAYMENT FOR THE WHOLE
SUITE OF SERVICES ESSENTIALLY
THAT AN INDIVIDUAL IS RECEIVING
IN THAT INPATIENT STAY.
THIS ARE THE GOVERNOR AT HAD NO
PROPOSAL IN THIS AREA AND THE
SENATE TOOK NO ACTION WELL THIS
CERTAINLY ADOPTED TRAILER BILL
TO ESTABLISH A NEW REIMBURSEMENT.
METHODOLOGY FOR HOSPITALS THAT
WOULD REIMBURSE -- THAT THE
HOSPITALS FOR NEWLY APPROVED
HIGH COST DRUGS OUTSIDE OF THE
BUNDLED DIAGNOSIS RELATED GROUP
PAYMENT [inaudible]
FINANCE.
FINANCE IS STILL EVALUATING SOME
THE FISCAL AND POLICY ABOUT SAID
THIS PROPOSAL THAT WE BELIEVE IT
IS VERY POSSIBLE THAT IT COULD
RESULT IN POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT COST PRESSURES WHICH
WERE NOT -- REFLECTED AT NINETY
SPECIFIC SPECIFICITY IN THE
ASSEMBLY PROPOSAL SO FOR THAT
REASON WE SUPPORT THE SENATE ON
THIS.
ONE THANK YOU A QUICK QUESTION
THE LA L. A NEWLY APPROVED HIGH
COST DRUGS WHO WHO.
DETERMINES WHETHER A DRUG MEANS
THAT -- I GOTTA GORY IN SPEAKING
WITH PROPONENTS OF OF OF THIS
INITIATIVE -- ONE THRESHOLD WAS
PUT FORWARD AND FIFTY THOU DRUG
THAT COST MORE THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS -- THERE'S NO
NECESSARY TO NOT THERE'S NOT
NECESSARILY A UNIFORM DEFINITION
OF A HIGH COST DRUGS SO THAT
COULD BE -- CHANGE THROUGH YOU
KNOW THROUGH THE BILL
DEVELOPMENT PROCESS OR THROUGH A
PROCESS AND DH CS.
RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
SEE NORMALLY THAT ITEM OPEN
ISSUE TWENTY EIGHT VIRTUAL
DENTAL HOMES CLEAR FINE LANGUAGE --
ELIA.
VIRTUAL DENTISTRY IS WHERE --
DODD DENTISTS DENTAL SERVICES
ARE PROVIDED -- BY A PROVIDER
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY -- A
BILLING PROVIDER BUT A BILLING
PROVIDER IS PROVIDING -- SOME
OVERSIGHT OF THAT PROCESS AND SO
FORTH FROM FROM A DENTAL OFFICE.
ON THIS ISSUE GOVERNOR HAD NO
PROPOSAL AND THE SENATE TOOK NO
ACTION WELL THE ASSEMBLY ADOPTED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO CLARIFY
THAT CLINICS ARE NOT -- AND AND
THIS WOULD BE APPLIED TO SUCH IN
ENTITIES AS FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS CLINICS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO HAVE A FACE TO FACE
VISIT -- WITH THE DENTAL PATIENT.
TO ESTABLISH THE PATIENT AS A
CRITICS PATIENT SUCH AS DURING
THESE FOR VIRTUAL DENTAL VISITS.
THANK YOU FINANCE WE SUPPORT THE
SENATE ON THIS PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS. THREE NINE LEAVE THAT
ITEM OFTEN MOVING ON TO ISSUE
TWENTY NINE EARLY PSYCHOSIS
RESEARCH AND TREATMENT
[inaudible]
HELLO.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED AT TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
PROVIDE GRANTS TO COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH PLANS AND NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS -- AS WELL AS
OTHER ENTITIES TO IDENTIFY IN
SUPPORT APPROPRIATE
INTERVENTIONS FOR CALIFORNIA
USED SEXY PAIR IN CERTAIN IN
EARLY SIGNS OF PSYCHOSIS.
THE SENATE REJECTED THE
GOVERNOR'S -- PROPOSAL AND
APPROVED INSTEAD TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND --
FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION TO FIND -- IT'S EARLY
PSYCHOSIS IN EARLY PSYCHOSIS
INTERVENTION PLUS PROGRAM THAT
IT IT OPTED PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD ALLOW
THE GENERAL FUND ARE TO BE USED
FOR THIS PROGRAM INSTEAD OF WHAT
PREVIOUSLY WOULD HAVE BEEN.
A MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUNDS.
THE ASSEMBLY REJECTED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AS WELL AND
APPROVED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND
FOR THEM AND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION. TO
FUND THE SAME EARLY PSYCHOSIS
INVENTION PLUS PROGRAM -- IT
WOULD IT ADOPTED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ALLOW GENERAL FUND
TO BE USED FOR THIS PURPOSE --
SO THE ISSUE BEFORE YOU TODAY IS
THE FUNDING LEVEL TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE SENATE
VERSUS TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE ASSEMBLY -- AS WELL AS
THE FUNDING SOURCE GENERAL FUND
ON THE SENATE SIDE AND TOWARD
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE.
FINANCE WILL MAKE THREE BRIEF
POINTS -- FIRST WE BELIEVE THAT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IS
THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PRIORITY FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION I KNOW IT'S COME
UP IN DISCUSSION HERE AS WELL
MAKING SURE THAT AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE WE CAN DIAGNOSE AND
INTERVENE.
IN THESE TYPES OF CASES.
THE SECOND POINT IS WE WANTED
THIS TO BE GENERAL FUND BECAUSE
FOR WE ARE PROPOSING IN OUR
BUDGET.
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND FOR
THE WEB PROGRAM WORKFORCE
EDUCATION AND TRAINING AND I
KNOW ALSO EARLIER TODAY WE
TALKED ABOUT THE NEED TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS SO WE THINK
THAT IS THE BEST USE.
OF THAT MONEY SO ANY REDIRECTION
OF THAT MONEY WOULD REDUCE OUR
ABILITY TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL AND
THEN THE THIRD POINT OUR
PROPOSAL IS A ONE TIME AND SOME
OF THE OTHER PROPOSALS ON THE
TABLE HERE ARE ONGOING.
AND BECAUSE AS ALL OF YOU KNOW
THIS MONEY COMES FROM THE TAX OF
1% MARGINAL ON PEOPLE WHO MAKE
ABOUT THE MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT REVENUE -- IS CAN BE FALL
TILE FROM YEAR TO YEAR SO WE
pFUNDING FROM THAT REVENUE
SOURCES MORE APPROPRIATE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
SIGNAL QUESTIONS WILL HOLD ITEM
OPEN THANK YOU ISSUE THIRTY
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASE
PREVENTION FUNDING ELIA.
SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK -- ELLIE
ABLE TO BUNDLE THE NEXT SEVERAL
ITEMS.
ISSUES THIRTY THROUGH
[inaudible]
THIRTY TWO C<c.cyan> PERFECT.</c>
IS SONYA PEDIGO.
I AM SO THE THREE ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN BUNDLED TOGETHER ALL
CONCERNED -- INCREASED
INVESTMENTS IN -- THE PREVENTION
OF INFECTIOUS DISEASES THE FIRST.
RELATES SPECIFICALLY TO SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED DISEASES -- THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED TO MILLION
FROM THE GENERAL FUND ON AN
ONGOING BASIS FOR LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS FOR PREVENTION OF
STDS.
THE SENATE APPROVED TWENTY
MILLION GENERAL FUND -- IN
ADOPTED PLACE HOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO STRENGTHEN THE
STATUTORY GUIDANCE.
ON HOW THOSE FUNDS ARE
DISTRIBUTED THE ASSEMBLY
MEANWHILE APPROVED TWELVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND AND
ALSO DOCTOR PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE SO THE ISSUE
REALLY IS THE LEVEL OF FUNDING.
SENATE TWENTY MILLION ASSEMBLY
TWELVE MILLION -- THE SECOND
ISSUE ISSUE THIRTY ONE CONCERNS.
RESOURCES FOR THE PREVENTION OF
HIV ON THIS PROPOSAL -- IN THIS
ISSUE THE GOVERNOR HAD NO
PROPOSAL THE SENATE APPROVED
TWENTY MILLION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND ON AN ONGOING BASIS ANA
DOCTORED PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE -- CONCERNING HO
THOSE FUNDS ARE USED THE
ASSEMBLY APPROVED A TEN MILLION
FROM THE GENERAL FUND ONGOING SO
THE ISSUE AGAIN IS THE FUNDING
LEVEL TEN MILLION OR TWENTY
MILLION -- AND FINALLY THE THIRD
ISSUE ISSUE THIRTY TWO IS
RELATED TO PREVENTION OF
HEPATITIS C..
ON THIS ISSUE THE GOVERNOR HAD
NO PROPOSAL THE SENATE TOOK NO
ACTION WELL THE ASSEMBLY
APPROVED TEN MILLION GENERAL
FUND ON AN ONGOING BASIS IN
ADOPTED PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE.
THANK YOU FINANCE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT THEM A
REVISION PROPOSAL.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MISTER
MAYES.
I'M JUST A LITTLE CONFUSED HERE
BECAUSE BUNDLING THEM ALL
TOGETHER SAFE ISSUE THIRTY
THIRTY ONE AND THEN THIRTY TWO
AND AND I IS IT.
THIS IS THE SENATE TWENTY
MILLION.
PLUS TWENTY MILLION AND THAT'S A
TOTAL OF FORTY MILLION.
WOULD ONLY BUNDLED IN TERMS OF
LA ALL PRESENTATION NOT BUNDLED
IN TERMS OF ACTIONS WILL TAKE
LATER OKAY BECAUSE THEY WERE ALL
COMMUNICABLE DISEASES WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH EACH
OF THE EACH OF THESE ACTIONS ARE
SEPARATE.
THEY ARE SEPARATE YES THAT'S
WHAT I WANTED TO MAKE YES.
OKAY.
THIS ONLY BUNDLE IN TERMS OF
PRESENTATION AND THEN THE ONLY
pMICROPHONE IS ON IS.
IT IS -- AT THE BEEN AMAZED AT
THE AT THE NEW -- DRUGS THAT ARE
OUT THERE A TO BE ABLE TO SPEND
WITH HIV DRUGS PREP AND PAT --
AMAZING THAT THE THE WORK THAT'S
DOING -- DOCTORS DON'T KNOW
ABOUT IT'S JUST FASCINATING TO
ME THAT THEY DON'T AND SO I'M AN
INCREASE -- IN IN I THINK THIS
IS A GOOD INVESTMENT -- TO BE
ABLE TO GET THE WORD OUT BECAUSE
THEY DO TO THIS I HAVE A MAJOR
IMPACT ACTUAL DRIVE DOWN COSTS
THE SAME TIME.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
FREEMAN WILL HOLE ALL THREE OF
THESE ITEMS OPEN.
IF YOU THIRTY THREE ALL FARMERS
EARLY DETECTION DIAGNOSIS DELEO.
ON THIS ISSUE -- THE GOVERNOR
HAD NO PROPOSAL -- ASIDE FROM
ACTUALLY SOME -- INVESTMENT OF
THREE MILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
APPROVED BY THE GOVERNMENT BY
BOTH HOUSES THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAD PROPOSED IN JANUARY.
SO -- IN ADDITION TO THAT THE
SENATE HAS APPROVED TEN MILLION
GENERAL FND ONE TIME FOR GRANTS
TO BUILD.
A STATEWIDE PUBLIC HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT --
EARLY DETECTION AND TIMELY
DIAGNOSIS OF ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE
THE ASSEMBLY ALSO A APPROVED
THIS THE SAME A ACTION IS THE
SENATE BUT ADDED AN ADDITIONAL
FIVE MILLION GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME TO FUND RESPITE CARE. FOR
PEOPLE WITH ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE
AND OTHER RELATED DEMENTIAS --
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA CARE COR
[inaudible]
FINANCE.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S FOCUSES
EXAMINING THESE ISSUES THROUGH
THE NEARLY PROPOSED TASK FORCE
ON ALZHEIMER'S PREVENTION AND
PREPAREDNESS WHICH THE GOVERNOR --
ANNOUNCED IN HIS STATE OF THE
STATE ADDRESS AND WHICH WILL BE
CHAIRED BY MARIA SHRIVER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CLARIFICATION FOR ME THE THREE
MILLION YOU REFERENCE THAT WENT
THAT WAS IN THE CHEN RIVER FALLS
YEAH IT IS I APOLOGIZE IF I
CONFUSE THE MATTER BUT I WHEN I
SAID THE GOVERNOR DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING I WAS.
I WANTED TO BE FAIR AND
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE WAS A
PROPOSAL IN JANUARY FOR THREE
MILLION -- FOR GRANTS IN THE IF
IT MINISTER BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH -- SPECIFICALLY
FOR TO TARGET WOMEN AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND PART OF
THOSE FUNDS WOULD BE USED FOR
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE ON IT
ALZHEIMER'S -- IT RELATED WORK
BUT NOT I DELETED YES AND I
APOLOGIZE THAT'S OKAY THANK HERE.
YOU JUST TESTED ME TO MAKE SURE
I WAS PAYING ATTENTION -- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THIS
ITEM.
THIRTY THREE THANK YOU HOLDING
IT OPEN ISSUE.
THIRTY FOUR SAFE COSMETICS
PROGRAM FUNDING ALEJO.
ON THIS ISSUE THE SAFE BECAUSE
MEDICS PROGRAM -- THE GOVERNOR
DID NOT HAVE A PROPOSAL THE
SENATE APPROVED ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING TO
INCREASE STAFFING FOR
ENFORCEMENT.
AND PROGRAM PROGRAM IMPROVEMENT
ACTIVITIES IN THE SAFE BECAUSE
MEDICS PROGRAM.
I'M SORRY THE ASSEMBLY TOOK NO
ACTION THANK YOU.
FINANCE THIS ITEM IS NOT IN OUR
BUDGET [inaudible]
QUESTIONS. THREE NINE THANK YOU
WE HOLD THE ITEM OPEN.
ISSUE THIRTY FIVE LESBIAN
BISEXUAL AND WOMEN'S HEALTH LA
JOH.
THIS ISSUE IS THE SENATE ONLY
ACTION THE SENATE APPROVED
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME TO SUPPORT
A LOCAL COMPREHENSIVE GRANT
PROGRAM TO ADDRESS WAS BEING
BISEXUAL QUEER.
WOMEN'S HEALTH DISPARITIES AND
TO FUND RESEARCH TARGETING L. B.
Q. WOMEN'S HEALTH NEEDS AN
INVENTORY OF EXISTING PROGRAMS
SO THE GOVERNOR DIDN'T HAVE A
PROPOSAL IN THE ASSEMBLY DIDN'T
TAKE AN ACTION.
THANK YOU FINANCE WE SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY ON THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
HOW THE ITEM OPEN MOVING ON TO
ISSUE?
THIRTY SIX CALIFORNIA
IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY ALEJO.
ON THIS ISSUE THE SENATE
APPROVED TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
GENERAL FUND ON GOING TO PROVIDE
FULL FUNDING FOR THE CALIFORNIA
IMMINENT IMMUNIZATION REGISTRY
WHICH IS ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC.
HEALTH -- IT'S CURRENTLY -- UP
AND RUNNING BUT THIS WOULD
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ONGOING
FUNDING -- THE GOVERNOR HAD NO
PROPOSAL IN THE ASSEMBLY TOOK NO
ACTION.
THANK YOU FINANCE WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS SHOULD BE ASSESSED
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGIES PROJECT APPLICATION
LIFECYCLE PROCESS AND WE ALSO
BELIEVE IT'S POSSIBLE THAT WE
CAN LEVERAGE ADDITIONAL FAT
FEDERAL FUNDING.
RATHER THAN ONGOING COST
PRESSURES FOR THE STATE.
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
CNN WILL HOLD THE ITEM OF ISSUE
THIRTY SEVEN INTEGRITY OF HEALTH
CARE FACILITY INSPECTIONS LA OUT --
ISSUE THIRTY SEVEN IS THE
LANGUAGE ISSUE THE SENATE
ADOPTED PLACE HOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO ALLOW EMPLOYEES
OF HEALTH CARE INTO DETAIL
FACILITY ENTITIES THAT ARE
INSPECTED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. TO HAVE THE RIGHT.
TO DISCUSS -- DISCUSS ISSUES
WITH THE INSPECTORS THAT COME
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO SURVEY THE THE
FACILITY -- THE ASSEMBLY TOOK NO
ACTION IN THE GOVERNOR HAD NO
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU FINANCE MINISTRATION
SUPPORTS ASSEMBLY ON THIS AND
BELIEVES THAT POLICY PROCESS IS
THE BEST BEAGLE TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OPTIONS MEMBERS. THREE NINE HOLE
IN THE ITEM OPEN.
ITEM THIRTY EIGHT MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES REDUCTION ELLIE OUT.
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED EIGHT
MILLION -- IT TOTAL SO FIVE
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND ON
A ONE TIME BASIS FOR A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAM --
FOCUSED ON REDUCING DISPARITIES --
THROUGH.
INNOVATION PROJECTS.
OF THE REMAINING THREE MILLION
WOULD COME FROM THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FUND ON AN
ONGOING BASIS FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO COUNTIES TO REDUCE
MENTAL HEALTH DISPARITIES.
FINANCE SUPPORT SENATE ON THIS
ISSUE AND FOR THE REASONS
DISCUSSED PREVIOUSLY REGARDING
OUR PROGRAMMING PROPOSED FOR THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS THE BEST
WAY TO ALLOCATE THAT FUNDING.
THANK YOU COMMENTS MEMBERS
QUESTIONS.
HOLDING THE ITEM OPEN ISSUE
THIRTY NINE SICKLE CELL DISEASE
CENTERS OF EXCELLENCE ALEJO.
ON THIS ISSUE THE ASSEMBLY
APPROVED FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME IN ADOPTED
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO ESTABLISH CENTERS OF
EXCELLENCE TO PROVIDE CARE TO
ADULTS WITH SICKLE CELL.
DISEASE THROUGHOUT THE STATE THE
SENATE TOOK NO ACTION IN THE
GOVERNOR HAD NO PROPOSAL.
FINANCE THIS ITEM IS NOT IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SEE NONE.
OF ALL THE ITEM OPEN.
ISSUE FORTY PARKINSON'S REGISTRY
FUNDING [inaudible]
LA JOH.
ON THIS ISSUE THIS WAS ANOTHER
ASSEMBLY ONLY ACTION THE
ASSEMBLY APPROVED TEN MILLION
FROM THE GENERAL FUND ON GOING
IN ADOPTED PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE.
TO SUPPORT THE ESTABLISHMENT AND
OPERATION OF THE PARKINSON'S%
DISEASE REGISTRY THE SENATE TOOK
NO ACTION IN THE GOVERNOR HAD NO
PROPOSAL.
FINANCE HERE ALSO WE BELIEVE IT
MAY BE POSSIBLE TO LEVERAGE
FURTHER FEDERAL FUNDING AND ALSO
BELIEVE HERE THAT THIS COULD BE --
THEY SHOULD BE INCLUDED IN THE
ASSESSMENT THROUGH THE UP
PROJECT APPLICATION LIFECYCLE
PROCESS.
COMMENTS MEMBERS.
WILL HOLD THE ITEM OPEN ISSUE
FORTY ONE CARE NAVIGATORS IN
HARM REDUCTION PROGRAMS ALEJO.
ON THIS ISSUE THE ASSEMBLY
APPROVE FIFTEEN POINT TWO
MILLION GENERAL FUND ONE TIME IN
ADOPTED PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO SUPPORT YOUR
NAVIGATORS IN HARM REDUCTION
PROGRAMS. TO REACH PEOPLE WHO
USE DRUGS AND ARE NOT IN
TREATMENT AND ASSIST THEM WITH
LINKAGES TO HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
THE SENATE DID NOT TAKEN ACTION
IN THE GOVERNOR DID NOT HAVE A
PROPOSAL.
FINANCE THIS ITEM IS NOT IN OUR
BUDGET.
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. THREE
NINE HOLE THE ITEM OPEN ISSUE
FORTY TWO SYRINGE ACCESS PROGRAM
AMENDMENTS ALEJO -- ON THIS
ISSUE THE SENATE ADOPTED
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE UPDATING AND CLARIFYING
SOME OF THE REQUIREMENTS IN THE
SYRINGE ACCESS PROGRAM THE
ASSEMBLY DID NOT TAKEN ACTION IN
THE GOVERNOR DID NOT HAVE A
PROPOSAL.
FINANCE DOCTOR BUDGET
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE ITEM OPEN.
ISSUE FORTY THREE CALIFORNIA
HOME VISITING AND BLACK INFANT
HEALTH.
HELLO.
ON THIS ISSUE -- THERE THERE
THERE'S ACTUALLY NOT A HUGE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT
EVERYBODY HAS PROPOSED AN
IMPRINT SO.
THE THE GOVERNOR -- HAD PROPOSED
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND SPENDING
FOR BOTH THE HOME VISITING
PROGRAM AND FOR THE BLACK INFANT
HEALTH PROGRAM.
AND IN MAY -- AS SUBMITTED
ANOTHER PROPOSAL NOTING THAT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO DRAW OWN
FEDERAL FUNDS BASED ON THIS NEW
GENERAL FUND -- AUGMENTATION IN
THESE AREAS.
SO THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED WITH
THE GOVERNOR HAD PROPOSED AT THE
SENATE ALSO APPROVED WITH THE
GOVERNOR HAD PROPOSED BUT SIMPLY
SAID THAT SOME OF THE GENERAL
FUNDS THAT WERE OFFSET BY THE
FEDERAL DRAWDOWN.
SHOULD BE -- DIRECTED TO LOCAL
ASSISTANCE AND RATHER RATHER
THAN GOING TO STATE OPERATIONS.
FINANCE.
THE ADMINISTRATION CONCURS WITH
THE FUNDING LEVELS AS LA --
NOTED ADOPTED IN BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE BUDGETS HERE
WE BELIEVE THAT THE STATE
OPERATIONS FUNDING FOR THE
DIRECTION THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED IN ITS
MAY REVISION.
IS THE RIGHT APPROACH BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO
SUPPORT FOR OVERSIGHT AND TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
TRAINING TO LOCAL HEALTH
JURISDICTIONS IN THESE AREAS.
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS. THREE
NINE WILL HOLD THE ITEM OPEN
ISSUE FORTY FOUR CHILDHOOD LEAD
POISONING PREVENTION I. T.
PROJECT AALIYAH.
THIS ISSUE CONCERNS AN I. T.
PROJECT IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH RELATED TO
CHILDHOOD LEAD POISONING
PREVENTION AND THE ISSUE REALLY
AT HAND.
THE THE GOVERNOR AND SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY ALL APPROVED THE
POSITIONS AND FUNDING AMOUNTS
BUT THE CONFERENCE ISSUE IS THAT
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED.
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
REQUIRE NOTIFICATION TO THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE UPON COMPLETION OF
STAGES THREE AND FOUR OF THE
PROJECT APPROVAL -- LIFECYCLE
PROCESS PRIOR TO AUTHORIZATION
OF THE EXPENDITURES.
THANK YOU FINANCE PLEASE.
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THAT IN
THIS CASE THAT THIRTY DAY
WAITING PERIOD CAN TO WAY
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT AND COULD
HARM THE PROPOSED THE PROJECT SO
WE DO NOT SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
COMMENTS MEMBERS.
WILL THE ITEM OPEN ISSUE FORTY
FIVE MIDDLE HEALTH TRIAGE GRANTS
ELIA.
WHEN YOU'RE READY?
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT
REDUCED ANNUAL FUNDING -- FOR
FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION TO GIVE OUT -- MENTAL
HEALTH TRIAGE GRANTS WHICH ARE
GRANTS -- FOR COUNTIES AND AND
AND SO FORTH TO PROVIDE --
PERSONNEL AIMED AT DODD
PROVIDING SERVICES IN THE EVENT
OF A CRISIS.
THE GOVERNOR HAD NO PROPOSAL IN
THIS -- ON THIS ISSUE WHILE THE
SENATE APPROVED TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FUND
ON GOING TO RESTORE THE FUNDING
THAT WAS REDUCED IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT.
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS -- IN MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES FUND ONGOING --
TO PROVIDE INCENTIVE GRANTS TO
COUNTIES -- THESE GRANTS WOULD
BE FOR SIMILAR PURPOSES AS THE
TRIAGE GRANTS BUT THE USES WOULD
BE EXPANDED SO THAT IT WOULD NO
LONGER.
BE LIMITED ONLY TO SAY CRISIS
RESPONSE THAT PREVENTIVE
SERVICES WOULD BE ALLOWABLE AND
IT WOULD ALSO ALLOW EXPERT IN
THE ALLOWABLE USES SO IT
WOULDN'T ONLY NECESSARILY BE ON
PERSONNELBUT COULD BE ON OTHER
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS TRAINING AND
SO FORTH.
THANK YOU FINANCE THESE ITEMS
ARE NOT IN OUR BUDGET AND WE HAD
SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER THE
COMMISSION WOULD BE ABLE TO
FULLY UTILIZE THESE EXTRA FUNDS.
A QUESTION FOR MEMBERS.
THE NOVEL THE ITEM OPEN ISSUE
FORTY SIX COMMISSION
TRANSPARENCY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE STAFFING MIL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION DELEO --
SO BOTH HOUSES -- APPROVED A
PACKAGE OF AUGMENTATIONS THAT
WOULD -- PROVIDE GREATER
RESOURCES THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION -- TO
IMPROVE FISCAL TRANSPARENCY AND
OTHER DATA ANALYSIS -- TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR INNOVATION
INCUBATORS TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE -- TO SUPPORT
COUNTIES IN THEIR MENTAL HEALTH
PRIORITIES TO PROVIDE
STAKEHOLDER ADVOCACY CONTRACTS
FOR IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES.
THAN TO SUPPORT OVERSIGHT AND
MONITORING OF PREVENTION EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS THE ONLY
REAL DIFFERENCE AT CONFERENCE
HERE IS -- THE LEVEL OF FUNDING --
THE EXCUSE ME THE SENATE A
PROVIDED TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS -- FOR INNOVATION
INCUBATORS WHILE THE ASSEMBLY
PROVIDED TWO POINT SEVEN FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE
INNOVATION INCUBATORS.
FINANCE PLEASE.
AND NEITHER ARE THESE ITEMS WERE
IN THE ADMINISTRATION'S BUDGET
[inaudible]
COMMENTS NUMBERS.
SEE NONE WILL HOLD THE ITEM OPEN
ISSUE FORTY SEVEN COMMISSION
MEMBERSHIP TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
LANGUAGE HELLO -- GOVERNOR I HAD
NO PROPOSAL IN THE ASSEMBLY TOOK
NO ACTION ON THIS ITEM THE
SENATE APPROVED PLACEHOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO CORRECT
AND INNER INADVERTENT CHANGE TO
THE SENATE'S AUTHORITY TO
APPOINT.
MEMBERS TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION --
THERE WAS A REFERENCE TO THE
CHAIRPERSON OF MULTIPLE
COMMITTEES -- AND INSTEAD THE
SENATE WOULD PUT IN LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD REFER TO THE
CHAIRPERSON OF THE SENATE OR
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE -- AS
BEING -- DOMINATED FOR THIS
COMMISSION.
WE CHANGED OUR NAME TO TWENTY
YEARS AGO.
OF FINANCE.
YES RIGHT.
YEAH BUT THEY WERE TOGETHER A
HUNDRED YEARS AGO WHEN I STAFF
TO CENTER NIELSEN FINANCE
SUPPORT THE SENATE'S PROPOSALS
TO CLEAN THIS UP THANK YOU ANY
COMMENTS FROM ANYONE.
QUESTIONS -- IDENTITY IN A
MOTION TO ACCEPT THE SENATE
VERSION.
SO MOVE THANK YOU IT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED WITH A VOTE
ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE OF FIVE OH
THANK YOU IS ON THE SENATE SIDE
OF FIVE OH THAT ITEMS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH.
TOP ISSUE.
FORTY EIGHT RELOCATION TO THE
CLIFFORD L. ALLEN BE BUILDING
HELLO YEAH.
SORT OF BORED LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE -- THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED IN THE SENATE APPROVED.
EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE GENERAL FUND
DECLINING TO FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AN ON GOING. TO MOVE
THE HEADQUARTERS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES INTO THE
CLIFFORD L. ALLEN BE BUILDING AS
WELL AS TO PURCHASE EQUIPMENT
FOR THE NEW BUILDING AND
MAINTAINING THAT EQUIPMENT.
THE PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDED
BUDGETBILL LANGUAGE EXEMPTING
CONTRACTS RELATED. TO DOCUMENT
ARCHIVING SERVICES RELATED TO
THE MOVE FROM PORTIONS OF THE
GOVERNMENT CODE THE PUBLIC
CONTRACT CODE IN THE STATE
CONTRACTING MANUAL AS WELL AS
OVERSIGHT OF TGS.
UNDERSTANDING IS IS THAT THIS
WAS TO PREVENT THE NEED FOR ME
USING -- MORE EXPENSIVE TGS
DOCUMENT ARCHIVAL SERVICES.
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED THE
RESOURCES BUT MODIFIED THE
BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE TO ONLY
EXEMPTS THE DEPARTMENT FROM
NEEDING TO USE THE GS FOUR
DOCUMENT ARCHIVAL SERVICES.
WE'D RECOMMEND THE ASSEMBLY
ACTION AS IT'S UNCLEAR TO US WHY
IT'S NECESSARY TO DO THE BROADER
EXAM EXEMPTIONS JUST TO PREVENT
THE NEED FROM USING ID GS FOR
DOCUMENT ARCHIVAL SERVICES.
THANK YOU FINANCES IN
MINISTRATION APPRECIATES BOTH
THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE BUDGETS --
INCLUDING THESE FUNDING REQUESTS
AND THE ADMINISTRATION IS
COMFORTABLE WITH THE
MODIFICATIONS PROPOSED BY THE
ASSEMBLY.
EXCELLENT -- ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SEEN ON A LIMITED
MOTION TO ACCEPT THE ASSEMBLY
VERSION.
THANK YOU WITH A VOTE OF HAS
BEEN MOVED WITH A VOTE OF FIVE
ZERO FROM THE ASSEMBLY.
AND FIVE ZERO FROM THE SENATE
[inaudible]
MOTION CARRIES.
IF YOU FORTY NINE HOSPITAL
POLICE OFFICER ACADEMY ELIA.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED AND THE
SENATE APPROVED FIVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND
AND THREE PERMANENT POSITIONS
FOR DS AGE TO OPERATE THE D. S.
H. POLICE ACADEMY AT ITS CURRENT
EXPANDED CAPACITY ON AN ONGOING
BASIS.
THE ASSEMBLY UPON HER APPROVED
THE RESOURCES ON A THREE YEAR
LIMITED TERM BASIS AND APPROVED
PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE REQUIRING THE REPORT
THAT DEPARTMENT TO REPORT
ANNUALLY ON POLICE OFFICER
VACANCIES ATTRITION RATES.
AS WELL AS OFFICER RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION RATES IN THIS CASE
WE'D RECOMMEND THE ASSEMBLY
ACTION GIVEN THAT EVEN IF THERE
WAS AN INCREASE IN OFFICER
ATTRITION RATES -- IT'S POSSIBLE
THAT THE ACADEMY WOULD PRODUCE
ACCESS GRADUATES WITHIN THREE
YEARS AND THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS WOULD INCREASE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER THE
LEVEL OF RESOURCES TO PROVIDE TO
THE ACADEMY.
THANK YOU FINANCE THE
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORTS THE
SENATE PROPOSAL AND DOES BELIEVE
THAT THESE RESOURCES SHOULD BE
I'M GOING ON A TRIP.
INSULIN TO BUILT AGAIN
[inaudible]
OKAY CORRECT.
ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WILL HOLD THIS ITEM OPEN
[inaudible]
ISSUE.
WE HAD A DIFFERENT RECCO
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLY.
IF YOU'VE GOT CABLE SERVICES AND
PATIENT MINIMUM WAGE EL AL.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED IN THE
ASSEMBLY APPROVED THREE POINT
TWO MILLION FROM THE GENERAL
FUND ANNUALLY IN ONE POSITION TO
STANDARDIZE D. S. H. -- DS AGES
WAGE STRUCTURE ACROSS HOSPITAL'S
INPATIENT WORKER TYPES -- THE
SENATE APPROVED THE RESOURCES
BUT ADOPTED PLACEHOLDER TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO PROHIBIT D. S.
H. FROM TAKING FUNDS IN EXCESS
OF FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
IN PATIENT HOSPITAL BANK
ACCOUNTS AT THE END OF EACH
MONTH WE RECOMMEND THE SENATE
ACTION GIVEN THAT TAKING FUNDS
FROM PATIENT ACCOUNTS ONLY
CREATES A MINOR STATE BENEFIT.
ROUGHLY ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR.
AND COULD NEGATIVELY AFFECT THE
ABILITY OF PATIENTS TO SUPPORT
THEMSELVES UPON THE RELEASE
WHICH COULD INDIRECTLY CREATE
GREATER HA COSTS FOR THE STATE
IN THE LONG RUN.
THANK YOU FINANCE ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORTS THE ASSEMBLY ACTION.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS.
SEE NONE WILL HOLD THAT ITEM
OPEN.
ITEM FIFTY ONE PREMIUM
AFFORDABILITY SYSTEMS AND
MANDATE PENALTY [inaudible]
HELLO. FOR THIS ISSUE -- THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED PROVIDING
INDIVIDUAL MARKET HEALTH
INSURANCE PREMIUM SUBSIDIES FOR
QUALIFYING INDIVIDUALS WITH
INCOMES BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND
6100%.
OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL.
THE GOVERNOR ALSO PROPOSED
ENACTING A STATE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE WITHIN ASSOCIATED
PENALTY THAT WOULD BE BASED ON
THE FEDERAL INDIVIDUAL MANDATE.
AND TO USE THESE COUNTY REVENUES
TO FIND -- THE PREMIUM SUBSIDIES
BECAUSE THE BOUNTY REVENUES
WOULD NOT BE AVAILABLE UNTIL
AFTER THE BUDGET YEAR.
THE MAYOR VISION PROVIDED TWO
HUNDRED AND NINETY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
FOR THE SUBSIDIES IN NINETEEN
TWENTY FROM THE GENERAL FUND
WITH THAT AMOUNT GROWING
SOMEWHAT IN THE FOLLOWING TWO
YEARS AND THE SUBS SON SUBSIDIES%
THEN SUN SETTING AFTER.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO IN CONTRAST
THE COUNTY WOULD BE ON GOING.
AND WOULD BE PROJECTED TO FULLY
REIMBURSE THE GENERAL FUND FOR
THE COST OF THE SUBSIDIES OVER
THAT PERIOD.
THE SENATE AUGMENTED FUNDING FOR
THE SUBSIDIES BY THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS -- OVER THE
AMOUNT PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR
IN EACH OF THE FISCAL YEARS
201-920-2020 ONE AND TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO THE SENATE ALSO
ADOPTED SEVERAL CHANGES TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
THAT WOULD IMPLEMENT THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE.
AND THE PREMIUM SUBSIDIES
SPECIFICALLY THE SENATE LANGUAGE
WOULD ALLOW INDIVIDUALS WITH
INCOMES LESS THAN 2100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL TO ALSO
RECEIVE SUBSIDIES.
IT WOULD ELIMINATE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE SUBSIDIES
BE LIMITED TO PENALTY REVENUES.
IT SPECIFIES THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE PENALTY WOULD ONLY BE IN
EFFECT WHEN A CERTAIN MINIMUM
LEVEL OF SUBSIDIES EITHER
FEDERAL OR STATE -- ARE PROVIDED.
THAT IT EXEMPTS INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR MEDICAID
MEDICARE MEDICARE I'LL EXCUSE ME
FROM THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
PENALTY.
IT WOULD NOT REQUIRE THAT --
CERTAIN -- RECIPIENTS OF THE
SUBSIDIES RECONCILE THEIR
SUBSIDIES THROUGH THE STATE
INCOME TAX SYSTEM WHEN THE
RECONCILIATION IS SMALL.
AND IT WOULD REQUIRE -- THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD TO REPORT
CERTAIN INFORMATION ABOUT THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE REQUIRED TO
PAY THE PENALTY.
IT WOULD SUNSET A PROPOSED
EXEMPTION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT
AFTER THREE YEARS.
AND FINALLY THE SENATE ACTION
WOULD NOT EXEMPT FROM THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PENALTY
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
ENROLLED IN.
HEALTH CARE SHARING MINISTRY IS
WHICH ARE ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT ALLOW MEMBERS TO SHARE SOME
OF EACH OTHER'S MEDICAL COSTS
BUT ARE NOT REGULATED BY THE
STATE.
AS INSURANCE.
THE ASSEMBLY APPROVED THE LOWER
AMOUNT OF FUNDING FOR SUBSIDIES
THAT WAS PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY BUT REJECTED THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE I'M IN FAVOR
OF CONSIDERING SUCH CHANGES
THROUGH THE POLICY BILL PROCESS.
I'M BRIEFLY SIMILAR COMMENTS ON
THIS WE'VE PREVIOUSLY NOTED THAT --
THE STATE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
MERIT SERIOUS CONSIDERATION.
AS A COST EFFECTIVE APPROACH TO
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF UNINSURED
RESIDENTS IN THE STATE.
AND WETHINK IT MAKES SENSE TO
CONSIDER A STATE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE PENALTY WITH --
SUBSIDIES AT THE SAME TIME. TO
OFFSET SOME OF THE NEGATIVE
IMPACTS OF THE OF THE MANDATE
PENALTY.
HOWEVER WE HAVE FOUND THAT
LIMITING FUNDING FOR THE
INSURANCE SUBSIDIES TO THE PARA
COUNTY REVENUES COULD BE
PROBLEMATIC -- SINCE THE GOAL OF
THE INDIVIDUAL MANDATE AS A
DETERRENT AGAINST FOR GOING.
ON INSURANCE COVERAGE IS AT ODDS
WITH THE GOAL OF RAISING
REVENUES FOR THE SUBSIDIES.
AND FINALLY WE FIND THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO SUNSET
THE SUBSIDIES CREATES BUDGETARY
PRESSURES TO CONTINUE THE
SUBSIDIES -- IN LATER YEARS.
THE ASSEMBLY IS APPROACH OF
DEFERRING ENACTMENT OF LANGUAGE
TO THE POLICY PROCESS WOULD
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL TIME. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THESE
ISSUES.
HOWEVER THERE ARE REASONS TO
PURSUE MORE IMMEDIATE ACTION ON
THESE POLICIES PARTICULARLY IF A
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
IMPLEMENTATION DATE FOR THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE AND THE
SUBSIDIES.
AS PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR IS
DESIRED.
AND THE REASON IS THAT THESE
POLICIES ARE EXPECTED TO AFFECT
THE REST MIX IN THE INDIVIDUAL
MARKET WHICH FEEDS INTO THE
RATES THAT -- INSURERS THE
PARTICIPATE IN THE MARKET WILL
SET AND THOSE RATES -- TYPICALLY
WOULD NEED TO BE SET BY JULY --
TWENTY NINETEEN AS A RESULT THE
LÏNG ACKMAN OF LANGUAGE TO
IMPLEMENT THE MANDATE OR THE
SUBSIDIES -- COULD MAKE IT
CHALLENGING TO GET THOSE RATES
SET AND GET ALL OF THESE
POLICIES IMPLEMENTED BY.
TWENTY TWENTY THANK YOU FOR THAT
LA L..
NOT ELIO FERNANDO.
PEOPLE MAKE THREE BRIEF POINTS
FIRST -- FOR SEVERAL THE REASONS
THAT THE LA -- JUST MENTIONED
THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES VERY
STRONGLY THAT THIS SHOULD TAKE
PLACE TO BE CONSIDERED IN TERMS
OF THE IN AN INDIVIDUAL MANDATE
AND SUBSIDIES.
PART OF THE BUDGET PROCESS
BECAUSE AS LA -- GENOCIDE IF WE
WANT TO START THIS PROGRAM BY
JULY BY JANUARY FIRST OF NEXT
YEAR COVER CALIFORNIA REALLY
NEED CERTAINTY BY NEXT MONTH
JULY OF TWENTY NINETEEN THE
MATCH UP AS BEST AS WE COULD
ESTIMATE.
THE MONEY RAISED BY THE MANDATE
PENALTY -- WITH THE SUBSIDIES
THAT WE ARE SPENDING AND SO WE
BELIEVE THAT CHANGES BEYOND THAT
PROCESS WHETHER IT'S DIRECT
ADDITIONAL FUNDS OR WHETHER IT'S
CHANGES TO ELIGIBILITY OR
EXEMPTIONS BEYOND WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED.
COULD RESULT IN COST PRESSURES
ON THE GENERAL FUND THAT WE
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY BE ABLE TO
ABSORB OR WOULD HAVE TO TRADE
OFF AGAINST OTHER PROGRAMS WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THAT OFFSET
PRINCIPLE.
IS IMPORTANT HERE AND THEN THE
FINAL POINT THAT I WANT TO MAKE
IS THIS IS A NEW PROGRAM AND WE
ARE THE FIRST STATE IN THE
NATION IN TERMS OF THIS LEVEL OF
SUBSIDIES THAT WE'RE PROPOSING.
AND SO WE BELIEVE THAT AN ANNUAL
REVIEW OF HOW THIS PROGRAM IS
STRUCTURED IN DESIGNED IS
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET THIS RIGHT BOTH IN THE FIRST
YEAR BUT ALSO IN THE SECOND AND
THIRD YEARS OF THIS PROGRAM.
I WOULD CERTAINLY IS A SUPPORT
THE COUNCIL OF ANNUAL REVIEW I
AGREE.
BY ANY CONTENT OF COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS ON THIS ITEM
[inaudible]
TAMARA.
SO.
I GUESS WE COULD HAVE A
DISCUSSION ON WHETHER THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT IS WORKING
OR WHETHER PREMIUMS ARE.
DECLINING ARE LEVELING OUT ARE
RISING THEY SEEM TO BE RISING
INTO.
WE TALKED ABOUT WHETHER THIS IS
A TAX INCREASE -- I'M CONCERNED
ABOUT SOME PROPOSALS TO TRY TO
ELIMINATE CERTAIN EXEMPTIONS.
ANI I WILL GO THERE BUT I JUST
SAY THAT THIS IS A BIG A BIG
DEAL.
AND AND SO YOU'RE YOU'RE TAKING
ON SOME INTERESTING ISSUES AND I
WOULD THINK THAT A LITTLE MORE
TIME -- MORE DISCUSSION IS
WARRANTED THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WELL HOLD ON A MOTION MOVED TO
ISSUE.
FIFTY TWO SENIOR NUTRITION
PROGRAMS [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THE HOUR.
IS.
FOR THE FOLKS MARK [inaudible]
RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT LA ELLIS BEGINS
NUTRITION PROGRAMS TO MOVE NOW
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
JACQUI RESCUE WTH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE I'M
AS NOTED IN YOUR GENDER THE
GOVERNOR BUDGET INCLUDES AN
INCREASE IN FEDERAL FUNDS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF AGING SOME OF
WHICH IS FOR THE SENIOR
NUTRITION PROGRAM BOTH HOUSES
ALSO IN.
IN -- PROVIDED AN INCREASE IN
GENERAL FUND LEVELS FOR THE
SENIOR NUTRITION PROGRAM BUT
DIFFERENT AMOUNTS THE SENATE
PROVIDED SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE
MILLION ONGOING -- WHILE THE
ASSEMBLY PROVIDED TWENTY MILLION
ONE TIME THAT COULD BE SPENT
ACROSS MULTIPLE YEARS IN
ADDITION THE ASSEMBLY REQUESTED
PERIODIC UPDATES STARTING
JANUARY TEN TWENTY TWENTY SO THE
ISSUE BEFORE YOU IS.
WHETHER TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND -- WHETHER THAT
GENERAL FUND SHOULD BE ONGOING --
ONE TIME AND THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OF FINANCE THE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT ITS MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL.
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
HOLD THE ITEM OPEN.
A VARIETY OF ADJUSTMENTS ISSUE
[inaudible]
FIFTY THREE ELIA.
ARE THE SENATE APPROVED TO
AUGMENTATIONS ONE WOULD PROVIDE
FIVE MILLION ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR PAUL PAUL PREVENTION PROGRAM.
AND THAT WOULD BE ADMINISTERED
BY THE LOCAL AREAS -- OF AGING.
THE OTHER WOULD PROVIDE FIVE
MILLION ON GOING TO EXPAND THE
USE OF THE NO WRONG DOOR MODEL
WITHIN THE AGING AND DISABILITY
RESOURCE CENTERS.
THE GOVERNOR SIMPLY HAD NO
PROPOSES RELATED TO THESE
PROGRAMS THUS THE ISSUE BEFORE
IS WHETHER TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO THESE PROGRAMS.
FINANCE NO PROPOSALS IN THIS
AREA THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON
ISSUE.
FIFTY THREE HOLDEN THE ITEM OPEN
ISSUE FIFTY FOUR FUNDING FOR
ADMIN SUPPORT.
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE.
HISTORICALLY THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE HAS SOLELY
RELIED ON REVENUES FROM ITS TAX
CHECKOFF FUND HOWEVER REESE IN
RECENT YEARS -- THE REVENUES
FROM THE TAX CHECKOFF FUND HAVE
NOT BEEN ENOUGH TO COVER
OPERATIONAL COSTS -- OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE WITH TEMPORARY
GENERAL FUND ASSISTANCE HOWEVER --
IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
THE GOVERNOR DID NOT PROPOSE ANY
GENERAL FUND ASSISTANCE THE
ASSEMBLY DID PROVIDE THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND I'M GOING
GENERAL FUND TO COVER CSL
OPERATING COST.
THE SENATE HAS NO PROPOSAL THUS
THE ISSUE BEFORE USE WHETHER TO
PROVIDE THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE WITH ONGOING FUNDING.
FINANCE.
IN MINISTRATION VOICE TO SENIOR
LEGISLATURE DOES HAVE SUFFICIENT
RESERVES TO COVER BUDGET
EXPENSES FOR THE BUDGET YEAR.
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
I VIçT.
YES I WOULD NOTE THAT -- THAT IS
AN ACCUMULATION OF TAX REVENUES
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS THUS
WHILE THIS CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE MAY HAVE ENOUGH
FUNDING IN NINETEEN TWENTY THERE
IS STILL A QUESTION.
OF WHETHER THEY WOULD HAVE
ENOUGH FUNDING FOR FUTURE YEARS
THROUGH THE TAX CHECKOFF FUND --
ENOUGH [inaudible]
HI.
THE MORE LOT MEASURE THAT DOES
THE SENIOR.
LEGISLATURE DO ANY OTHER FUND
RAISING BESIDES THE CHECK OFF
BOX.
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY
DO TRY TO GET VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTIONS ON BESIDES THE TAX
CHECK OFF FUND AND THAT'S PART
OF THEIR INITIATIVE AS WELL TO
SEE IF BUT THEY COULD INCREASE
THOSE EFFORTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY MORE QUESTIONS.
WILL PULL THE ITEM OPEN
[inaudible]
MOVING.
TO DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES DEPARTMENT OF REHAB.
ISSUE.
FIFTY FIVE STABILIZING SERVICES
FOR CONSUMERS.
LA JOH NA PARTICULARLY --
ACTUALLY OF A HAND OUT RELATED
TO THIS ISSUE THAT YOU SHOULD
YOU SO.
MANAGERS PRESENT FROM FROM THE
HAND OUT -- SO I'LL START BY
NOTING THAT AS YOU PROBABLY ALL
KNOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES HAS --
WHAT COULD BE DESCRIBED AS AN
OUTDATED?
COMPLEX AND NON TRANSPARENT RATE
SETTING PROCESS CURRENTLY --
IT'S A IT'S SOME OF THE TARGETED
BUDGET SOLUTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
ENACTED IN RECENT YEARS HAVE
FURTHER COMPLICATED THE WAY THAT
RATES ARE SET [inaudible]
AND IMPROVE.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THE
ESTABLISHED METHODS FOR SETTING
RATES SOME OF THESE BUDGET
SOLUTIONS HAVE LED TO A
SITUATION WHERE THOSE
ESTABLISHED METHODS ARE JUST ON
PAPER THOSE ARE REALLY THE
METHODS THAT WE USE ANY LONGER
TO SET THE RATES?
AND THERE ARE ALSO SOME
SIGNIFICANT -- AND SOMEWHAT
ARBITRARY INEQUITIES BETWEEN THE
RATES PAID TO PROVIDERS WHO ARE
OTHERWISE SIMILAR.
SO THIS A PROBLEM REALLY IN THE
RATE SETTING PROCESS IN THE DDS
SYSTEM RESULTED IN THE
LEGISLATURE CALLING FOR A RATE
STUDY -- THIS WAS A RESULT OF
SPECIAL SESSION LEGISLATION IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATION PROVIDED THREE
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
THE DEPARTMENT TO CONDUCT THE
STUDY.
AND THE STUDY WAS DUE ON MARCH
FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN SO -- JUST
IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR MARCH
FIFTEENTH DDS AND ITS
CONSULTANTS SUBMITTED A DRAFT
RATE STUDY REPORT INCLUDING THE
THE PROPOSED RATE SETTING MODELS
FOR EACH OF THE SERVICE
CATEGORIES.
AND BUT ONE OF THE KEY FINDINGS
FROM THIS STUDY IS IT SUGGESTED
THAT THE SYSTEM WAS UNDERFUNDED
BY ONE POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS ONE POINT TWO GENERAL
FUND.
A RELATIVE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
BUDGET -- SO.
THE GOVERNOR SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
EACH APPROVED PROPOSALS FOR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THAT
RESPOND IN PART TO THE RATE
STUDY BUT ALSO -- TO SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT THE SYSTEM HAS
BEEN FACING IN RECENT YEARS SO.
I'LL DISCUSS THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN WHAT HAS BEEN APPROVED
BY A PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR
AND THEN APPROVED BY THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
TWO OF THE HAND OUT.
WE HAVE A A TABLE THAT SORT OF
DOCUMENTS THESE DIFFERENCES.
SO THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED
ABOUT ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN NINETEEN TWENTY THIS
IS A HALF YOUR COST BECAUSE THE
RATE INCREASE THESE ARE.
FOR A TARGETED RATE INCREASES IN
FOUR DIFFERENT SERVICE AREAS
THIS REPRESENTS A HALF YOUR
COSTS BECAUSE THE RATE INCREASES
WOULD BEGIN JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY N. IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THIS INCLUDES A
SMALL AMOUNT -- FOR SOME OF THE
RATES THAT ARE IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION SYSTEM THAT
CONFORM. TO THE RATE LEVELS IN
THE DDS SYSTEM SPECIFICALLY FOR
SUPPORTED EMPLOYMENT.
THE GOVERNOR ALSO PROPOSED TO
SUSPEND -- A POLICY CALLED THE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY POLICY SCHEDULE
RATHER THAT -- ESSENTIALLY
PROHIBITS -- PAYMENT FOR
SERVICES ON FOURTEEN SAID DAYS
PER YEAR -- BOTH OF THESE
PROPOSALS BY THE GOVERNOR WOULD
SUNSET ON DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE SENATE --
APPROVED THE GOVERNOR'SPROPOSAL
FOR RATE INCREASES BUT REJECTED
THE SUNSET.
THE SENATE ALSO APPROVED -- AN
ADDITIONAL RATE INCREASE -- IT
SAID THAT IT WANTED TO PROVIDE
AN ACROSS THE BOARD RATE
INCREASE FOR ALL SERVICE
PROVIDERS NOT JUST THE FOR THAT
WERE INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S.
BUDGET AD ESSENTIALLY WHAT IT
WOULD DO IS IT WOULD PROVIDE 8%
ACROSS THE BOARD. TO ALL SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN THE SYSTEM AND THEN
THE ONES THAT WERE PART OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OF A PROPOSAL MAKE
END UP GETTING AN ADDITIONAL
INCREASE.
IN IN HIS IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
THIS WOULD COME AT A COST OF
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN NINETEEN TWENTY
AND AGAIN THAT WOULD BE A HALF
YOUR COSTS OF THE ANNUAL IS
COSTS WOULD BE ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION GENERAL FUND --
I'M GONNA JUST GO THROUGH THE
RATE INCREASE DIFFERENCES AND
THEN TALK ABOUT SOME OF THE
OTHER -- AS THINGS THAT WERE
PROPOSED A APPROVED BY BOTH THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY -- SO I WHEN
IT COMES TO READING CREASES THE
ASSEMBLY APPROVED TO THE AMOUNT
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAD PROPOSED
THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION -- BUT
INSTEAD OF TARGETING IT WOULD
APPLY IT ACROSS THE BOARD AND SO
THAT RESULTS IN AOUT A 526%
ACROSS THE BOARD RATE INCREASE.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER
ACTION -- THIS I'M SORRY THE
SENATE THE ASSEMBLY ALSO
REJECTED THE THE SUNSET THAT HAD
BEEN PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR.
THEY'RE ALSO IN A NUMBER OF
OTHER POLICY CHANGES -- THAT THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY TOOK ACTION
ON SO I'M I'M GOING TO JUST NAME
THEM AND IF YOU HAVE ANY FOLLOW
UP QUESTIONS ABOUT THE DETAILS I
AM HAPPY TO PROVIDE ANY LEVEL OF
DETAIL THAT YOU WOULD LIKE.
BUT THE SENATE APPROVED --
FIXING WHAT WE'RE CALLING THE
STATE MINIMUM WAGE QUIRK THAT
COMES AT A COST OF NINE MILLION
GENERAL FUND.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND WOULD BE --
REAL IT WOULD FUNDS THAT --
INCREASES STARTING WITH THE
JANUARY FIRST -- TWENTY TWENTY
STATE MINIMUM WAGE INCREASE.
BOTH HE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
VOTED TO PERMANENTLY REPEAL THE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE RATHER
THAN TEMPORARILY SUSPENDING IT.
THAT WOULD COME AT A COST OF
THIRTY POINT ONE MILLION ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS FROM THE GENERAL
FUND.
BOTH THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
VOTED TO PERMANENTLY REPEAL
WHAT'S CALLED THE HALF DAY
BILLING POLICY THIS IS HAS A
RELATIVELY MODEST COST OF ONE
POINT SIX MILLION.
FROM THE GENERAL FUND ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS.
AND THE BOTH OF THOSE THE
UNIFORM HOLIDAY SCHEDULE.
PARDON ME AND THEY HAVE TO A
BILLING POLICY WERE BULLS
ACTIONS THAT WERE TAKEN IN THE
RECESSION AS A BUDGET SOLUTION.
SO IN SOME WAYS THIS IS SORT OF
RESTORING SOME FUNDING TO THE
SYSTEM -- BUT THE THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY ALSO RESTORED CERTAIN
BENEFITS THAT HAD BEEN SUSPENDED
DURING THE RECESSION.
SO SPECIFICALLY THE SENATE
APPROVED RESTORATION OF SOCIAL
CAMPAñA RECREATION SERVICES AT
A COST OF TWO POINT SIX MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN NINETEEN TWENTY
THAT WOULD BE SORT OF A PARTIAL
COST AS IT RAMPS UP.
THE FULL ANNUALIZED COST WOULD
BE FOUR POINT NINE GENERAL FUND.
FOUR POINT NINE MILLION GENERAL
FUND THE ASSEMBLY ALSO APPROVED
RESTORATION OF SOCIAL RECREATION
IN CAMP -- AS WELL AS NON
MEDICAL THERAPIES AND
EDUCATIONAL SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN AGES -- THREE THREE
SEVENTEEN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
CAR TWENTY COSTS THERE IS
FOURTEEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND THAT WOULD RAMP
UP TO TWENTY SEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND.
FINALLY -- BOTH THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY APPROVED PLACE HOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT TO SUBMIT
A RATE REFORM IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN -- IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET PROPOSAL AND THE ONLY
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
PLACEHOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS THE START DATE FOR
WHEN RATE REFORM IMPLEMENTATION
WOULD NEED TOHAPPEN.
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR
THE SENATE JULY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOR THE ASSEMBLY.
SO.
I WOULD LIKE TO JUST MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS ABOUT THE VARIOUS
PROPOSALS -- THEIR NUMBER OF
POSSIBLE OPTIONS TO TAKE IN THIS
AREA A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PROPOSALS -- FOR IT FOR YOU
MEMBERS TO CONSIDER. ONE THING
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND
THE ACTIONS TAKEN BY THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE HAVE.
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE HAVE IN
COMMON IS THAT THEY EACH ATTEMPT
TO PROVIDE SOME LEVEL OF
PHYSICAL RELIEF TO SERVICE
PROVIDERS IN THE DDS SYSTEM.
THEY ALSO EACH.
WANTED TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE THE
BROADER ISSUE OF RATE REFORM --
THE DEPARTMENT SAID IN BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS THAT IT
WAS OPEN TO HAVING DISCUSSIONS
OVER THE SUMMER ABOUT HOW TO DO
THAT THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE
ACTUALLY WANT TO CODIFY THAT
REQUIREMENT SO BENT AND REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT. TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND ACTUALLY DEVELOP
A PLAN FOR REFORM IMPLEMENTATION --
IN OUR VIEW.
THE MOST IMPORTANT ELEMENTS.
IN ALL OF THIS IS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT PREPARE A RATE REFORM
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN AND SUBMIT
IT WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET PROPOSAL.
IF.
IF VIEWED IN THAT LIGHT ANY OF
THE SOLUTIONS IN NINETEEN AND IN
BUDGET YEAR NINETEEN TWENTY
COULD BE VIEWED AS SORT OF AN
INTERIM -- STEP TOWARD.
FULL RATE REFORM IMPLEMENTATION
AND THE LONGER TERM GOAL OF
ESTABLISHING A TRANSPARENT AND
LOGICAL RATE SETTING PROCESS.
SO THE TWO THINGS THAT YOU
REALLY NEED TO CONSIDER OF A FOR
FOR NINETEEN TWENTY YEAH IF YOU
WERE TO APPROVE THE THE IDEA OF
REQUIRING A RATE REFORM
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
IS WHAT THE LEVEL OF PROVIDER
FISCAL RELIEF DO YOU WANT TO
PROVIDE.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND THEN DO
YOU WANT TO USE ANY OF THE
FINDINGS FROM THE RATE STUDY IN
THE ACTIONS THAT YOU TAKE IN
NINETEEN TWENTY SO I WOULD NOTE
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL -- AS I
MENTIONED IS TARGETED TO FOR
SERVICE AREAS AND THEY BASED
THEIR SELECTION OF SERVICE
CATEGORIES ON SOME OF THE FINE
FINDINGS FROM THE RATE STUDY
WHICH INDICATED -- THAT SOME
AREAS -- WERE WERE PERHAPS MORE
UNDER FUNDED THAN OTHER AREAS
AND THEY ALSO -- TOOK SOME STEPS
TO TRY TO REDUCE SOME OF THE
INEQUITIES BETWEEN.
SERVICE PROVIDERS THAT ARE
OTHERWISE SIMILAR [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
I AM.
I WILL TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE THERESA.
THERESA CALAR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN MINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT ITS MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL OF TARGETED --
SUPPLEMENTALS SERVICE INCREASES
SERVICE RATE INCREASES AS WELL
AS COMPLIMENTARY TRAILER BILL
THAT'S THE NEXT ISSUE REGARDING
THE OVERSIGHT AND TRANSPARENCY.
FACTORS THAT THE LA ALLUDED.
TO THE SKINNER FOLLOWED BY THE
THANK YOU.
TOM THIS IS A FRUSTRATING ITEM
FOR ME BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE WE
WHEN I WAS -- BEFORE I LEFT THE
ASSEMBLY WE WERE DEALING WITH
THIS VERY SAME ISSUE O THAT WAS.
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND THEN
SUBSEQUENTLY.
I THE SERMON TO BILL AS ELLIE --
STUDY SHOWS IN -- TWENTY SIXTEEN
LA WAS REPORT SHOWS THAT ASKED
FOR A. D. D. S. TO CONDUCT THEIR
STUDY.
OF A SERVICE PROVIDER RATE
SETTING PROCESS AND WHILE THE
LANGUAGE IN THAT WASN'T EXPLICIT.
TO PREPARING A A RE REFORM
PROPOSAL IT WAS PRETTY CLOSE I
MEAN THERE'S LOTS OF WAYS YOU
COULD HAVE INTERPRETED THE
LANGUAGE BUT I WOULD HAVE
INTERPRETED IT PROBABLY THAT IT
WAS ASKING. FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO TELL US HOW TO MAKE THIS
FUNDING LEVEL SUSTAINABLE WHICH
IS PROBABLY A RATE REFORM
PROPOSALS SO HERE WE ARE.
IN NINETEEN TWENTY EN LA -- IS
RECOMMENDING BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE IT YET THAT WE PUT IN SOME
OTHER TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ASKING HIM FOR ANOTHER STUDY AND
I'M KIND OF LIKE -- YOU KNOW
MAYBE WE HAVE TO DO THAT I KNOW
IT'S DIFFERENT WHAT YOU BUT AND
IT'S MORE SPECIFIC.
BUT I'M EXPRESSING A FRUSTRATION
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE EVEN IF WE
CROSS THE TEASE IN DOT THE ICE.
WE MAY NOT STILL GET WHAT WE
NEED FROM THE DEPARTMENT AND THE
DEPARTMENT'S OWN AND WE'RE TO
AND I'M TALKING NOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES.
WE HAVE NOT GIVEN FOR THE WE'VE
ONLY GIVEN TO RATE INCREASES
OVER TWENTY YEARS.
THE DEPARTMENT ITSELF ESTIMATES
THAT THIS THE NEED IS.
THE THAT WERE BEHIND IN TERMS OF
DEFINING NEED BY OVER ONE POINT
EIGHT BILLION -- AND I I FEEL
LIKE THIS IS A POPULATION.
THIS REALLY IS LIKE OUR FOSTER
KIDS LIKE A NUMBER OF OTHERS
THIS IS A POPULATION THAT WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IN THAT WE NEED
TO ASSIST IN WERE FAILING -- I
WOULD SUPPORT THE SENATE'S
PROPOSAL.
A A I KNOW IT DOES NOT ANSWER
THE LONG TERM AND WE POTENTIALLY
SHOULD CONSIDER WHAT DE LA
ALWAYS RECOMMENDING IN TERMS OF
VERY SPECIFIC WORDING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO COME BACK WITH.
BUT I FEEL LIKE WHAT THEY'VE
COME BACK SO FAR WITH THE THINGS
WE VAST IS VERY INADEQUATE.
THANK YOU TO STORM.
I KNOW WE TALKED ABOUT THIS WHEN
WE FOR STARTED THE OVERALL --
PROCEEDINGS REGARDING CONFERENCE
AND JUST TO JUST KIND OF WANTED
TO REITERATE -- FOR US WE ARE
VERY CONCERNED WITH THE SUNSET
PROVISIONS THE MINISTRATION.
HANDED THEM WE THOUGHT THAT --
ANA HE'S WERE NOT WHAT I'M
EXPENDITURES.
THAT THE THE RATE INCREASES
WOULD BE USED TO CALL HIGHER
INDIVIDUALS.
THAT THESE WOULD BE JOBS THAT
WOULD -- NEED TO BE -- PLACE
WITH INDIVIDUALS AND THAT JUST.
TAKING THE MONEY AWAY IN TWO
YEARS JUST MEANT THOSE
INDIVIDUAL GET LAID OFF I DON'T
KNOW IF.
LA -- COULD SORT OF JUST COMMENT
ON THAT -- OF THE THIRD SET AND
THEN GO BACK TO THE
ADMINISTRATION.
YES -- WE WERE VERY CONCERNED TO
SEE THE SUNSET PROPOSALS AS WELL
BECAUSE THESE AE REALLY ONGOING
SERVICES AND ONE OF THE THE
RATIONALES -- FOR TARGETING FOR
EXAMPLE.
I'LL JUST GIVE AN EXAMPLE ONE OF
THE REASONS THE ADMINISTRATION
GAVE FOR TARGETING RATE
INCREASES TO RESIDENTIAL CARE
PROVIDERS WAS THE NEED TO
STABILIZE THE SYSTEM.
OBVIOUSLY SEND SETTING THOSE
RATE INCREASES K. COULD HAVE THE
EFFECT OF DESTABILIZING THE
SYSTEM.
I THINK THE MAIN THING FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION IS -- WE
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR BROADER
REFORM AND SO WE ARE IN THE NEXT
TWO YEARS UP BETWEEN NOW NEXT
TWO AND A HALF YEARS AND ARE
PROPOSED SUNSET WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CONTINUE FORWARD ON
THAT PATH.
I MAKES.
SENSE BUT I THINK IT'S AGAIN I
DO IT DOCTOR'S RESPONSE TO MY
EARLIER POINT WHICH IS.
THAT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO HIRE
PEOPLE IF THEY THINK THE ONLY
HAVE A JOB. FOR FOR TWO YEARS
AND VERY TIGHT LABOR MARKETS
PUSH WHEN PEOPLE.
ARE GETTING PAID THAT MUCH TO
WORK AT THESE.
FACILITIES THAT IT IS MAKES IT
EVEN MORE DIFFICULT AND COULD
KICK IN.
I'M NOT HAVE THE EFFECT OF
STABILIZATION THAT WE WOULD ALL
LIKE TO SEE.
ON I THINK THE OTHER QUESTION
WAS IS -- THERE ARE OTHER
DIFFERENT NEW PROPOSALS THAT ARE
IN THE BUDGET WHY NOT SUNSET A
NEW PROPOSAL RATHER THAN.
SOMETHING THAT IS A A RATE
INCREASE OF A LONG STANDING
PROGRAM THAT WE'VE MADE.
HAD A LONG COMMITMENT.
TO I THINK THERE BECAUSE THIS
RATE STUDY JUST CAME OUT IN
MARCH SO JUST ABOUT TWO MONTHS
AGO AND WE UNDERSTAND THAT IT'LL
BE IMPLEMENTED OVER TIME.%
WE THOUGHT THIS WAS ONE OF THE
AREAS WHERE IT IS MOST RIGHT FOR
THAT KIND OF RETHINKING AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
THINGS THE RIGHT WAY AND WE ARE
COMMITTED WE KNOW IT'S ALWAYS
HARDER THAN IT SOUNDS BUT TO
BENDING THE COST CURVE IN TRYING
TO GET MORE.
WHILE SPENDING LESS.
I KNOW IT'S LATE IN -- BUT I
JUST FEEL LIKE I WANT TO JUMP ON
A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE THIS IS A
NOT A BI PARTISAN BUT NINE NON
PARTISAN ISSUE THINK ABOUT THE
LETTERMAN ACT -- BUT IT'S
EXCEPTIONALLY FRUSTRATING WE
HAVE MORE REVENUE OF THAT'S COME
INTO THE STATE BUDGET THIS YEAR
THAN ANY -- THAT THEN IN HISTORY.
AND YET THIS COMMUNITY.
THE DD COMMUNITY SEEMS TO EVERY
SINGLE YEAR.
THE WOEFULLY UNDERFUNDED WE GOT
WE DO A STUDY WE FIND OUT YEAH
THEY NEED MORE MONEY.
AND THEN WE SAY ALL. TO DO MORE
STUDIES WE ARE WITH A LITTLE BIT
A LITTLE BIT LONGER.
AND I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND WHEN
WERE -- WHEN WERE PRIORITIZING?
OUR RESOURCES WHY IN THE WORLD
THIS COMMUNITY YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR GETS THE SHORT END OF
THE STICK.
I I I DON'T I DON'T GET IT
BECAUSE WHEN I LISTEN TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHEN WE'RE WE'RE
DEBATING THIS ON THE FLOOR AND
COMMITTEE WE ALL SAY THAT WERE
FOR THIS COMMUNITY.
BUT I CAN TELL YOU THE PROVIDERS
OF THEIR IN MY IN MY DISTRICT --
ARE ARE ARE ABOUT THE ABOUT DONE
THERE ONLY CONTINUING ON BECAUSE
THEY CARE SO DEEPLY ABOUT THESE
THESE INDIVIDUALS THEY'RE NOT
GETTING PAID.
ENOUGH THEY'RE DOING IT I'M OUT
OF THE KINDNESS OF THEIR HEART
BUT THEY'VE HAD ENOUGH WHEN DO
WE IS THE STATE SAY OKAY IT'S
OUR RESPONSIBILITY WE'VE GOT TO
BE ABLE TO TO JUST THIS.
WHEN ARE WE GOING TO STEP TO
STEP UP -- I THINK IT'S A IT'S
ABOUT TIME AND AGAIN I'VE THIS
FRUSTRATION AMEND MY VOICE NEVER
THIS FROM OTHERS THIS IS NOT A
PARTISAN ISSUE ALL OF US SAYING
I JUST DON'T UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THE HANG UP IS MAYBE YOU
CAN SHED SOME LIGHT ON IT?
SO THE ADMINISTRATION WE
COMPLETELY AGREE THAT THIS IS
NOT AND SHOULD NOT BE A PARTISAN
ISSUE AND I THINK I WOULD MAKE A
TWO POINTS AND WE UNDERSTAND
THAT SENATOR SKINNER SAID AS
WELL THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT WE'VE.
ALL BEEN LOOKING AT FOR QUITE
SOME TIME AND SO I THINK THE
FIRST POINT IS THAT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS CERTAINLY NOT
ENOUGH TO SOLVE THIS ISSUE BUT
IT'S ALSO NOT INSIGNIFICANT EVEN
IN THE CONTEXT OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUDGET WE THINK THIS WILL MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
WE UNDERSTAND THERE'S SOME
DIFFERENCES IN TERMS OF HOW TO
SPEND THAT MONEY BUT THE
TARGETED APPROACH THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED WE
THINK IT'LL MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
IMPROVING ACCESS FOR THIS
COMMUNITY.
AND THEN THE SECOND POINT IS --
AND THIS IS SOMETHING THE
GOVERNOR OFTEN SAYS ACROSS
ISSUES HE SAYS IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT RESOURCES BUT
RESOURCEFULNESS AND OF COURSE
YOU ALWAYS DO NEED RESOURCES AS
WELL WHICH IS WHY WE'RE
PROPOSING MORE MONEY.
BUT THIS REFORM EFFORT AND
FIGURING OUT HOW DO WE ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THIS RATE
STUDY AND SEE HOW IN THESE FIRST
TWO TWO AND A HALF YEARS.
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE BEING
ADOPTED WHAT THE ACTUAL OUTCOMES
ARE FOR PEOPLE WHAT IS THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE'RE GETTING FROM
FAMILIES WATER I THINK THIS IS
THE NEXT ISSUE ON THE AGENDA BUT
IN TERMS OF SOME THE OVERSIGHT
FOR THESE ORIGINAL LETTERMAN --
ACCENTORS DOES ALL NEED TO BE
PART OF THE CONVERSATION SO
WE'RE GONNA BE FOCUSED ON THE
MONEY WE'RE GONNA BE OBVIOUSLY
HERE AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE CLOSELY TRACKING THE
MULTI YEAR FORECAST AND THAT'S
WHAT DROVE SOME THE SUNSETS THAT
WE WERE DISCUSSING THE VICE
CHAIR TANG.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
SPENDING THE MONEY AS
EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE.
MADAM CHAIR IF I CAN TO THE
FOLLOW UP QUESTION ARE ARE YOU
SUGGESTING THAT YOU DON'T TRUST
THEM THE PROVIDERS -- AND THAT
YOU HAVE TO GO DOING GOOD DIG IN
A LITTLE BIT MORE TO BE ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT WHETHER THEY'RE
SPENDING THIS MONEY -- BUT
EFFECTIVELY TO FEEL LIKE THERE'S
THERE'S ABUSE I MEAN I AGAIN I
THAT'S NOT WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
THE FOLKS IN IN IN IN MY
DISTRICT PROVIDERS THEIR THEIR
THEIR THEIR DESPERATE AT THIS AT
THIS POINT.
AND THAT'S I THINK IS WHY
THERE'S A THERE'S A LEVEL OF
FRUSTRATION AMONGST -- THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS THE CITY CALIFORNIAN
REGARDS THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
SAYING A NEFF'S ENOUGH WE'VE GOT
TO PROPERLY PROPERLY FUND THEM.
WELL AGAIN I I DON'T GET WHAT
THE HANG UP IS NO I SHOULD
CLARIFY WAS NOT SAYING THAT --
WAS FOCUSED MORE ON IN TERMS OF
YOU KNOW WE'RE ALWAYS DEALING
WITH TRADE OFFS SO IF WE'RE
GOING TO INVEST A SET AMOUNT OF
MONEY WHETHER IT'S A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS.
OR MORE A THE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE HAVE PROPOSED POWER WE
ALLOCATING THAT MONEY AND WHAT
TYPES OF OUTCOMES ARE WE GETTING
FOR IT.
CENTER FOR LAW AND ORDER.
MAYBE I COULD FOLLOW UP ON SEVEN
MAYES THIS LINE OF QUESTIONING.
WHAT TERM?
WHAT ALTERNATIVE STRATEGY DO YOU
HAVE?
ALTERNATIVE IN THE SENSE OF IF --
REGARDING OUR PROVIDE IF YOU
COULD CLARIFY A LITTLE BIT MORE.
WHAT IF THESE VENDORS DECIDE?
THEY JUST CAN'T DO ANYMORE THEY
CAN HIRE THE RIGHT PEOPLE WE
CAN'T PROVIDE THE RIGHT SERVICE
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT BEING
COMPENSATED PROPERLY.
WHAT WHAT'S YOUR PLAN B.?
IT'S ALSO VERY BRIEFLY AND THEN
TURN OVER JITTERY SO WE'RE GONNA
WE KNOW THIS IS THE FIRST PHASE
OF IMPLEMENTING THIS RIGHT
STUDIES SO WE WILL BE.
TRACKING -- THAT FEEDBACK VERY
VERY CLOSELY BOTH WITH THE
VENDORS THEMSELVES AND WITH
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY -- YOU
KNOW WE WILL GET THEIR FEEDBACK
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION AND TO
RESET IF YOU WANT TO ADD ANY
DETAIL OF GOD JUST ON THIS
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THIS
SERVICE IS BEING AN ENTITLEMENT
FEAST CONSUMERS ARE ENTITLED TO
THE SERVICES.
WE ARE SEEN -- EVEN ABSENT THE
RATE INCREASES ARE SEEN --
EXPENDITURE GROWTH IN THE SYSTEM
EVEN FASTER THAN CASELOAD THE
SERVICES ARE BEING PROVIDED THE
EXPENDITURE GROWS OUT OUT PIECES
A CASELOAD SOME OF THE THINGS
WE'RE LOOKING -- FOR AS FAR AS
THE TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT
AS MORE INFORMATION MORE
INFORMATION.
THAT THE RATE STUDY STARTED HELP
HELPING US POINT TO AS FAR AS
KIND OF WOOD HOW SERVICES ARE
BEING PROVIDED -- ARE WE WE MAY
HAVE A SERVICE CODE ARE WEAK
CONSISTENT AND STATEWIDE IN OUR
APPROACH AND HOW THAT'S APPLIED
SO THERE'S A LOT OF INFORMATION
FOR THAT -- BUT TO YOUR TO YOUR
POINT OF WHAT THE ALTERNATIVE IS
IT'S IT'S AN ENTITLEMENT SERVICE
THAT CONSUMERS WILL GET THE WILL
GET THE SERVICES AND AND TO THE
EXTENT THERE ARE ISSUES THOSE
ARE ELEVATED TO THE REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE ALSO ELEVATED TO THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND CASES WHERE -- THERE'S
ISSUES WITH ANY OF THE SERVICES
BEING PROVIDED [inaudible]
SO.
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE THERE'S
THERE ON OCCASION SEEMS TO BE AN
EMPHASIS TO TRY AND AND AND HIRE
MORE STATE EMPLOYEES.
IS IS THAT WHERE THIS IS GOING
ARE BECAUSE THAT'S EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE IF YOU WANT TO START.
PAYING STATE WAGES AND PENSIONS
AND RETIREE MEDICAL AND SO I I'M
I'M I'M IT ME AM I JUST.
MAYBE CHECK IN A LITTLE
SKEPTICAL ALERT REFERRING BACK
TO WHEN WE WERE ATTACKED Là
CALLED THE CLOSING THE CLOSURE
OF THE DEVELOPMENT CENTERS IN
THAT TRANSITION.
FROM ONE OF THOSE STATE
EMPLOYEES REFERRING -- TO A BILL
THAT -- THE CINNAMON.
SO YOU'RE JONES DID A COUPLE
YEARS AGO HE WAS S. A. B..
ELEVEN FIFTY WANTED TO MAKE
EVERYBODY KNOW NONPROFITS AT ALL.
IN IN A JUST HAVE EVERYONE BE A
STATE EMPLOYEE AND I I'M I'M I'M
JUST WANNA USE THAT PLAN B.
BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY REALLY
EXPENSIVE.
IF YOU'RE TRYING TO KEEP YOUR
COSTS DOWN.
SO I'M JUST I'M JUST TRYING.
TO AND THAT THE FUNDING PROPOSED
HERE IS GOING OUT TO THE
COMMUNITY SERVICES SYSTEM SO
THAT HUNDRED MILLION IT GOES TO
TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IS. TO THE PROVIDERS WHICH
ARE ECONOMIC MIGHT BE NONPROFIT
OR PRIVATE BUSINESSES THEY ARE
NOT STATE ENTITIES [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU THAT'S WEBER.
YES I I HOPE YOU -- PROBABLY
HEAR THE DEEP DEEP CONCERN AND
EVERYONE'S VOICE CONCERNING THIS.
AND YOU KNOW I WAS CHAIR BUT
GETS HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
WHEN YOU AND CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET.
MY COLLEAGUE HERE FROM THE BAY
AREA -- AND THAT WE WERE COMING
OUT OF A RECESSION AND THEY HAD
TAKEN A LOT OF HITS IN THAT
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS EVERYONE
ELSE SAID.
AND AND THEN WE HAD BEGUN TO DO
THINGS LIKE.
INCREASE MINIMUM WAGE ALL THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS AND SO THOSE
COMMUNITIES WERE HEAVILY
IMPACTED BY THAT THEY'VE HAD TO
CONTINUE TO CUT SERVICES THEY'VE
GOT SOME.
STIPULATIONS ON WHAT HAVING
OTHER NOW I COULD GO TO THIS
BUDGET AND FIND THE MONEY THAT I
NEED ON THINGS THAT I DON'T
REALLY CARE THAT MUCH ABOUT.
OF TO BE VERY HONEST ABOUT IT
AND THIS COMMUNITY HAS BEEN
WAITING AND WAITING AND WAITING.
AND IT'S NOT LIKE WE NEED TO
REASSESS WHETHER NOT THEY'RE
PROBABLY USING THE MONEY THAT IT
UP THESE FOLKS NEED RACES THEY
NEED TO EXPANSION OF STAFF --
THAT'S REAL CLEAR IN TERMS OF
YOU EVER GO VISIT THEM AND SEE
WHAT THEY DO WITH THESE VARIOUS
CENTERS AND THE WORK THAT'S DONE.
AND THEY COME HERE EVERY YEAR
ASKING US TO BE SENSITIVE. TO
WHAT WE HAVE REALLY LAID ON THEM
BYE BYE BASICALLY INCREASING
MINIMUM WAGE AND A HOST OF OTHER
THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE.
BOB THEY CONTINUE TO SERVE
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE SO STRONGLY
IN THE PEOPLE THAT THEY WORK
WITH -- AND IT JUST SEEMS
UNCONSCIONABLE TO METHAT WE
WOULD.
NOT PRIORITIZE IS MUCH HIGHER.
IN OUR OWN THINKING BECAUSE
THAT'S REALLY WHAT IT IS IT'S A
MATTER PRIORITIES -- IN YOU KNOW
WE WE CAN THROW AROUND THREE
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION HERE THREE
FOUR HUNDRED MILLION THERE WE
CAN DO A BILLION WITH SOMETHING
ELSE WE CAN FIND ALL THESE
THINGS AND THEN WE GET TO THE
DDS COMMUNITY.
OF IT'S A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
STORY.
AND THESE PEOPLE ARE PATIENT
THEY COME THEY WAIT THEY MEET
WITH US EVERY YEAR THEY SAY THE
SAME THING.
AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT THEY ARE
IN MEET.
AND SO THEN WE END UP WITH
SOMETHING THAT TALK ABOUT WELL
IF YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO YOU FOR YOUR TO DO THIS AND
SUNSET.
DATA REASSESS WHETHER NOT USE
THE MONEY APPROPRIATELY BLAH
BLAH BLAH.
YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S A STE IT
APPEARS TO BE A STALLING TACTIC
AND THE IN THAT AND IT'S REALLY
DEALING WITH THE THE THE THOSE
WHO HAVE THE LEAST AMOUNT OF
INFLUENCE.
GET THE GREATEST AMOUNT OF TASKS
THAT THEY DO WHICH IS TAKEN CARE
PEOPLE THAT WE ARE
RESPONSIBILITY.
FOR SO I FIND IT UNCONSCIONABLE
THAT WE WOULD EVEN BE HAVING
THIS CONVERSATION WE HAVE MONEY
TO DO WHAT WE KNOW IS RIGHT.
CAN I ASSUME THAT WE WOULD DO
THAT.
HANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ARE MOST BIGELOW [inaudible]
ARE YOU.
VERY MUCH JUST A QUESTION I MEAN
ARE WERE GOING AROUND THIS ROOM
WORLD BATTING.
AROUND AT SOME POINT.
WE HAVE TO TAKE ON THE ISSUE.
WHY NOT TAKE IT ON RIGHT NOW?
WHY NOT GIVE DIRECTION AND
DIRECTION GOES TO STOP?
WHY DON'T WE CHOOSE ONE OF THESE
OPTIONS?
AND MOVE IT FOR TODAY.
I MEAN IF THE CHAIR WAS
INTERESTED IN A MOTION WE GIVE
THAT DIRECTION.
IF THE CHAIR WAS INTERESTED.
I WILL BE INTERESTED IN THE
MOTION -- EITHER ON THURSDAY AND
FRIDAY NOW AND I LOOK TO GET IT
FROM YOU MISTER BIGELOW I WOULD
BE HAPPY TO OFFER THAT MAKE YOU.
THANK YOU.
BUT HOLD OUT LONGER IF YOU DON'T
MIND BUT IF I'M NOT THE
ALTERNATIVE.
MAY NOT GET IT FROM ALL COME GET
YOU I'LL COME GET YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY.
BUT BETWEEN NOW AND THEN YOU
KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
PLEASE GOING TO TALK TO SOMEBODY
THAT WILL THERE BE WILL SHY AWAY
FROM THIS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
DISCUSS.
I DON'T I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
CASE WITH THE BIG A LOT IF JOHN
I THINK I BUSINESS SKINNER COULD
COME UP WITH AN AXE ABSOLUTELY
OF THAT I GET I THINK A GOOD
NUMBER OF YOUR COLLEAGUES WHO
ALREADY SPOKEN EITHER I WILL I
WILL SAY IF THERE ARE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
HAVING SHARED SUB THREE A NUMBER
OF YEARS -- FULL BUDGET THIS IS.
AN ISSUE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS -- ANA OPINED ON OF FOUGHT
OVER ATTEMPTED TO FUND -- WE'VE
STEPPED TO THE PLATE AND ANY
NUMBER OF OCCASIONS WITH THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION AND NOW
WITH THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION --
AS WE'VE TRANSITIONED CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS FROM -- THE THE
<c.cyan>ACILITIES INTO THE COMMUNITY.</c>
YOU KNOW WE'VE HEARD FROM AMILY --
WE WE'VE HEARD FROM ALL ANGLES --
OF THESE ISSUES AND WE HEARD
FROM COMMUNITY PROVIDERS FOR
MANY YEARS WHO QUESTION WHY WE
CONTINUE TO POUR HUGE AMOUNTS OF
MONEY INTO THE CENTERS WHILE WE
HAD A PLAN.
THE CALLS -- AND WE WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE CLOSED
WHALE AND THOUGHTFUL -- WHAT
WITH TRANSITION PLANSIN PLACE
SO THIS IS NOT A NEW ISSUE?
FOR EVERYONE ON THIS DIET AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE THOUGHTFUL
AND DELIBERATE IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING -- A SAFETY NET FOR
THIS VERY FRAGILE -- COMMUNITY
WITHIN OUR BROADER COMMUNITY.
I THINK THAT'S REFLECTED IN.
THE DOLLAR AMOUNTS -- ON AS
EVIDENT THAT DIDN'T PUT FORWARD
BY.
THE TWO HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO CONTINUE TO TO DIALOGUE
ABOUT WHAT WE THINK IS BEST
EITHER IN THE SHORT TERM OR THE
LONGER TERM.
AW AS WE HAVE THE CONVERSATION
EARLY ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THIS IS A
COMPLICATED COMPLEX.
HUGE STATE AGENCY THAT'S GONE
THROUGH A NUMBER OF TRANSITIONS
JUST SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND SO IT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU'VE GOT A
NUMBER OF MEMBERS HERE WHO HAVE
ENOUGH -- TEN YEAR UNDER OUR
BELT TO HAVE FOLLOWED THIS ISSUE
AND I HOPE THAT THAT YOU ARE AND
THEN NEW MEMBERS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION HERE US LOUD AND
CLEAR UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S AN
ISSUE THAT WE WILL CONTINUE. TO
FOLLOW -- WITH GREAT INTEREST
AND ENERGY AS TO WHAT THAT WILL
LEAVE THE ADAM OPEN FOR NOW AND
LOOK FORWARD -- TO ALL CLOSURE
THAT SUITS ALL OF OUR
EXPECTATIONS [inaudible]
FAIR ENOUGH.
THANK YOU SIR TO THE OFFICE.
ISSUE FIFTY SIX REGIONAL CENTER
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT TBL.
ON THIS ISSUE THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
MEASURES TO ENHANCE REGIONAL
CENTER AND PROVIDER OVERSIGHT.
AND WOULD FACILITATE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISION PROPOSAL ON RATES --
THE IS SET THE EXCUSE ME THE
SENATE ADOPTED PLACE HOLDER
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ISSUES.
THE ASSEMBLY TOOK NO ACTION IN
ORDER TO HAVE THIS DISCUSSION AT
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE.
SO THE ISSUE IS WHETHER TO
APPROVE THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IN WHOLE OR IN PART.
AND ONE IMPORTANT THING THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE ABOUT IT IS --
A LARGE SECTION OF THE TRAILER
BILL HAS TO DO WITH THE RATE
INCREASES PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
YOU CHANGE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL -- SURE YOU WOULD ALSO
HAVE TO EITHER CHANGE THE
TRAILER BILL OR OR DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
I THINK I THINK BASED ON THAT
REALITY [inaudible]
I YEAH.
ON THIS ISSUE -- THE GOVERNOR
HAD HAS PROPOSED SEVEN POINT
THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND TO
ENHANCE THE SYSTEM OF CRISIS AND
SAFETY NET SUPPORTS.
THE SENATE APPROVED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FUNDING THE
ASSEMBLY ALSO APPROVE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FUNDING AND
IN ADDITION APPROVED FIVE
MILLION GENERAL TIME JUST SORRY
GENERAL FUND ONE TIME. FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTS FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WHO ALSO HAVE A
SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH DIAGNOSES.
DIAGNOSIS.
FINANCE WE SUPPORT THE SENATE ON
THIS PROPOSAL THANK YOU.
IN THE COMMENTS.
MOVING ON TO DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES [inaudible]
THIS WAS [inaudible]
IT'S THIS.
OF HEALTH CARE CENTERS LA YOU
KNOW.
UNDER CURRENT LAW LICENSE CHILD
CARE FACILITIES ARE INSPECTED
EVERY THREE YEARS HOWEVER IN
RESPONSE TO FEDERAL CHOIR MEANT
THE STATE IS NOW REQUIRED TO
INSPECT LICENSE CHILD CARE
FACILITIES EVERY YEAR.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED TO
INCREASE POSITION AUTHORITY TO
MEET THIS FEDERAL REQUIREMENT
AND THEM BOTH HOUSES APPROVED TO
INCREASE THE POSITION OF
AUTHORITY.
THE ASSEMBLY HOWEVER ALSO PROVE
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD CHANGE STATE
LAW SO THAT IT REFLECTS THE
FEDERAL REQUIREMENT WHICH WOULD
TAKE EFFECT JULY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THANK YOU --
COMMENT FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
FINANCE FOR THE SENATE ON THIS
PROPOSAL.
IN THE COMMENTS.
THE WHOLE THAT ITEM OPEN.
ISSUE FIFTY NINE BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM.
JANIE BELL AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE THE BRINGING
FAMILIES HOME PROGRAM WAS FIRST
AUTHORIZED INTO AS PART OF THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN BUDGET.
IT IS A HOUSING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR CHILD WELFARE
FAMILIES TO HELP PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS AND ALSO -- FOSTER
CARE PLACEMENTS.
THE FUNDING FOR THAT PROGRAM IS
SET TO EXPIRE IN JUNE OF TWENTY
NINETEEN SO THIS MONTH.
THE GOVERNOR PROPOSED SOME
REAPPROPRIATION AUTHORITY
ALLOWING ON SPENT FUNDING TO BE
ROLLED OVER INTO THE BUDGET YEAR.
BOTH THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY
APPROVED THAT.
THE ASSEMBLY -- AND THEY BOTH
ACTUALLY PER -- PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM TO ALLOW IT TO COULD
CONTINUE FOR LONGER THE
DIFFERENCE REALLY IS JUST THE
LEVEL OF FUNDING.
THE SENATE APPROVED TEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND THE
ASSEMBLY APPROVED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
BOTH TO BE SPENT OVER THREE
YEARS.
FINANCE ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES
TO SUPPORT THEIR REAPPROPRIATION
AUTHORITY BUT NOT THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS PROPOSED BY THE ASSEMBLY
OR THE SENATE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON
ISSUE [inaudible]
FIFTY NINE HELLO [inaudible]
IT -- MISTER CARTY ASK YOUR
QUESTION ISSUE.
FIFTY EIGHT I JUST THOUGHT JUST
A COMMENT THAT -- AS YOU KNOW
MADAM CHAIR THAT.
WE SPEND MORE TIME INSPECTING
OUR NAIL SALONS AND SO FORTH SO.
I THINK IT'S ABOUT TIME WE GET
IN THE MODERN ERA AND FOCUS ON
OUR HEALTHCARE CENTERS
[inaudible]
HERE HERE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN WE'RE GOING
TO WRAP IT UP ON A NICE EVEN
ISSUE SIXTY THIS EVENING IF MR
TING SAID THAT HE TURNED INTO A
PARKING AFTER NINE O'CLOCK.
AND I DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT.
SO ISSUE SIXTY WILL BE OUR LAST
ISSUE FOR THIS EVENING AND WE'LL
PICK UP TOMORROW -- AT TWO PM.
WE CERTAINLY DID THANK YOU FOR
YOUR DILIGENCE COLLEAGUES.
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
ISSUE SIXTY CAL WORKS HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM ALEJO GOOD
EVENING JAZZ -- OF THE LA L. ON
THE GOVERNOR AND THE SENATE HAVE
NO PROPOSAL FOR THIS ITEM -- THE
ASSEMBLY DID APPROVE FOURTEEN
POINT SIX MILLION GENERAL FUND
ON GOING FOR THE COW WORKS
HOMELESS ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IN
ORDER TO ALLOW CAN'T HOMELESS
CAO WORKS FAMILIES. TO USE --
TEMPORARY HOUSING ASSISTANCE AS
PART OF THIS PROGRAM FOR SIXTEEN
CUMULATIVE DAYS IN ANY TWELVE
MONTH PERIOD WHEREAS UNDER
CURRENT LAW -- THE PROGRAM IS
AVAILABLE TO FAMILIES -- FOR
SIXTEEN CONSECUTIVE DAYS THIS
WOULD ADD SOME FLEXIBILITY IN
THE COW WORKS HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM.
THANK YOU FINANCE AND I TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE TYLER.
THANK YOU.
FINANCE HER WORDS WE SUPPORT THE
SENATE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WHILE THE AUTOMOTIVE.
MR TING HAS BEEN OVERRULED BY
HIS COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE ON ISSUE
SIXTY ONE CAN YOU GIVE ME A
WARNING THAT THE PUMPKIN WHAT
HAPPENS FIRST IS A STEM TALK
ABOUT.
TELL ME OKAY BUT NOT THIS
[inaudible]
ONE BACK UP.
ISSUE SIXTY ONE MINISTER OF
COSTS FOR CALPERS EXPANSION
ELLIE -- PLEASE. SIXTY ONE IS --
TRAILER BILL DIFFERENCE THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSED FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE
TIME FOR COUNTY HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS RELATED TO THE SSI
EXPANSION -- THAT'S A BY PRODUCT
OF ENDING THAT THE CASH OUT
PROGRAM SUCH THAT AS A SCIENCE
AS P. RECIPIENTS ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR COVERAGE BENEFITS.
ON THE SENATE ADOPTED THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AS IT THE
ASSEMBLY THE ASSEMBLY ALSO
INCLUDED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
DIRECTING THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES AND THE
ADMINISTRATION.
IN THE COMING YEAR TO UPDATE THE
BUDGETING METHODOLOGY USED IN
THE CAL FRESH PROGRAM -- RECENT
SIMILAR LANGUAGE HAS BEEN USED
IN THE COW WORKS PROGRAM AND THE
IDEA TO SENSE PROGRAM TO UPDATE
THE BUDGET A METHODOLOGY THAT
THE STATE USES TO DETERMINE HOW
MUCH COUNTIES WILL NEED TO FUND
OPERATIONS -- WE SEE THIS AS
GENERALLY CONSISTENT WITH THAT
ENDEAVOR TO UPDATE THESE THESE
BUDGETING METHODOLOGIES.
OKAY THE THE THE THE THE THE
WOULD BE TO UPDATE THE
METHODOLOGY FOR CAROL FOR ASH
FOR THE NEW ASSET FIVE
POPULATION OR CALPERS ACROSS THE
BOARD.
IT WOULD BE TO UPDATE THE
METHODOLOGY FOR THE ENTIRE CAL
FRESH HAN GRAHAM AND NOT
EXCLUSIVE TO THAT BASS AS I
EXPANSION TANK YOU THANK YOU
FINANCE.
THE ADMINISTRATION BOYS WE ALL
SHARE VERY SIMILAR OBJECTIVES
HERE SO WE ARE OPEN TO
COMPROMISE ON RESOLVING THIS
ISSUE OKAY WELL WE LOOK FOR TO
THE COMPROMISE OF ANY QUESTIONS.
FROM MEMBERS BEFORE WE SEE THAT
LANGUAGE THROUGH TO MORE LAW.
I THINK YOU TOUCHED ON IT MADAM
CHAIR BUT WHAT WILL BE THE
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT.
BY ONE ALL RIGHT NOW.
HELP.
YOU YOU'LL YOU'LL BE THE FIRST
DAY TAIL WHEN THEY FIGURED OUT.
KEEP WATCHING WHAT THAT'S RIGHT.
THAT'S RIGHT.
MOVING ON ISSUE SIXTY TWO SENIOR
ACCESS TO CAL FRESH LA JOH.
IN THIS ISSUE -- THE SENATE
APPROVED ONE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND AND ASSOCIATED
PLACEHOLDER TBL -- TO ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO
DESIGN A SIMPLIFIED APPLICATION
FOR CALPERS FOR SENIORS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES -- THE
STATE HAS UNDERTAKEN EFFORTS IN
RECENT YEARS TO SIMPLIFY THESE
APPLICATIONS AND THIS WOULD BE A
CONTINUATION OF THOSE EFFORTS
GOING FORWARD.
ON THE ONE THING WE WOULD NOTE --
THAT THE AGENDA ITEM DOES
MENTION THE INCLUSION OF
AUTOMATION AS PART OF THIS
PROPOSAL IN SUBSEQUENT
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THESE FUNDS WOULD BE USED.
FOR DESIGNING THAT THE PAPER
APPLICATION ITSELF NOT
AUTOMATION THE PAPER APPLICATION
IS NEEDED THEN IN THE FUTURE TO
TO BUILD THE AUTOMATION BUT IT
WOULD BE EXCLUSIVE TO THE DESIGN
PHASE AT THIS POINT.
I'VE BEEN A PART OF ANY NUMBER
OF ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM
APPLICATION SIMPLIFICATION.
THE MILLION DOLLARS I WAS JUST
STRUCK BY THE FUNDING LEVEL I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE SPENT A
MILLION DOLLARS TO SIMPLIFY THE
HEALTHY FAMILIES APPLICATION ALL
BE IT THAT WAS TWENTY YEARS AGO.
BUT FINANCE ANY COMMENTS YOU
HAVE.
AS LA -- MENTION DSS HAS BEEN
VERY ACTIVE ON THIS ISSUE IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS SO WE DON'T
THINK ADDITIONAL FUNDS ARE
NECESSARY.
INTERESTING OKAY ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS [inaudible]
SKINNER.
SO MY HEARING THAT WE'D BE ABLE
TO SIMPLIFY THE APPLICATION
WITHOUT PROVING SOME EXTRA MONEY
FILES FOR THANKS AND VERY WELL
THAT WOULD BE VERY IN FAVOR OF
THE SIMPLIFIED APPLICATION.
JUST HOLD IT OPEN IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY DO HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO GET IT DONE.
IN A REASONABLE TIME FRAME SORRY
TAIYO HER WORDS PER MINUTE
FINANCE I THINK WE'RE STILL
TALKING INTERNALLY ABOUT WHAT
THAT COST SO WHAT IT WOULD TAKE
ASSOCIATE WITH DECIDED.
RIGHT.
AND WE ALSO DO -- WILL MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S ADEQUATELY RESOURCE SO
THE SUPPLICATION HAPPENS WITHIN.
A REASONABLE TIME FRAME THANK
YOU SHORT EVEN YES THANK YOU
WILL THAT HAPPEN FILE ITEM OPEN
COLLEAGUES.
ISSUE SIXTY THREE THE PROTECTIVE
SERVICES IN PUBLIC ADMINISTRATOR
GUARDING CONSERVATIVE TRAINING
[inaudible]
HELLO.
THE STATE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
TRAINING AND IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN THE STATE DID PROVIDE
THREE MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO SPEND THAT COULD
BE EXPANDED OVER THREE YEARS FOR
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
TRAINING.
A PORTION OF THOSE FUNDS WERE
ALSO USED FOR A PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATOR GUARDIAN AND
CONSERVATORSHIP TRAINING AS WELL
THE FUNDING EXPIRES AT THE END
OF THIS FISCAL YEAR THE GOVERNOR.
DOES NOT PROBE -- INCLUDE ANY
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
INCLUDE ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING
MEANING THAT THE TRAINING
FUNDING LEVELS WILL REVERT BACK
TO THE PRIOR LEVELS WHICH WERE
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS.
GENERAL FUND ON BOTH HOUSES
APPROVED ADDITIONAL ONE TIME
FUNDING -- BUT DIFFERENT AMOUNTS
SENATE APPROVED FIVE POINT EIGHT
MILLION ONE TIME WHILE THE
ASSEMBLY APPROVED TWO POINT ONE
MILLION ONE TIME.
FINANCE IS ITEMS ARE NOT IN OUR
BUDGET.
OKAY I WOULD JUST SAY THAT ON
THE SENATE -- ACTUALLY THE PART
OF THE SENATE AGING PACKAGE AND
AS WE DISCUSSED EARLIER OUR OUR
COLLECTIVE CONCERN ABOUT.
THE DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
COMMUNITY I THINK ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES ANOTHER AREA
THAT I'M SURE MANY OF YOU HERE
IN YOUR DISTRICTS ARE ABOUT
SEVERE CONCERN ABOUT.
YOU KNOW THE PROTECTION OF OUR
AGING COMMUNITY AND MAKING SURE
THAT THERE ARE CONSERVATIVES IN
GUARDIANS THAT ARE THERE TO
PROVIDE PROTECTION SERVICES --
SO HOPEFULLY WE'LL BE ABLE TO
HAVE SOME CONVERSATION ABOUT
INVESTMENT IN THIS AREA.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
SIGNAL HOLE THAT ITEM OPEN ISSUE
SIXTY FOUR SS I SS P. GRANTS
ALEJO.
WAS IN A PROPOSED TO PROVIDE A
ONE TIME COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT TO THE STATE PORTION
OF THE EXERCISES BE GRANT WHICH
IS THE S. S. P. GRANT -- THIS
WOULD TAKE EFFECT JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY IT'S ESTIMATED
THAT THIS WILL RESULT IN ABOUT
FIFTY TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND
COST IN TWENTY NINETEEN THAT'S A
HALF YOUR ESTIMATE INCREASING TO
ABOUT. ONE OH TWO HUNDRED AND
TWO MILLION IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FOR YOUR COST THE ASSEMBLY
GOVERNOR HAD NO PROPOSAL.
FINANCE THIS ITEM IS NOT
CURRENTLY IN OUR BUDGET.
THANK YOU.
AGAIN THIS IS A CALL OF THAT WAS
SUSPENDED PERMANENTLY -- NUMBER
OF YEARS AGO ON AND THESE THESE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES FOR OUR OUR
MOST -- IT.
MEDICALLY FRAGILE IF YOU WILL.
FOR AN OLD -- HAVEN'T BEEN
ADJUSTED FOR COST OF LIVING AND
SO I HOPE IT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
POSSIBLY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MISS SKINNER THIS ECHO
THAT IT'S VERY SIMILAR TO ME. TO
ME AS OUR DISCUSSION AROUND THE
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED
POPULATION THAT [inaudible]
REALLY -- REALLY CANNOT AFFORD
TO LIVE ON WHAT'S PROVIDED AND
SO -- I SUPPORT A SUGGESTING
THAT COLA.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
CNN WILL HOLD THE ITEM OPEN
ISSUE SIXTY FIVE TRACKING OF
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT NEEDS AND
STRINGS THE CANS TOOLS
EXPENDITURE DELEO.
THE ISSUE SIXTY FIVE IS THE
DIFFERENCE IS A TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE DIFFERENCE THE GOVERNOR
PROVIDED A NINE POINT EIGHT
MILLION GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
COUNTIES AND THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE CHILD AND ADOLESCENCE
NEEDS AND STRAINS.
TOOL IMPLEMENTATION WHICH IS
PART OF THE CONTINUUM OF CARE
REFORM EFFORTS IT'S ONE TIME
FUNDING BOTH THE SENATE AND THE
ASSEMBLY ADOPTED THAT FUNDING.
THE ASSEMBLY ADOPTED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THE ADMINISTRATION TO WORK WITH
COUNTIES TO FIGURE OUT THE
ONGOING WORK LOAD AND COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH.
THE CONTINUED IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE CANS TOOL.
THANK YOU FINANCE WE BELIEVE
THAT CURRENT LAW SUFFICIENT TO
ACHIEVE THE GOALS -- SO WE
SUPPORT THE SENATE ON THIS ISSUE.
THE ROLE IN THAT I WILL OPEN.
ALL RIGHT ISSUE.
SIXTY SIX THE GOVERNOR HAD NO
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO THE TRANSITIONAL
HOUSING PLUS PROGRAM THE
ASSEMBLY APPROVED A MILLION
pAND PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING. TO SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
UP FINANCE MINISTRATION SUPPORTS
THE SENATE ON THIS ISSUE.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
HEARING NONE WILL MOVE TO ITEM
SIXTY SEVEN CHILD WELFARE PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSING PROGRAM DELEO.
YOU KNOW I AM A QUICKLY IF THE
LA OKAY PRESENT THE NEXT.
THREE IN A BUNDLE.
ALL SIXTY SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT AND
SIXTY NINE PER OUR PREVIOUS.
CONVERSATION WITH YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY HERE WE GO SO -- ITEM SIXTY
SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT AND SIXTY NINE
WHAT THEY HAVE IN COMMON THEY'RE
ALL -- AUGMENTATIONS PROVIDED --
BY THE ASSEMBLY BUT NOT THE
GOVERNOR THE SENATE THE FIRST
ONE IS EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ON GOING IN
PLACE HOLDER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE -- TO SUPPORT AT BAY.
TROUBLE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
NURSING PROGRAM -- IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
THE SECOND ITEM IS A FOUR POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND PROPOSAL ADOPTED BY
THE ASSEMBLY.
ON TO CREATE A TWO YEAR LEGAL
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM OUGHT TO BE.
OPERATED OUT OF DEPARTMENT
SOCIAL SERVICES CALLED THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
FELLOWSHIP -- ON THE FELLOWSHIP
NEWER ATTORNEYS WOULD BE PAIRED
WITH MORE EXPERIENCED
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEYS IN
GENERALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS OF
THE STATE OVER A TWO YEAR PERIOD --
IN ORDER TO IMPROVE -- LEGAL AID
REPRESENTATION CAPACITY IN THOSE
AREAS.
AND ITEM.
SIXTY NINE RELATES TO TO
ASSEMBLY PROPOSALS FOR A TOTAL
OF SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONE TIME.
ALSO ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES --
FOR TO USE THE CAN FAMILIES
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT -- NONPROFIT
UNDERTAKINGS -- THE DELORES
HUERTA FOUNDATION IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE MARTIN LUTHER KING.
JUNIOR FREEDOM CENTER ARE
COMBINED ONE OF THOSE PROPOSALS
AND THE THE SECOND PROPOSAL IS --
WITH THE INLAND CONGREGATIONS
UNITED FOR CHANGE IN THE
CEMETERY KNOWN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AREA.
EXCELLENT FINANCE ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORTS THE SENATE ON ALL OF
THESE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
NOTHING OKAY HEARING NONE --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
DILIGENT WORK EVERYONE THANK YOU
FINANCE IN LA -- FOR STICKING
WITH A WE GOT TROUGH OUR FIRST
PASS OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES.
WE WILL CONVENE TOMORROW AT TWO
PM.
OUR GOAL WILL BE TO COMPLETE OUR
FIRST PASS OF THE BOOKING GET
THROUGH BOTH.
PUBLIC SAFETY IN LABOR.
AND STATE ADMINISTRATION AND
GENERAL GOVERNMENT.
WE STAND ADJOURNED